THIS OF COURSE. GOOD
MORNING. WE GOING TO CALL ORDER
THE SO COMMITTEE ON RE
TRANSPORTATION THIS IS ASSEMBLY
SELECT COMMITTEE OF THAT HAS
BEEN TASKED WITH THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF LOOKING OUT
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
HOW BEST TO CONNECT COMMUNITIES
THROUGH A VARIETY OF A MODEL-
OPTIONS- WE HAVE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE IN THIS GREAT
COMMUNITY AND THERE ARE YOU FOR
A NUMBER OF TIMES SO THE LAST
WAS IN RANCHO CUCAMONGA. ALSO
WE ARE CERTAINLY ARE KEENLY
AWARE OF THE IMPORTANCE OF-
BRINGING UNDERSTANDING- TO
POLICIES THAT FOR ALL AROUND A
LOT OF IMPORTANT ISSUES BUT
CERTAINLY MOST NOTABLY
TRANSPORTATION AND HOW WE CAN
CONNECT COMMUNITIES AND CONNECT
REGION- I AM PLEASED TO HAVE
JOINED ME- NUMBER OF MEMBERS-
WHO AND WE HAVE MEMBERS A PART
OF THIS COMMITTEE THAT ARE
REPRESENT VARIOUS PARTS OF THE
STATE- BUT I AM PLEASED TO HAVE.
THIS MORNING AT I'M A WILL HAVE
OTHER JOIN US ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ WHO REPRESENTS
POMONA- AND- PORTIONS OF THIS-
COMMUNITY AS WELL AND- THE
GREAT SENATOR CONNIE LEIVA. IT
WAS ALSO MY FRIEND AND SOMEONE
WHO I TRULY RESPECT AND- AS A
AS A SENATOR IS NOT A PART OF
THE COMMITTEE BUT IS HERE IT
WILL HAVE ALL THE- PRIVILEGES
OF THE COMMITTEE IN TERMS OF.
THE NAME HAVING AN OPENING
STATEMENT AND- BEING FULL AND
GAZE AS AS A MEMBER WE HAVE
OTHERS WHO WILL JOIN WILL GIVE
THEM AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTICIPATE- AND HAVE AN
OPENING STATEMENT- WHEN THEY
ARRIVE. LET ME THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US TODAY FOR A TIMELY
DISCUSSION ON THE IMPORTANCE OF
INTERCONNECTED E. AND THE
DEVELOPMENT OF LONG LIFE LONG
TRANSIT RIDERSHIP. ON THE
FUTURE OF SUSTAINABLE
TRANSPORTATION. AS A FATHER OF
FIVE THERE'S NOTHING MORE. FOR
THEY- TURNING TO THE NAY YEAR A
FUTURE THAT IS BRIGHT AND THAT
HAS TAKEN HAS THE OPPORTUNITY
TO RECOGNIZE THE BENEFITS OF
WHAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO DO TO
TRY TO. CREATE A CLEANER
ENVIRONMENTALLY CORRECT
COMMUNITY AND WORLD. OF THAT IS
WHY THIS SELECT COMMITTEE ON
REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION
SOLUTIONS IS SO IMPORTANT. OUR
OUR JOB IS TO THINK ABOUT
SOLUTIONS THAT CONNECT REGIONS
OF OUR STATE. THROUGH
SUSTAINABLE TRANSPORTATION
METHODS CALIFORNIA'S NUMBER ONE
SOURCE OF GLOBAL WARMING
POLLUTION IS FROM OUR
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR. AND AS
MANY OF YOU KNOW IN THIS ROOM
TAKING BOLD STEPS IN OUR
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
IS THE BEST WAY TO CURB OUR
CARBON EMISSIONS AND MAKE OUR
COMMUNITIES SAFER AND HEALTHIER
PLACES. TO LIVE TODAY WE ARE
HERE IN THE BEAUTIFUL CITY OF
ONTARIO. AND HOME OF THE
ONTARIO INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT
AMONG OTHER IMPORTANT ARE
QUALITIES AND LANDMARKS. AS MY
PLEASURE AT THIS TIME TO
INTRODUCE THE MAYOR OF ONTARIO
POLLY ON. AND THE ONTARIO CITY
COUNCIL- AND RECEIVE THEIR
WELCOMING A TO THIS GREAT CITY
AND OFFERING US THIS COUNCIL
CHAMBERS WHICH IS STATE OF THE
ART OF FOR OUR HEARING TODAY.
AND MAYOR WILL TURN TO YOU FOR
A SOME OPENING COMMENTS AND-
YOUR WELCOMING. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AND CONTINUING WITH THE INTO
WERE HAVE OUR MEMBER ALLAN WHAT
IS HERE IT'S ALSO MEMBER CTA
AND OUR COUNCIL. RABEN VALENCIA
ALSO HERE AND I THINK THAT WERE
BROUGHT IT WILL BE SHOWING UP
AT SOME POINT WE ALSO HAVE OUR
CITY MANAGER MISTER SCOTT SHOW
IS STANDING IN BACK. ON ON
BEHALF OF THE ONTARIO CITY
COUNCIL I'D LIKE TO WELCOME
EACH OF YOU TO THIS MEETING-
WHAT IN AUGUST BODY WE WOULD
SAY. AS WE LOOK OUT AND THERE
ARE SO MANY OF YOU THAT ARE
ELECTED OFFICIALS AND- AND
DIGNITARIES FROM OUR REGION
THANK YOU FOR COMING. AND WE
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOLDEN FOR THE MEMBERS AND THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. FOR
GIVING US THE OPPORTUNITY TO
HOST TODAY'S HEARING ON
REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION.
BRINGING RAIL TO ONTARIO
INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT. IS
CRITICAL FOR THE CONTINUED
GROWTH AND DEVELOPMENT OF OUR
REGION. AS THE AIRPORT IS
ECONOMIC ENGINE DRIVING THE
INLAND EMPIRE. SO THE ONTARIO
AIRPORT GROWS AND SUCCEEDS. WE
ALL GROW AND SUCCEED IN THIS
REGION. AND SPEAKING THE
REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION LIGHT
RAIL IN PARTICULAR THE ONTARIO
CITY COUNCIL HAS BEEN A FIVE
OH. THE VOTE ADVOCATE FOR
EXTENDING THE GOLD LINE AS A
SEAMLESS TRANSFER
TRANSPORTATION FROM LOS
ANGELES. TO ONTARIO
INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT FOR MANY
YEARS. AND IS MORE THAN ABOUT
AIR TRAVEL IT'S ABOUT FREEWAY
CONGESTION. ABOUT AIR POLLUTION
CLIMATE CHANGE. FACTORS AND
MUCH MUCH MORE. AND WE MUST
PROVIDE CLEAN EFFICIENT AND
OBTAINABLE TRANSPORTATION FOR
ALL FOR THE FUTURE. I WHICH
OPENS THE DOOR ALSO FOR ALL
MODES OF LIFE RAILINGS DIEM.
AND OTHER. METHOD THAT WE WOULD
FIND TO SOLVE OUR- WITH AND- OF
IN CALIFORNIA. WE DON'T CLOSE
THE DOOR ON ANY IDEA. I BELIEVE
THOUGH THAT THE SEAMLESS GOLD
ROUTE CRITICAL. FOR THE
CONTINUED SUCCESS SOUTHERN.
EFFICIENT TRANSPORTATION. FOR
DECADES AHEAD IN THE QUALITY
IT'LL THE PEOPLE OF THE INLAND
EMPIRE. IN ORDER TO REVERSE IN
AND OUT. OF RESPECT. COUNTY IS
IT REGION FOR WORK PLEASURE AND
DOUBLE. WE CAN'T AFFORD TO WAIT
FOR PER WE NEED TO ACT OR BE TO
BE. US IN RE FOR. TOGETHER OUR
PARTNERS IN THE STATE. AND
NEIGHBORS NAY CITY AND THE SAN
FERNANDO COUNTY FRANCE FOR AT
THE- WE CAN BRING THIS RAIL
SERVICE TO FRUITION BUT WE MUST
ALL WORK TOGETHER WITH THE
CLEAR RESOLVE IN A COMMON
VISION. EVEN IF THAT VISION
INCLUDES ALL THESE ADDITIONAL
METHODS OF LIGHT RAIL AND
EFFICIENT TRANSPORTATION. SO I
THINK YOU FOR TAKING THE BOLD
STEP TO CREATE A NEW AUTHORITY
RESPONSIBLE FOR COMPLETING THIS
IMPORTANT PROJECT I UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE ARE SOME SUGGESTIONS
ON THE WAY TO ADJUST THE
LANGUAGE TO ENSURE THE NEW
AUTHORITY WILL HAVE WHAT IT
NEEDS TO BE SUCCESSFUL. AND I'D
LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR LEADING
THE WAY TO ENSURE THAT- ONE DAY
WE'LL ALL BE CONNECTED
INTERCONNECTED BY LIGHT RAIL IN
THIS REGION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MAYOR AND- THEN CERTAINLY
WE ARE HERE TODAY TO CERTAINLY
HAVE THAT AS A PART OF THE
CONVERSATION BUT WE ALSO WANT
TO FOCUS ON SOME OF THE LARGER
ISSUES IN ADDITION TO- RAIL AND
CERTAINLY REAL IS IMPORTANT AND
THERE ARE SOME THOUGHTS AND
IDEAS AND WE'RE COMING OVER
FOR. A COVERING A VARIETY OF
ISSUES TODAY BUT- WE DO THINK
THAT THAT IS THE CONTINUATION
OF THE PROJECT IS VERY
IMPORTANT AND CERTAINLY- WILL
HAVE FURTHER. DISCUSSIONS
AROUND THAT. AGAIN THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMENTS- LET ME JUST
SAY IN. A YEARS PASSED THE
SELECT COMMITTEE HAS HEARD.
EXPERT TESTIMONY ON THE
IMPORTANCE OF SECURING FUNDING
FOR INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS
AND THE IMPACT. BUT TRANSIT
CONNECTIVITY ON OUR
COMMUNITIES. TODAY WE WILL
EXPLORE THESE PAST THEMES ARE
CURRENT PLANS NEW IDEAS TO MEET
OUR CLIMATE GOALS AND THE
ADDITIONAL BENEFITS THEY BRING
TO IMPROVE PUBLIC HEALTH EQUITY
AND OUR ECONOMY. AS LEGISLATORS
IT'S OUR DUTY TO SERVE THE LONG
TERM INTERESTS OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS AND THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA PROVIDING
SUSTAINABLE TRANSPORTATION
OPTIONS. THAT JUST THE THAT
OPTIONS DOES JUST THAT BY ONE
CREATING EFFICIENT ALTERNATIVES
TO DRIVING AN INTERN REDUCING
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED TO
SUPPORTING TECHNOLOGIES THAT
REDUCE OUR DEPENDENCE ON DIRTY
FOSSIL FUELS THREE. HIGH
QUALITY TRANSIT OPTIONS REDUCE
PERSONAL VEHICLE TRAFFIC ON
ROADS AND HIGHWAYS AND IN TURN
MAKING OUR COMMUNITIES SAFER TO
NAVIGATE AND SHORTENING TRAVEL
TIMES WHEN DRIVING IS NECESSARY
FOR BOTH. TIMES IT ENSURE
AFFORDED AND ACCESSIBILITY TO
HIGH QUALITY TRANSIT MAKE
CERTAIN THAT NO ONE IN OUR
COMMUNITY IS BARRED FROM
EDUCATIONAL AND ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES. AND FIVE
PROMOTING THE DEVELOPMENT OF
ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE HELPS ENCOURAGE
COMMUNITIES TO ENGAGE IN ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION WALKING BIKING
FOR SKATEBOARDING WHICH IS A
SHOUT OUT TO THE MILLENNIALS.
ARE ALL THE- EMISSION TRANSFER
OPTIONS THAT CONTRIBUTE TO
IMPROVED PUBLIC HEALTH. SINCE
OUR LAST HEARING IN OCTOBER TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN FUNDING FOR
REGIONAL TRANSIT PROJECTS HAS
BEEN SECURED AND WE CONTINUE TO
MOVE TOWARD ACHIEVING OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS A NOTABLE
PROJECT AS THE MAYOR POINTED
OUT IS THE FOOTHILL GOLD LINE.
UNDER THE LEADERSHIP OF THE
FOOTHILL GOAL LINE REAL
AUTHORITY HAS SECURED FUNDING
TO REACH POMONA. ONE STEP
CLOSER TO THE PROJECTS TERMINUS
IN MONTCLAIR. ITS ROUTE ALONG
THE TWO TEN FREEWAY HAS CREATED
A VIABLE ALTERNATIVE TO DRIVING
THUS REDUCING CONGESTION IN
THIS CORRIDOR. THE GOAL LINE
HAS PLAYED A MAJOR ROLE IN
CONNECTING THE SAN GABRIEL
VALLEY TO THE REST OF LOS
ANGELES COUNTY AS OF DECEMBER
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN IT IS
ESTIMATED THAT THE GOAL LINE
SERVERS OVER FORTY THOUSAND
TRIPS PER MONTH. AS A GOAL LINE
EXTENSION PROJECT PRESSES
FORWARD TO MIND CLEAR BERIA'S
TO THE PROJECTS TIMELY
COMPLETION. HAVE PRESENTED
THEMSELVES. THE FOUR HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION SHORTFALL
FROM POMONA TO MY CLEAR POSES A
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGE. MY
DISTRICT ENCOMPASSES TWO
COUNTIES THE UNIQUE ISSUES
AROUND FUNDING A PROJECT THAT
CROSSES THE COUNTY LINE IS NOT
NEW TO ME. BUT IT IS NOT AN
ISSUE ONE COUNTY MUST FACE
ALONE. STATE FUNDING SOURCES
SUCH AS SOLUTIONS FOR CONGESTED
CORRIDORS PROGRAM WHICH IS
OUTLINED IN SB ONE AND THE
TRANSIT IN INNER CITY REAL
CAPITAL PROGRAM SUPPORTED BY G.
R. F. FUNDING COMBINED WITH
LOCAL FUNDING MEASURES PROVIDE
A PROMISING OUTLOOK. ON THE
FUTURE OF INTER COUNTY
CONNECTIVITY. IN A REGIONAL
CONNECTIVITY IS NOT ACHIEVED
OVERNIGHT. THOSE FAMILIAR WITH
THE GOAL LINE PROJECT KNOW THAT
IT HAS COME THIS FAR BECAUSE OF
COLLABORATION BETWEEN
POLICYMAKERS PLANNERS ADVOCATES
IN GOVERNING BODIES WE DID IT
BECAUSE WE SAID WE KNOW WE CAN.
MY COLLEAGUES AND I ARE
COMMITTED TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO GET THIS
CRUCIAL PROJECT COMPLETED. THE
GOAL LINE PROJECT PROVIDES A
PREVIEW OF A GREATER URBAN
PLANNING VISION FOR OUR REGION.
RAIL TO THE AIRPORT
CONNECTIVITY. BEFORE I INVITE
OUR FIRST PANEL THE TO BE
SEATED I'D LIKE TO OFFER MY
COLLEAGUES AN OPPORTUNITY TO
MAKE A FEW OPENING COMMENTS AS
WELL AND WITH THAT I WILL TURN
TO- MY A MEMBER OF OUR
COMMITTEE AND GOOD FRIEND A
SIMILAR RODRIGUEZ. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
WALKING ON TERRIO. AND THANK
YOU WELL YOU DON'T THE RECORD
BLANCA REGARD. SO IT'S GOOD
THAT YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
WELCOME ON TERRY WANTED TO THE
PAUL THE ON IN MAY OF THE FOR
HOSTING US TO. I'M GLAD THEY
WERE THIS SO COMMITTEE HERE IN
THE CITY OF TERROR WERE TRUMP.
INFRASTRUCTURE THE JUST PLACER
A VITAL ROLE AND HOW JOBS IN
THE CAR. EVERY YEAR SINCE I'VE
IN OFFICE I'VE BEEN HOLD
COMMITTEE. COMMUNITY COFFEES
ANY CITY A REP. THESE COUGH
PROVIDE ME WITH THE OP. TO
PROVIDE A- UP FROM IMPORTANT
THE OP. TO LISTEN TO IS THANK
FOR ARKANSAS. EVERY YEAR
THERE'S A- ONE TOP. AN ISSUE
THAT ALWAYS UP IN THIS
TRANSPORTATION. DOT IS WHY I'VE
AUTHORED A FEW OF. DEALING WITH
THE TERM OF THE GOAL LINE.
TRANSPORTATION A TOP ISSUE. BUT
MOST IMPORTANTLY HERE IN THE
INLAND EMPIRE WHAT WE HAVE MEGA
COMMUTERS WHO TRAVEL NINETY
MINUTES OR MORE FOR WORK
AFFECTING TRAFFIC
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE
ENVIRONMENT. THE INLAND EMPIRE
IS ALSO TRANSPORTATION
UPGRADING. CONNECTIVITY COUNTY
WIDE THROUGH THIS THROUGH THE
TENDENCY TO ROADWAYS AND
PLAYING THROUGH THE ON TERROR.
LOOK FOR TO THE THEME ACRE. OF
CAL FOR ALL THE FUTURE OF
SUSTAINABLE TRANSPORTATION AND
THE HEARING EACH OF THESE PET
CENTER TODAY ON HOW WE CAN WORK
TOGETHER. TOOK GREAT RESULTS
FOR THE TRANSPORTATION NEEDS
THE COMMITTEE THE INLAND EMPIRE
IN THE FUTURE THANK YOU AGAIN
CHAIRMAN FOR HOLDING US
TOGETHER IN THE PORT FOR A-
VERY INFORMATIVE DISCUSSION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR
REMEMBER- I MORE ALSO JOINED
BY- AN OUTSTANDING LEADER IN
THE INLAND EMPIRE OUR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ELOISE RACE IS ALSO A
MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE.
DELIVERY YES IF YOU LIKE TO.
HAVE A FEW COMMENTS Q. I WANT
TO START OFF BY THANKING OUR
CHAIR CHRIS HOLDEN. GREAT
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GREAT COLLEAGUE
I ALWAYS ENJOYED WITH HIM ON
THE ISSUES THAT AFFECT US.
ESPECIALLY HERE AS IN THE INTER
CONNECTIVITY THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT. NEVER TRY TO CONNECT ALL
OF CALIFORNIA BUT THE TRUTH IS
WE'RE JUST TRYING TO CONNECT
OUR TWO COUNTIES HERE. BOB THIS
IS THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
THERE ARE SOME. LOSE THAT
AFFECT SOME ISSUES IMPORTANT
ONE. CLOSE TO THE OTHER. BUT IN
THE. IT WE CAN AND- ALL OUR
FAMILIES TO DO TO GET TO WORK
TO GET SCHOOL. TO WHATEVER IT
IS NEED TO. BECAUSE WHEN WE'RE
TO ABOUT ACCESS TRANSFER. WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT FAMILIES. ARE
CONSTITUENTS IN THE TAXPAYERS
WHO WILL ALL BE AFFECTED BY THE
DECISIONS WE MAKE ARE LOOKING
TO US TO COME UP WITH THE RIGHT
DECISIONS. IT'S CRITICAL THAT
WE DISCUSS THE PLANS OF INTER
REGIONAL CONNECTIVITY AND
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES. AND
AS- IS THE CHAIR SAID IT'S
INTER COUNTY. IN ADDITION TO
THAT. WHAT WE DO WE MUST DO
WITH A SHARED VISION. A SHARED
VISION THAT IS VITAL TO
ACCOMPLISHING TRANSPORTATION
GOALS. AND LEVERAGING OUR
RESOURCES. TRAFFIC DOESN'T STOP
AT CITY BORDERS TRAFFIC DOESN'T
STOP AT COUNTY BORDERS. ARE
BUSES OR CARS BICYCLES
PEDESTRIANS AND IS THE CHAIR
SAID SKATEBOARDERS AS WELL ALL
TRAVEL WITHIN AND BETWEEN OUR
CITIES AND AS WE MOVE FORWARD
AND DISCUSS A RAIL CONNECTION
TWENTY AIRPORT WE MUST BRING
EVERYONE TO THE TABLE. AS WE
HAVE THESE DISCUSSIONS IT IS
CRITICAL THAT FOR ME THAT SB
CTA HAVE A SEAT AT THE TABLE. I
AM PLEASED TO SEE THE DOCTOR
RAY WOLF EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
BEST PC TA IS ON THE PANEL I
SEE OTHER FAMILIAR FACES LIKE
MY DEAR FRIEND PAUL GREANEY
OVER EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE INLAND
EMPIRE ECONOMIC PARTNERSHIP.
AND MY MAYOR DARCY MAGNA BOW
REALLY PLEASED TO SEE ALL OF
YOU HERE. I TRUST THAT WE CAN
ALL COME TO THE BEST SOLUTION
ONE THAT DOESN'T BURDEN. SORRY
SANDRA DINO COUNTY- AND OUR
TAXPAYERS AND ONE THAT WORKS
WITH OUR EXISTING
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY. IN
ORDER TO BE SUCCESSFUL A
RENEWED VISION FOR
TRANSPORTATION POLICY HOUSE TO
HAVE SUPPORT FROM ALL
STAKEHOLDERS TOGETHER I KNOW
THAT WE CAN FIND THE BEST
REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION
SOLUTIONS ESPECIALLY BECAUSE I
HAVE MY FAVORITE SENATOR. AND
MY FAVORITE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
RIGHT HERE SITTING. LOOKING FOR
THE SOLUTIONS FOR OUR INTER
REGIONAL. CONNECTIVITY THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU AND- AS
WAS HEADLINED- ARE WONDERFUL
SENATOR THAT THAT'S AND IS
GREAT I AND THEN WE'RE JUST
HAPPY THAT SHE'S HERE TODAY I
KNOW JUST SO YOU'RE AWARE THAT
THE SELECT COMMITTEE HEARINGS
ARE THEY COVER A VARIETY OF
SUBJECTS AND- WHETHER IN THE
SENATE SIDE OR THE ASSEMBLY
SIDE THERE CHAIRED USUALLY AND-
DISTRICTS ARE IN IN THE
COMMUNITY- BUT SOMETIMES A
SACRAMENTO. AND YOU CAN POP
INTO ANY ONE OF THEM AND YOU
MIGHT SEE ONE OR TWO OF MEMBERS
WHO ARE PARTICIPATING IN A VERY
IMPORTANT SUBJECT BUT HERE WE
OBVIOUSLY ARE OUT IN THE
COMMUNITY AND WE HAVE- FOR AND
PROBABLY WILL HAVE FIVE MEMBERS
WHO WILL JOIN US TO BE A PART
OF THIS CONVERSATION SO- WE'RE
IN YOUR WONDERFUL COMMUNITY
CENTER AND WE JUST WANT TO
WELCOME YOU A CENTER COUNTY
LEYVA FOR ANY COMES TO MIND.
THANK YOU SO MEMBER HELLO GOOD
MORNING IT'S JANUARY THIRTY
FIRST SO HAPPY NEW YEAR WE
CAN'T STATE AFTER TODAY TO
THOSE OF YOU WHO I HAVE NOT
SEEN I'M THRILLED TO BE HERE
THANK YOU FOR LETTING US CENTER
BE AN INTERLOPER HERE.
TRANSPORTATION THE ASSEMBLY
SAID IS THE NUMBER ONE. TO OUR
G. G. R. GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS HOW DO WE GET PEOPLE
OUT OF THEIR CARS AND GET THEM
INTO MASS TRANSIT HOW DO WE GET
THEM INTO RAIL- WE DO THAT BY
MAKING IT EASY BY MAKING IT
CONVENIENT AND BY MAKING IT.
AFFORDABLE SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE- THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CONVENING ALL OF US THIS IS A
SUBJECT THAT'S BEEN TALKED
ABOUT WELL BEFORE I WAS ELECTED
BUT I HAVE TO TELL YOU I BRING
YOU A LITTLE BIT OF HOPE-
SOMETIMES AS ELECTED OFFICIALS
WE WORK IN SILOS. BUT WE ARE
NOW REALLY BREAKING THOSE SILOS
DOWN I THINK IN SACRAMENTO. I
HAVE ONE CITY THAT'S IN LA
COUNTY THAT IS PROMOTED THE
REST OF MY CITIES ARE IN SAM
READY NO COUNTY. SO I ATTEND
THE LA COUNTY- CAUCUS MEETINGS
WE MEET ONCE A MONTH. AND WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT
REGIONALIZATION WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT WHAT WE JUST DO
IN LA WOULD WE JUST DOING SAM
RADIO BECAUSE WE KNOW. AS THE
ASSEMBLY WOMAN SAID IT DOESN'T
STOP TRANSPORTATION DOESN'T
STOP AT CITY BORDERS SO HOW DO
WE MAKE SURE WE'RE GETTING
PEOPLE FROM LA TO ST REDDING OF
FROM SOMEBODY YOU KNOW THE LA.
SO I'M THRILLED TO BE HERE VERY
EXCITED TO HEAR FROM ALL OF OUR
PANELISTS AND LIKE WE LIKE TO
SEE ON TEAM LEYVA WHEN WE WORK
TOGETHER WE WENT TOGETHER. SO
LET'S WORK TOGETHER. IT'S A
WHIRLWIND AGO. OUR EGGS. BUT
MEMBERS WE HAVE ENOUGH. TO
QUESTION. EACH PANEL. HAS SO.
THAT WILL BE HOW WE'RE PRETTY.
AND THEN WE WILL HAVE ALL THE
PANEL PRESENTATIONS AND THEN AT
THE END. WE WILL TURN TO PUBLIC
COMMENT. BEFORE INTRODUCED THE
FIRST PANEL LET ME JUST
RECOGNIZE AND I AND WE'RE-
STILL GATHERING- THE
INFORMATION ON THE ELECTED WHO
ARE HERE BUT THE ONES THAT I
HAVE IN FRONT OF ME RIGHT NOW I
WANT TO RECOGNIZE SUPERVISOR
JANICE RATHER FOR. HIS STAND
WHERE. THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
SAID SURPRISE. AMONG MAYOR JOE.
DOCTOR. TWO THREE JOHN. CHIANG
MARE. ELISE UNISOM SO YOU ALL.
HELLO FORMER CLEAR MY CITY
MEMBER SAM JOE'S. THE CURRENT
CITY COUNCIL A RES. AND MAYOR
OF THE CITY AGREE TERRACE STAR
SO MACRO. PENN WHO IS ALSO THE
CHAIR OF THE SB CT. WELCOME ALL
OF YOU. LET'S SEE DO SERVE PAN
IN THE FIRST PASS WE HE VIEWS
ON PROMOTE THE VAL OF RAIL TO
AIRPORT CONNECTED. AND LOCAL TO
USE ZERO IN REAL CARS WE'RE
PRIVILEGE TO HAVE ALAN HER. OF
THE IN AIRPORT ONTARIO CITY
COUNCIL MEMBER AND MEMBER OF
THE SB CTA. SO I'M ASSUMING
EVERYONE IS GOING TO PRESENT
FROM. THIS SECTION OVER HERE.
OKAY SO AS A CALL YOUR NAME
MAKE YOUR WAY TO THE- ALRP.
WE'RE ALL PLEASED TO HAVE
MISTER PAUL GREEN ARROW OF THE
INLAND EMPIRE ECONOMIC
PARTNERSHIP AND WHO WILL
PROVIDE A PERSPECTIVE ON THE
ECONOMIC BENEFITS OF LOCAL
ECONOMIES WHEN PEOPLE ARE ABLE
TO MOVE ABOUT MORE EFFICIENTLY.
AS THE CHIEF STRATEGY OFFICER
METROLINK MISTER TODD MCINTYRE
WILL DISCUSS THE IMPORTANCE OF
INTERNET INTERCONNECTED BODY
WITHIN FIVE COUNTIES I WILL
TOUCH UPON THE IMPACTS OF REAL
TO AIRPORT CONNECTIVITY A SCENE
WITH METRO LINK AND THE BURBANK
AIRPORT. AND DOCTOR RAY WILL
FOR PROVIDE AN UPDATE TO SB
CTA'S PLANNED PURCHASE OF ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES AND WE
WELCOME ALL. OF OUR PANEL
MEMBERS AND WE CAN BEGIN WITH
THE FIRST PERSON INTRODUCED.
AND WE WILL LET THAT- WILL JUST
FOLLOWING ORDERS YOU WERE
INTRODUCED- FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION SO WELCOME ALL.
THANK YOU ARE MISTER CHAIR
WELCOME TO ONTARIO GOOD TO HAVE
YOU HERE WELCOME TO OUR SENATOR
CONNIE LEIVA. AND OUR ASSEMBLY
MAN FREDDIE RODRIGUEZ HE COVERS
THE ENTIRE CITY OF ONTARIO TO
SEE NO MYSTERY HERE AND OF
COURSE IT'S ALWAYS GREAT TO
HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMORY AS WITH US
WE WORK TOGETHER QUITE A BIT-
IT I GUESS IF YOU IF YOU LOOK
AROUND THIS ROOM THE THING I'M
MOST EXCITED ABOUT. IS ALL
THESE FOLKS CARE ABOUT ONTARIO
AIRPORT DASHES GREAT THAT'S
WHAT WE WANT TO SEE. AND I
THINK WE CAN ALL START ON THE
SAME LEVEL THAT WE ALL WANT TO
SEE TRANSIT AND RAIL BROUGHT TO
THE AIRPORT. AND THAT'S PRETTY
MUCH THE ATTITUDE THAT WE ARE
TAKING FROM THE AIRPORT- ALL
REEMPHASIZE WHAT ARE MAYOR
STATED IS THAT OUR COUNCIL IS
ON RECORD UNANIMOUSLY
SUPPORTING THE GOAL LINE. AND I
HAVE TO ALSO SAY PERSONALLY
SUPPORT THE GOAL LINE HAS THIS
PC T. IS ALWAYS SUPPORTED THE
GOAL LINE. AND I CAN TELL YOU
ABOUT THIS P. C. TA THAT IF
THEIR GOLD LINE WORTH COUNTING
ON WE ARE PREPARE TO BRING IT
TO MONTCLAIR SO THAT'S NEVER
BEEN. ANY ANY KIND OF POINTED
DISCUSSION. HAVING SAID THAT
THOUGH IT'S IMPORTANT FROM THE
AIRPORT PERSPECTIVE- ARE BACKED
UP TO THE SECOND. OUR
COMMITMENT TO THE COMMUNITY THE
CITY AS WELL AS THE AIRPORT HAS
ALWAYS BEEN THAT WILL GROW THE
AIRPORT AS LONG AS IT DOESN'T
IMPACT THE QUALITY OF LIFE FOR
THE FOLKS THAT LIVE IN THIS
COMMUNITY. WHEN I TALK ABOUT
THIS COMMUNITY IT REALLY MEANS
THE ENTIRE. REGION HERE. AND
WHAT THAT MEANS IS WE- HAVE. AN
ALLEY ACTS HAPPEN. WE CANNOT
TRY TO BE. A TRANSFERRED. IN AT
THE HARD IS ALREADY OCCURRED.
WE'VE GOT TO HAVE THE AND- IN.
PRIOR TO THE GROWTH OF THE
AIRPORT. RIGHT NOW WE'RE AT
FIVE AND A HALF MILLION
PASSENGERS WERE PROBABLY GOING
TO GO TO THIRTY OR THIRTY FIVE
MILLION PASSENGERS. AND LESS IT
IMPACTS THE QUALITY OF LIFE OUT
HERE. NOW WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
INTER CONNECTED READY. FOR US
IT'S MUCH LARGER THAN LOS
ANGELES AND SALMON TO DO NO
COUNTIES ARE CATCHMENT AREA
INCLUDES A SANKEY REBELLION LA
COUNTY. IT INCLUDES RIVERSIDE
COUNTY AND INCLUDES ORANGE
COUNTY. AND WE'RE WORKING WITH
RIVERSIDE IN ORANGE COUNTY TO
DEVELOP CONNECTIVITY AS WELL
USING RALPH. SO IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR US TO REACH ACROSS ALL THE
COUNTY LINES. ALL OF THE FOLKS
IN THIS ROOM AND I KNOW ALL THE
MEMBERS ON THIS COMMITTEE.
HELPED US TREMENDOUSLY IN BRING
IN LOCAL CONTROL TO OUR AIRPORT
SO I KNOW THAT THE SUPPORT IS
THERE FOR THAT. FROM THE
AIRPORTS PERSPECTIVE WE WANT
REAL TO THE AIRPORT. IF WE CAN
GET THE GOLD LINE THERE GOD
BLESS THAT IS GREAT WILL
WELCOME IT WITH OPEN ARMS. BUT
WE ALSO HAVE TO HAVE OTHER
OPTIONS AVAILABLE IF THAT
DOESN'T HAPPEN AND WE CAN'T
WAIT. TO SEE WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN WITH THE GOAL OF MINE.
AND SO FROM S. B. C. T. A AND
BY THE WAY ONCE AGAIN I'M SO
EXCITED. THAT THE C. T. A. B.
L. E. METRO AND CERTAINLY OUR
STATE LEGISLATURE. HAVE STEPPED
UP. TO SUPPORT US AND EVEN TAKE
THE LEAD ON PROVIDING RELAXES
TO THE AIRPORT I THINK
EVERYBODY RECOGNIZES HOW
IMPORTANT THAT IS. TO BE HONEST
WITH YOU A LONG TAMI WHAT THAT
ARE WHICH IS GOING TO BE A
FIGHT FOR THE AIRPORT IN THE
CITY. AND LOOK AT ALL THIS HELP
THAT WE'RE GETTING SO I YOU
KNOW I'M LOOKING AT THE
POSITIVES. AND WE HAVE TO LOOK
AT ALL THE OPTIONS THAT WE HAVE
AVAILABLE TO DELIVER. TO THE
AIRPORT IN AN EFFICIENT
ENVIRONMENTALLY- SHAPE.
ECONOMICAL WAY. ON WHATEVER WE
CAN DO TO BRING FOLKS TO THE
AIRPORT TO THE CAN UTILIZE IT
MORE CAN. THAT.
EIGHT FROM IS A
RIP. AS CTA AND WE'RE TO HEAR
FROM. WALL WE'VE BONTA OFF A
TO. AN WE'VE IMPLEMENTED THAT A
READY YOUR- WHERE THE FACT THAT
SB C. T. IS FOR SUPS. LIFT RIDE
FROM ANY OF THE MEASURE ST. IN
THE- FOR MONTHS. UPLAND RANCHO.
AND ONTARIO EAST. THAT'S THE
FIRST PHASE. IN AN- BEFORE TOOK
WILL CAN. L. A. D. NOT ALLOW
ANY. ON POOR ARE ON THE TRAIN
SYSTEM WITH FORCED TO DROP. OFF
ON THE OUTER. AND THEN TAKE A-
TO AIRPORT. SO ON THE DAY THAT
WE TO CONTROL OMNITRANS BEGAN
FIFTEEN MINUTE HEADWAYS INTO
BOTH TERMINALS. SO WE BEGAN OUR
TRANSIT AT THAT POINT TWO TO
CONTROL WE'RE NOW DO CONNECTIVE
ITTY THE METROLINK WRITER. IN
WILL PROBABLY GO TO WILL. JUST
LIKE THE DAY ANOTHER. OAKLAND
EXAMPLE AND THEN IN WHAT THE
SAME TIME WE'RE GONNA BE. ON A
REAL CONNECTION NOW I KNOW YOU
CAN SEE ON THE MAP UP HERE THAT
THE JURY'S OPTION AVAIL AND I
THINK THAT CALL WAS ALL GOING
TO TALK ABOUT STUDY. THAT WE
DID AT SKAGGS THE TALKS ABOUT
THE VARIOUS WAYS TO CONNECT LA
WITH ON SUMMER TO DO NO
COUNTIES. BUT YOU CAN SEE THE
MANY OPTIONS THAT ARE. SURE
TALK ABOUT THE GOAL MINE IN MY
HAVE OFF TO THE LINE FOR UNDER.
YOU YOU CAN TRAVEL IN. IN THE
WORLD AND PEOPLE KNOW ABOUT THE
GOAL LINE. REALLY I MEAN EASY
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHERE YOU ARE
THEY MAY NOT KNOW WHAT THE GOAL
LINE IS BUT THEY KNOW THAT
THERE'S A GOLD MINE. SO
CERTAINLY THE GOAL LINE HAS
ALWAYS BEEN IN THE PLAN FOR
ACCESS TO THE AIRPORT AND IT'S
STILL THERE. HAVING SAID THAT
WE'RE ALSO LOOKING AT THE
POTENTIAL SPUR BETWEEN RANCHO
CUCAMONGA AND THE AIRPORT- THE
TECHNOLOGY. IS WE'RE GONNA LOOK
AT IT WE'RE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
MAYBE THE BORING TECHNOLOGY.
THAT I MISTER MUSKIES USING IT
COULD BE A PEOPLE MOVER WE'RE
NOT QUITE SURE WHAT IT IS-
WE'RE ALSO LOOKING AT THE
POTENTIAL FOR THE FIRST TIME.
AT USING THE EL HAMBRE
SUBDIVISION. NO THAT REAL IS
THE ONE THAT'S CLOSEST TO THE
AIRPORT. THE WOOD STICKLE
PROBLEM WE HAVE IS THAT THE
CHAIRMAN INDIAN METROLINK LINE.
IS NORTH. AND THE ROOM THE
RIVERSIDE LINE OF THE ONTARIO
STE. IS ALSO THE YEAR REPORTS
WHICH REALLY DIFFICULT TO.
THOSE TO THE PATH. AREA THE
HAVE SUB. IT RIGHT THE YEAR.
WEEK COMES UP OF AGREE AND- IT
DOESN'T MATTER WHICH TECHNOLOGY
WERE YOU. PLEASED OF THE RIGHT
OF WILL BE THE DELIVER. RIGHT
TO THE- ARE STARTING. THE AS
WELL CORE IS C. T. DEVELOP IS
FOR LIGHT RAY SYSTEM. IN
REDLANDS PASSED RAIL REDUCING
ON THE- COME ON A MISSION.
SYSTEM USING- GM YEARS ZERO
MISSION UNITS IN THAT TEN
REDLANDS AND CERTAINLY THERE'S
AN EFFORT THAT COULD BRING THAT
ACROSS FROM THE EAST TO THE
WEST- AS I MENTIONED WE'RE
WORKING WITH ORANGE COUNTY NOW
THAT'S GOING TO DELIVER. REAL
FROM THE ORANGE COUNTY ARCTIC.
TO YEAR. TO A REALLY LOOKING AT
ALL THE END WE'RE LOOKING FOR
THE AT THE AIRPORT IS WHEN WE
BUILT TERM THREE WHICH KNOW IS
IN THAT SPACE BETWEEN. TWO AND
FOUR. WE WANT A REAL DELIVERED
TO THE IN THE TERM. TIME THAT
THE LIST STEP WILL BILLS. THE
WORLD IS. AND HAVING THAT
DIRECT CAN. TO COM. AND THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR. SO
AGAIN I THINK ALL OF YOU FOR
YOUR INTEREST. I THINK AGAIN IF
WE ALL START WITH THE PROMISE
THAT WE WANT REAL ACCESS TO THE
AIRPORT AND WORK FROM THAT
FORWARD. AND WILL BE ABLE TO
SUCCEED THE AIRPORT IS A LARGE
ECONOMIC GENERATOR. AND IN CASE
YOU'RE NOT A WERE THE ONLY
UNCONSTRAINED AIRPORT IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. WHICH
MEANS IN THAT PHYSICAL OR
POLITICAL WHICH MEANS THAT ONCE
ALL THE OTHER PORTRAIT CAPACITY
WHICH THEIR NEARLY THERE. ON
KERRY'S ONLY PLACE THAT CAN
HELP THE ENTIRE REGION OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA NEEDED
DEVIATION NEEDS. AND SO BECAUSE
OF THAT. PEOPLE THROUGHOUT
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EXTREMELY
INTERESTED IN THE SUCCESS OF
ANTERIOR PORT AND WE CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR INTEREST.
THANK YOU MISTER. THANK YOU.
ALL. REPORTER MISTER A SURE
ENOUGH OF THE COMMITTEE FOR OUT.
HE'LL BE WHATEVER PARTNERSHIP
WHY DON'T. THE AND SHE SAID
THAT I TO WEAR GLASSES WHEN I
DO YOU CAN PRESIDENT. PAGE THAT
I WANT TO YOU YOUR STAFF FOR
NAY THIS HEARING. SO IF YOU
LOOK AT THIS SLIDE IT REMINDS
US THAT THE INLAND EMPIRE'S
POPULATION HAS ALMOST DOUBLED
IN THE LAST THIRTY YEARS. WE'RE
ON TRACK TO REACH MORE THAN SIX
MILLION PEOPLE BY TWENTY FORTY.
THE NEXT SLIDE. TALKS TO US
YOUR BACK ON THE- SO SINCE THE
RECESSION THE NUMBER OF JOBS IN
THE INLAND EMPIRE HAVE
INCREASED BY NINETEEN POINT 1%
SURPASSING CALIFORNIA'S JOB
GROWTH OF TWELVE POINT 8% AND
THE U. S. IS JOB GROWTH OF NINE
POINT 6% THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
I DON'T THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE
APPRECIATE SINCE THE GREAT
RECESSION IT IS THE INLAND
EMPIRE THAT HAS BEEN THE NUMBER
ONE JOB CREATOR IN THE UNITED
STATES. THE USE OF THE ONTARIO
AIRPORT HAS INCREASED TO MORE
THAN FIVE POINT FIVE MILLION
PASSENGERS IN TWENTY NINETEEN
IS PROJECTED TO SURPASS THIRTY
MILLION BY TWENTY THIRTY FIVE.
YET ACCESS TO THE AIRPORT HAS
ACHIEVED ALMOST EXCLUSIVELY BY
PASSENGER VEHICLES. THE
METROLINK PROVIDE SERVICE FROM
RIVERSIDE THE CARRIES
PASSENGERS INTO ONTARIO BUT
DOES NOT DELIVER THEM DIRECTLY
TO THE TERMINAL AREA AS WELL
AS- TO- THE- METROLINK LINE
FROM A UNION STATION- TO SAN
BERNADINO. TO ACCOMMODATE THE
PROJECTED GROWTH NOT JUST AT
THE AIRPORT BUT IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO
INVEST IN PUBLIC RAIL
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEMS THE CAN
TRANSPORT PEOPLE FROM ALL OVER
THE REGION. TO AND FROM THE
AIRPORT QUICKLY. CITIES WITH
AIRPORT RAIL LINKS HAVE BEEN
SHOWN TO BE MORE PRODUCTIVE
THAN THOSE WITHOUT- AIRPORT
RAIL LINKS CAN BE A CATALYST
FOR WIDER ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT.
I WANNA STOP HERE AND PAINT A
PICTURE THAT I THINK IS REALLY
IMPORTANT- ABOUT THE INLAND
EMPIRE. SO WE ARE VERY CLOSE TO
THE AIRPORT AND SO IF WE DRIVE
BEG CIRCLE AROUND US RIGHT NOW
TWENTY FIVE MILES OUT I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT- SOME OF THE
POPULATION THAT EXISTS OKAY SO
PRETTY MUCH. HOW THERE'S TWO
MILLION PEOPLE THAT LIVE WITHIN
TWENTY FIVE MILES OF THE
AIRPORT. AND IF YOU GO SOUTH OF
THE AIRPORT POMONA AB GOES
POSTS THAT SOUTH AND NORTH OF
THE TENT. BUT IF WE START IN
SOUTH POMONA IN POMONA CITY OF
A HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO
THOUSAND HOMES HUNDRED FIFTY
THREE THOUSAND. CHINO HILLS
SEVENTY SEVEN THOUSAND CHINO
EIGHTY THREE THOUSAND. CORONA A
HUNDRED AND SIXTY ONE THOUSAND-
RIVERSIDE- THREE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND- AND- MORENO
VALLEY TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND. SO
PRETTY MUCH SOUTH OF THE
AIRPORT A MILLION PEOPLE OKAY A
MILLION PEOPLE NOW LET'S TURN
AROUND AND START ON NORTH RIGHT
SO YOU BEGIN TO TALK ABOUT THE
CITY OF REDLANDS SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND- HIGHLAND- SAMPRADAY
NO TWO HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN
THOUSAND- ONTARIO A HUNDRED AND
SIXTY NINE THOUSAND FONTANA TWO
HUNDRED AND FIVE THOUSAND-
RIALTO- HUNDRED IN TWO
THOUSAND- ALL THE WAY BACK
RANCHO CUCAMONGA. ON'T AND
THEN- AGAIN BACK TO POMONA
ANOTHER MILLION PEOPLE. AND SO
I REALLY URGE- YOU- AS WE DEAL
WITH THIS ISSUE TO TAKE THAT
INTO TO HEART. THERE ARE
ANOTHER TWO POINT FIVE MILLION
PEOPLE THAT LIVE OUTSIDE OF
THAT TWENTY FIVE MILES- SO FROM
PARIS DOWN TO THE MENIFEE
VALLEY AND TO MARIETTA AND
LOOKED AT AND- TEMECULA- OUR
FRIENDS IN THE HIGH DESERT OUR
FRIENDS IN THE COACHELLA VALLEY
OUR FRIENDS IN THE MOUNTAIN
AREAS. SO RAIL AND TRANSIT
ACCESSIBILITY TO THE AIRPORT IS
ABSOLUTELY A KEY ECONOMIC
DRIVER FOR THE FUTURE OF THIS
REGION. ARE BUSINESS MEMBERS-
WOULD- TELL YOU THAT THERE'S AN
URGENCY TO THIS THEIR ABILITY
TO CONNECT TO THE AIRPORT THEIR
ABILITY TO BRING- PEOPLE INTO
THE AIRPORT TO DO BUSINESS
ABSOLUTELY KEY. SO DELIVERY OF
WHATEVER OPTIONS WE HAVE THE
SOONER THE BETTER. AND ALSO I
THINK THAT PART OF THAT FROM
THE FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF OUR
MEMBERS AGAIN WHO ARE THE
LARGER EMPLOYERS OF THE REGION-
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T HAVE
TOO MUCH BUREAUCRACY. RIGHT IT.
TRANSIT AND TRANSPORTATION
INVESTMENTS ARE EXPENSIVE AND
SO THE MORE THAT WE CAN DO THAT
WITH AN EXISTING- AGENCIES- I
THINK ARE BUSINESS MEMBERS
WOULD SAY THAT THAT'S THAT'S
BEST. TALK ABOUT THAT TWENTY
FIVE MILE CIRCLE- COUNSELING
WAPNER- TALKED ABOUT- AS SOME
OF THE ISSUES- THE PARISH
SCHOOL BOARD IS TWO MILES SOUTH
OF THE AIRPORT TWO MILES SOUTH
THAT HAS POTENTIAL CONNECTIVITY
TO RIVERSIDE AND EVERYBODY
GOING THAT WAY WHAT IT IS THE
SOLUTION FOR THAT TWO MILES- I
THINK WE NEED TO LOOK AT- THE
GREAT- POTENTIAL OF THE- THE
ERRO- SYSTEM- GOING IN FROM-
SAMBAR DINO TO REDLANDS- AND
THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE THE
FIRST EVER IN THE NATION ZERO
EMISSION- TRANSIT OPPORTUNITY-
TO THE NORTH OF THE AIRPORT.
AND THEN FIGURING OUT AGAIN HOW
WE CONNECT- THAT SYSTEM TO THE
AIRPORT AS WELL AS AS THE GOLD
MINE. AS YOUR EXAMINE OUR WAYS
TO ACHIEVE RAIL- TO THE
AIRPORT- I URGE YOU TO CONSIDER
THE LARGER REGION- HOW DO WE
PROVIDE THAT ACCESS TO SAN
BERNARDINO TO CORONA TO CHINO.
TO THE HIGH DESERT TO MACULA
AND THE COACHELLA VALLEY'S. WE
SHOULD ALSO SEEK TO AVOID
DUPLICATING EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE. INSTEAD WE
SHOULD FOCUS ON WORKING
TOGETHER WITH THE RELEVANT
AGENCIES IN ORDER TO ACHIEVE
THE GOAL OF A MORE CONNECTED
REGION I THINK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ON TOP
MCINTYRE CHIEF STRATEGY OFFICER
FOR METROLINK PRESENTING ON
BEHALF OF OUR CEO STEPHANIE
WEEK INTO SINCE OUR REGRETS SHE
CANNOT MAKE IT TODAY. WE WANTED
TO TALK A BIT IF WE GO TO METRO
LINK SYSTEMS AND- REITERATE
WHAT I BELIEVE ALL OF YOU HAVE
SHARED WHICH IS THAT OUR SHARED
GOAL IS TO DO OUR BEST AND
PROVIDE AS MANY ALTERNATIVES
TO. PRIVATE AUTOMOBILES AS
POSSIBLE. METROLINK DOES THAT
MEASURE LIKE HELPS US TO
ACCOMPLISH THE STATE'S
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED
REDUCTION GOALS. AND TO CONNECT
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
OPPORTUNITIES- TO HOUSING AS WE
KNOW THAT PEOPLE ARE THE OLD
ADAGE IS DRIVE TO QUALIFY THERE
ARE NOW WRITING TO YOU QUALIFY
ON THAT FEELING SERVICES. OUR
SYSTEM MAP I THINK IT SHOWS
REALLY THE GREAT INTER REGIONAL
CONNECTIVITY- OF THE METROLINK
SYSTEM. FIVE OF THESE COUNTIES
INCLUDING SAMBAR DINO IN IT LOS
ANGELES COUNTY ARE I REMEMBER
AGENCIES IN FUNDING AGENCIES WE
ALSO SERVICE SIX COUNTY OF SAN
DIEGO COUNTY. WE CONNECT A LOT
OF PEOPLE TO A LOT OF JOBS. ARE
AVERAGE RIDER- OVER THAT FIVE
HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT MILES
SYSTEM. GOES APPROXIMATELY
THIRTY SIX MILES ONE WAY. 60%
OF OUR WRITERS ACROSS THE
COUNTY LINE. TODAY WE KNOW THAT
85% OF OUR WRITERS ALSO OWN A
CAR. SO THEY ARE CHOOSING TO
TAKE METROLINK SERVICE AND
THEREFORE REDUCING
APPROXIMATELY NINE POINT THREE
MILLION CAR TRIPS PER YEAR- AS
OF FY NINETEEN. THE CEO VISION
HERE IN ORDER TO CONTINUE TO
GROW AND- ENHANCE METROLINK
SERVICE IS ONE THAT FOCUSES
FIRST AND PRIMARILY ON THE
CUSTOMER. TO GET PEOPLE TO GET
ON THE SYSTEM WE KNOW IT HAS TO
BE SEAMLESS AND EASY AND WE
DON'T NEED TO MAKE THEM PLAY
DETECTIVE IN OUR TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO USE IT. AND SO. WE HAVE-
INITIATED A FEW KEY. STRATEGIES
LIKE A WIFI PILOT TESTS. OVER
TEN YEARS. WIFI IMMUNITY WAS
THE MOST REQUESTED IMMUNITY ON
THE METROLINK SERVICE. AND IN
NOVEMBER WE INITIATED THE FIRST
TEST. WITH EIGHTEEN T. AND WE
WILL BE INITIATING ANOTHER
TEST- WITH SPRINT AS A CARRIER.
TO IDENTIFY WAYS FOR US TO
BRING AMENITIES LIKE THAT.
WITHOUT INCREASING THE COST TO
OUR MEMBER AGENCIES IMPORT. AN
INTEGRATED SYSTEM IS REALLY KEY
AND WE KNOW THAT THERE WILL BE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR
COMPLEMENTARY- USES AND
APPROACHES BETWEEN A METROLINK
GOAL LINE AND THE FIFTY ONE
OTHER TRANSIT OPERATORS THAT WE
ALLOW TRANSFERS TO THIRTY TWO
OF THOSE FREE TRANSFERS. AND WE
RECOGNIZE ALSO THAT WE ARE A
TECHNOLOGY COMPANY WE'RE
MODERNIZING OUR BIG BUSINESS
PRACTICES IN WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF POSITIVE
TRAIN CONTROL- WE HAVE TO LOOK
AT HOW WE DELIVER SERVICE AND
THE OPERATIONS OF OUR SYSTEM
DIFFERENTLY THAN WE HAVE IN THE
PAST INCREASING THE TECHNOLOGY-
IN THE LAST TEN YEARS WE'VE
GONE FROM THE INITIATION OF
SMARTPHONES TO EVERYONE HAVING
ONE IN THEIR POCKETS TODAY.
NEXT SLIDE HAS OUR RIDERSHIP
METRICS WHICH SHOW THAT OVER
THE LAST FIVE YEARS WE HAVE
SEEN CONTINUOUS RIDERSHIP
GROWTH- PEAKING ARE EXCUSE ME.
CAPPING IN FY NINETEEN ELEVEN
POINT NINE MILLION TRIPS TAKEN
WHICH IS A RECORD OF OUR TWENTY
SEVEN YEARS OF SERVICE. THE
GREATEST GROWTH WE'VE SEEN HAS
BEEN OFF PEAK AND WEEKEND
SERVICE- AND A LOT OF FAMILIES
TAKEN THAT SERVICE- IN LINE
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER PRESS
COMMENTS. WE WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THAT THE METROLINK SYSTEM TAKES
APPROXIMATELY TWO LANES OF
PARALLEL CAPACITY HIGHWAY
CAPACITY OFF OF THE HIGHWAYS.
WE ALSO SHARE YOUR VISION FOR A
SUSTAINABLE AND HEALTHIER
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. WE ARE
TAKING DELIVERY OF FORTY TEAR
FOR AND THAT'S THE EPA
DESIGNATION HIGHEST.
CLASSIFICATION OF CLEAN DIESEL
TECHNOLOGY AND THEY'RE
REPLACING OUR OLDEST FLEET AND
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS BY UP 285% FROM THAT
FLEET WE ALSO IN- PARTNERSHIP
WITH OUR MEMBER AGENCIES HERE
SB CTA LOOKING AT ZERO
EMISSIONS TECHNOLOGY AND-
LOOKING AT HOW CAN WE ACTUALLY
RETROFIT SOME OF THOSE OLD
DIESEL LOCOMOTIVES ARE COMING
OUT OF SERVICE. WITH SOMETHING
LIKE BATTERY ELECTRIC OR
HYDROGEN TAXI REDEPLOY THEM AS
PART OF A ZERO EMISSIONS FLEET
AS WELL. WE TALKED ABOUT IT
TRACKING A RETAINING WRITERS A
COUPLE OF THINGS I'D JUST LIKE
TO HIGHLIGHT IS FOR THE FIRST
TIME WE HAD A FREE FAIR DAY. ON
EARTH DAY WE SO I 48% RIDERSHIP
INCREASE ON OUR SYSTEM. MORE
SIGNIFICANTLY THAN THAT THOUGH
WE SAW A SIGNIFICANT INCREASE
IN THE DOWNLOAD OF OUR MOBILE
APPS WHERE PEOPLE CAN EASILY
BUY TICKETS FOR THEIR FAIRS.
AND A PROXY NINETY FIVE
THOUSAND NEW RETURNING RIDERS
AS A RESULT OF THAT. I
MENTIONED THE TEST PILOT AND
IN- KEEPING WITH THE HOLIDAY
SPIRIT THAT WERE COMING OUT OF.
A WE HAD A NEW APPROACH TO
HOLIDAY TRAINS AND WE ACTUALLY
RAN FOR DIFFERENT HOLIDAY
TRAINS AT A VERY AFFORDABLE
PRICE BETWEEN DOLLARS PER
PASSENGER THEY WERE SOLD OUT.
AND WE HAD A LOT OF FAMILIES
AND GREAT RECEPTION AND
RESPONSE TO THAT AND EXPECT TO
EXPAND THAT INTO THE FUTURE. ON
THE NEXT SLIDE A REGIONAL
CONNECTIVITY- A LOT HAVE
ALREADY TALKED ABOUT THE
ONTARIO AIRPORT REDLANDS
THEREFORE WE ALSO HAVE TO-
STATIONS FOR METROLINK AT THE
HOLLYWOOD BURBANK AIRPORT. AND
WE AGREE THAT WE ARE LOOKING TO
WORK WITH OUR PARTNERS TO STUDY
HOW. WE CAN PROVIDE MULTIPLE
OPTIONS TO GET TO THE DIFFERENT
AIRPORTS THROUGHOUT OUR REGION
INCLUDING ONTARIO. NEXT I'D
LIKE TO JUST SHOW A- BRIEF
VIDEO THE SCORE OR SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA OPTIMIZE RAIL
EXPANSION PROGRAM AS OUR TWO
BILLION DOLLAR PROGRAM THERE
REALLY WANTS TO- SEEKS TO
EXPAND AND ENHANCE OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE AND SERVICES. TO
REALLY MAKE US A PREMIERE
OPERATOR BY THE TIME THE
OLYMPICS ARRIVE- AND PART OF
THAT PROGRAM FOR INSTANCE ARE
LIKE THE LILACS RIALTO DOUBLE
TRACK PROJECT- THAT IS
CURRENTLY IN OUR TRANSPORTATION
AS YOU TRANSIT INTERCITY
PASSENGER RAIL- APPLICATION
WITH THE STATE. EACH DAY AS THE
SUN BEGINS TO RISE OVER
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA OVER TWENTY
ONE MILLION PEOPLE ARE COMING
IN GO. WHETHER THEY'RE HEADING
TO SCHOOL WORK OR A BALL GAME
METROLINK PROVIDES PEOPLE A
CONVENIENT STRESS FREE AND
GREEN WAITED TROUT. WE MUST DO
MORE IN ORDER TO SERVE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA'S GROWING POPULATION
AND MEET THE STATE'S AMBITIOUS
GOALS TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE
GASES AND IMPROVE ACCESS TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. METRO LINK
HAS AN AMBITIOUS CAPITAL
IMPROVEMENT PLAN TO UPGRADE ITS
SYSTEMS SO THAT THE REGION GETS
MORE. AND JUST IN TIME FOR THE
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT OLYMPIC AND
PARALYMPIC GAMES WITH OUR
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA OPTIMIZED
RAIL EXPANSION PROGRAM FOUR
SCORE WITH STORE. THE REGION
GETS MORE. SCORE WILL CREATE A
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM THAT
SEAMLESSLY CONNECTS OUR JOB
CENTERS TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND WILL HELP LOCAL BUSINESSES
GROW AND THRIVE. THE STORE ALSO
PROVIDES MORE SAFE RELIABLE
TRAINS. INFREQUENT SERVICE THAT
MEANS THE GIRLS ONE DIRECTION
DURING PEAK COMMUTE TIMES TO
SERVICE THAT RUNS REGULARLY
THROUGHOUT THE DAY IN BOTH
DIRECTIONS. MORE JOBS AND
ECONOMIC GROWTH THROUGHOUT THE
REGION MORE CLEAN AIR BECAUSE
WHEN MORE PEOPLE WRITING
NATURALLY MORE CARS ARE PARKED
WHICH REDUCES TRAFFIC AND
EMISSIONS ON THE MAJOR FREEWAYS
TO CHANGE INTO THE METRO LINK
SYSTEMS. STORE INCLUDES OVER
TEN BILLION WORTH OF. PROJECTS
IN GRADE CROSSING THAT IN TEN.
AND ALLOW CITIES TO LIVE.
SIGNAL IMPROVEMENTS THAT
STREAMLINED. TRACKING THAT WILL
RESULT IN FEWER DELAYS AND MORE
SERVICE WHEN THERE'S DEMAND AND
FUNDING WORKED IT WILL LOOK AT
SALARY PROGRESS TOWARDS OURS
ZERO EMISSIONS FUTURE. A STUDY
BY THE LOS ANGELES ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION
ESTIMATES THAT SCORE WILL
CREATE OVER ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND JOBS BEFORE THE TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHT OLYMPIC AND
PARALYMPIC GAMES AND OVER A
THIRTY YEAR PERIOD THIS STUDY
FORECAST APPROXIMATELY ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION JOBS AND SIX
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS IN GROSS REGIONAL
PRODUCT WILL BE ADDED TO THE
ECONOMY THROUGHOUT OUR FIVE.
COUNTY SERVICE AREA METROLINK
DOES MORNING TENANTS FROM POINT
A TO BE IT. SAYS AS A COMMUNITY
IN SO MANY WAYS. FROM YOUR HOME
TO YOUR CAREER FROM YOUR
FRIENDS IN THE VALLEY TO YOUR
FAMILY AND RIVERSIDE OR TO THE
BEACHES AND VENTURA LA AN
ORANGE COUNTY COAST LINE. FOR
YOUR HEALTH AND FOR THE HEALTH
OF OUR PLANET. NATURALLY RIDES
WITH YOU. FIND OUT HOW YOU CAN
GET MORE WITH SCORES AT
METROLINK TRAINS .COM FORWARD
SLASH SCORE.
ALL RIGHT AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
ATTENTION AND JUST I'LL JUST
CONCLUDE WITH THE FINAL SLIDE
WHICH IS SHOWS THE ECONOMIC.
IMPACT IN BENEFIT OF THE SCORE
PROGRAM BY COUNTY- IN TERMS OF
GDP AND JOB CREATION SO WE
INTEND TO CONTINUE TO GROW THE
BENEFITS OF METRO LINK AND
DOUBLE OUR RIDERSHIP IN THE
NEXT FOUR YEARS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING- CARE
HOLDEN MEMBERS OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS RAY WOLF
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
SAMBAR DINO COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK IN FRONT OF THE SYSTEM
PANEL THIS MORNING IF I COULD
JUST DIGRESS BRIEFLY CHAIR
HOLDING YOU TALKED ABOUT
SKATEBOARDING AND MILLENNIALS
IN YOUR INTRODUCTORY COMMENTS-
I WOULD SUGGEST JUST LOOKING
AROUND THE ROOM AND I MEAN NO
OFFENSE- THAT MOST OF THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE PRESENT HERE
THIS MORNING OUGHT NOT TO TRY
TO RIDE SKATEBOARDS. I PROVIDE
A LIVING TESTIMONIAL TO THAT-
AND WITH THAT I'LL I'LL MOVE ON.
SO I WANT TO FOCUS MY COMMENTS
AND PRIMARILY THIS MORNING ON
THE EXCITING PILOT THAT WE ARE
PARTNERING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE TRANSPORTATION AGENCY
THAT IS TO INTRODUCE THE FIRST
SELF POWERED ZERO EMISSION
PASSENGER TRAIN IN THE UNITED
STATES AND QUITE POSSIBLY IN
NORTH AMERICA WE COLLEGE EMAIL
I THINK THAT'S KIND OF A COOL
NAME. THE VEHICLE CAN OPERATE
ON EXISTING RAIL INFRASTRUCTURE
INTERMINGLED WITH HEAVY FREIGHT
AND HEAVY PASSENGER RAIL SUCH
AS WHAT METROLINX OPERATES
TODAY WE WERE ALREADY PLANNING
TO BRING THE DIESEL VERSION OF
THIS VEHICLE TYPE INTO SERVICE
WITHIN THE NEXT COUPLE OF YEARS
ON A NINE MILE EXTENSION OF THE
METROLINX AND WITHIN A LINE
FROM DOWNTOWN SAMBAR TO DO YOU
KNOW PROPER THE UNIVERSITY
EDMUNDS AND IT WAS REALLY NOT
PROJECT THAT SPURRED OUR DESIRE
TO LOOK FLOOR CLEANER
TECHNOLOGIES GIVEN THE THREAT
OF THE VEHICLE THAT WE WERE
OPERATING. WE SIGNED A
CONTRACT- LOOKED ADLER A SWISS
RAIL CAR MANUFACTURER- JUST IN
THE MIDDLE OF NOVEMBER OF LAST
YEAR A TO BUILD THAT FIRST
PILOT VEHICLE AND WE EXPECT
DELIVERY THAT VEHICLE TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR JUST FOR YOUR YEAR
AWAY SO I THINK THAT'S A IT.
AND I HOPE THAT YOU SHARE WITH
ME THE EXCITEMENT THE WE ARE IN
A LEADING HERE IN SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY IF WE COULD
GO TO THE NEXT SLIDE JUST A
COUPLE OF QUICK SLIDES HERE-
THIS JUST KINDA SHOWS THE
ACTUALLY GO BACK ONE I'M SORRY
THIS SHOWS SORT OF THE INSIDE
OF THIS NEW VEHICLE THAT'LL BE
OPERATIONAL- IN OUR COUNTY
WITHIN A FEW YEARS AND ONE OF
THINGS I WANT TO POINT OUT IS
THE LUGGAGE RACKS- THAT THERE
OF THE SEATS THESE ARE NOT ONLY
IMPORTANT FOR PEOPLES- YOU KNOW
WHATEVER THEY'RE CARRYING WITH
THEM- IS ARE MOVING FROM
COMMUNITY TO COMMUNITY- BUT
COULD ALSO BE VERY IMPORTANT
THE LONELY TALK ABOUT A RAIL
CONNECTION. TO ENTER THE WINNER
TIONAL AIRPORT WE CAN SO. THIS
SLIDE HERE JUST HOME IN AND IN
THE VEHICLE THAT WILL OPERATE.
THAT WILL HAVE ROOM FOR BY BUT
THAT CAN ALL. ADD ADDITIONAL
CAPACITY OF FOR LUGGAGE WHICH
IS GOING TO BE IMPERATIVE FOR
ANY CONNECTION THAT WE
ULTIMATELY BRING INTO THE
AIRPORT PROPERTY. AND WE COULD
GO TO THE NEXT SLIDE PLEASE
TRANSITIVE REALLY ABOUT
CONNECTING PEOPLE AND PLACES IN
A CONVENIENT MANNER. AS
DEPICTED ON THIS SLIDE EASY
CROSS PLATFORM CONNECTIONS ARE
POSSIBLE. WITH THE Z. MOVE-
CONNECTING TO OTHER TRANSIT
SYSTEMS THROUGHOUT THE REGION
NOT UNLIKE WHAT MORE MATURE
SYSTEMS IN THE UNITED STATES
EUROPE AND ASIA PROVIDE TODAY.
AND THE LAST LINE PLEASE I HOPE
THAT- AGAIN THAT YOU SHARE WITH
US THE EXCITEMENT- THAT WE ARE
SHEPHERDING THIS NEW
REVOLUTIONARY TECHNOLOGY- HERE
ON AMERICAN SHORES. IN CLOSING
I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE A BRIEF
MOMENT TO ADDRESS THE DOG IT
CONCERNS OF SOME WHO ALLEGE
THAT WE AT SPC TA OR I
PERSONALLY OPPOSE THE GOAL
LINE. THAT IS NOT TRUE AS PART
OF THE LARGER METRO LIGHT RAIL
NETWORK THE GOAL LINE PROVIDES
AN IMPORTANT CHOICE AS WE'VE
ALREADY HEARD THIS MORNING FOR
COMMUTERS AND OTHERS TO AVOID
OUR CONGESTED FREEWAYS IT'S
CONNECTIVITY TO MULTIPLE
TRANSIT SYSTEMS THROUGHOUT THE
LOS ANGELES REGION IS EXACTLY
WHAT WE SHOULD BE STRIVING TO
ACCOMPLISH. MY COMMENTS AT THE
SPC T. A BOARD OF DIRECTORS
MEETING LAST SEPTEMBER WERE
SIMPLY THAT I WOULD BRING
FORWARD A RECOMMENDATION TO THE
BOARD TO LOOK AT COST EFFECTIVE
ALTERNATIVES NOTING THAT THERE
WAS ANOTHER WAY TO PROVIDE
HIGHER FREQUENCY SERVICE USING
EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE. THE SB
CTA BORDERS ALLEN MENTIONED HAS
BEEN CLEAR IN ITS SUPPORT OF
THE GOAL LINE TO MONTCLAIR
PRIOR TO AND SUBSEQUENT TO THAT
SEPTEMBER MEETING. MY COMMENTS
WERE SPURRED BY THE NEED TO
ADDRESS TRANSIT ORIENTED
DEVELOPMENT NOT ONLY IN THE
CITY OF MONTCLAIR. BUT ALSO IN
RANCHO CUCAMONGA AND OTHER
COMMUNITIES CURRENTLY SERVED BY
THE SAMBAR DINO METROLINK LINE.
FUNDS FOR TRANSIT INVESTMENT IN
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE ARE
SCARCE IN OUR COUNTY AND SO WE
MUST MAKE JUDICIOUS DECISIONS
TO SERVICE THE GREATEST EXTENT
OF OUR POPULATION. MY COMMENTS
WERE INTENDED TO START A TOUGH
CONVERSATION AND THEY CERTAINLY
HAVE. MY JOB IS TO ADVISE THE
SB CTA BOARD OF OPTIONS
ALLOWING THEM TO MAKE EDUCATED
DECISIONS AND THEN MY JOB IS TO
IMPLEMENT THOSE POLICY
DECISIONS. THAT IS ALL I HAVE
DONE THANK YOU AND I WELCOME
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU AND WE
DO APPRECIATE- EACH OF YOU
MAKING. A PRESENTATION I THINK
WAS VERY- THOUGHTFUL AND HAD
SUBSTANCE BEHIND IT AND- MET
OUR SEVEN MINUTE TIME FRAME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I'M GOING
TO TURN TO MY COLLEAGUES- THE
TO SEE IF THEY WOULD LIKE TO
INITIATE ANY COMMENTS OR OR
QUESTIONS BASED ON THE FOR
PRESENTATIONS- I JUST HAVE A
FEW WILL COMMENT THAT'LL MAKE-
BUT ALL YOU'LL TO THEM AT THIS
POINT. SENATOR QUESTION. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU ALL
EXCELLENT PRESENTATIONS I
ENJOYED HEARING ABOUT ALL OF
THEM I'M GONNA START WITH JUST
A COMMENT- AND THOSE OF YOU WHO
WERE WITH ME AT THE- ON TERRIO
CHAMBER MEETING BEFORE THIS
HEARD ME SAY THAT WHEN I WAS
ELECTED OUR ELECTED OFFICIALS
DID NOT WORK WELL TOGETHER AND
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M VERY PROUD TO
SAY THAT ALL OF THE ELECTED
OFFICIALS IN THE INLAND EMPIRE
WORK VERY WELL TOGETHER AND
WHEN WE WORK TOGETHER GOOD
THINGS HAPPEN SO I'M GOING TO.
CHALLENGE OUR TRANSPORTATION
GROUPS TO WORK BETTER TOGETHER.
AND ALL OF YOU KNOW THIS
BECAUSE I HAVE SAID THIS TO ALL
OF YOU PRIVATELY BUT I'M GOING
TO SAY IT. PUBLICLY WHEN YOU
CAN'T PUT US IN THE MIDDLE YOU
KNOW YOU DON'T LIKE THIS YOU
DON'T LIKE THIS AND EVERYBODY
WANTS THEIR OWN THING. WE NEED
TO COME TOGETHER I'VE HEARD SO
MANY GOOD IDEAS ON BOTH SIDES.
METRO METROLINK GOLDLINE BUT WE
CAN'T CONTINUE TO OPERATE IN
SILOS OF FOR ACTUALLY GOING TO-
BENEFIT ALL OF THE PEOPLE THAT
WE REPRESENT. SO I'M GOING TO
CHALLENGE ALL OF YOU TO DO WHAT
WE HAVE DONE A SELECTED AND
LEARN TO WORK TOGETHER. BUT
WITH THAT- I WANTED TO ASK-
MISTER WALKER- WHAT YOU THINK
THE BEST OPTION IS FOR
CONNECTING RESIDENTS TO THE
AIRPORT. WHICHEVER ONE WE CAN
GET BUILT. REALLY WE HAVEN'T
REALLY WORKED- COMPARE THE
OPTIONS BECAUSE THE ABOVE SO
QUICKLY YOU KNOW IT WEEK AS FAR
AS THE GOLD ONE CONNECTION TO
THE AIRPORT THAT HAS NEVER BEEN
PLAN AND IT'S NOT FUNDED AND
THAT'S THE BIGGEST PROBLEM WE
HAVE AND I WAS REALLY HOPING
YOU GUYS FOR COMING WITH A
CHECKBOOK. BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT
IT'S GONNA TAKE FOR ANY OF
THESE PLANS TO HAPPEN. SO AT
THIS POINT AGAIN THE AIRPORTS
PERSPECTIVE IS IT DOESN'T
MATTER WHICH ONE OF THESE WORK
AS LONG AS IT WORKS IN A SERVER
HERE PORT NESTERS THE FOLKS
THAT WE SERVE. SO I'M SORRY
SHOULD I CAN'T GIVE YOU A
SPECIFIC ANSWER BECAUSE- WE'RE
NOT SET AND ANYONE OF THE
OPTION TO REALLY OPEN TO ANY OF
THEM. OKAY THAT'S GREAT THANK
YOU I DO HAVE MY PERSONAL
CHECKBOOK BUT I DON'T THINK IT
GETS US WHERE. THIRTY AND THEN
YOU PS IS DOING GREAT WORK IN
EXPANDING THEIR AT THE AIRPORT-
AND I'M JUST CURIOUS WHAT THE
PLAN IS TO MITIGATE THAT
TRAFFIC BECAUSE I'M SURE
THERE'S GOING TO BE. MUCH MORE
TRAFFIC ONCE IT'S BUILT HAVE
YOU GUYS THOUGHT ABOUT THAT.
THANK YOU SENATOR AND I'M GLAD
YOU BROUGHT THAT UP BECAUSE WE
CAN TALK ABOUT THE CARGO AND OF
THE AIRPORT. WHICH IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT. RESPONSIBLE FOR TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF JOBS IN THE
AREA- OBVIOUSLY YOU PS HAS HUGE
PRESENCE BUT MORE EXCITING THE
IS FED EX. IS NOW IN THE
PROCESS OF BUILDING. A HUB FOR
FED EX. IN FACT FOR THE FOLKS
HERE IN THIS YEAR YOU CAN BE
VERY PROUD TO KNOW. THAT OUR
AIRPORT IS NOW THE NUMBER ONE-
AIRPORT FOR OUTGOING CARGO WE
OVERTOOK ATLANTA AIRPORT A FEW
MONTHS AGO. BUT THE QUESTION IS
AGAIN OUR COMMITMENT TO THE
COMMUNITY TO NOT MEDIC NOT NOT
IMPACT THE COMMUNITY IN A
NEGATIVE MANNER. SO WE
ACTUALLY. PRIOR TO ALL OF THIS
GROWTH WE RECEIVE FEDERAL
FUNDING TO CREATE A GROUND
ACCESS PROGRAM. SO WE HAVE A
BROWN ACCESS PROGRAM NOT
NECESSARILY JUST FOR CARGO.
THERE'S IMPROVEMENTS BE MADE
AND GROVE AVENUE WE'RE LOOKING
TO CHANGE THE INTERCHANGE OF
THE TEN FREEWAY GROW SO CLOSE
ALL THE WAY FROM THE TEN. TO
THE SIXTY WITH EXPANDED
CAPACITY FOR CARGO AND WE'RE
GONNA HAVE A SPECIFIC CARGO
CIRCULATION PLAN. IN AND ON THE
AIRPORT GROUNDS ITSELF. VERY
GOOD THANK YOU IT'S VERY
HELPFUL FOR METROLINK. I KNOW
THAT- LA METRO HAS INFUSED
MONEY TO REDUCE THE FARES FOR
WRITERS IS THAT IN PERPETUITY
OR DOES THAT COME TO AN END AT
SOME POINT YES THAT SAY
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN SB CTA AND
LA METRO THAT HELP TO REDUCE
MAYORS IN OF THE THIS A TEST
PERIOD FOR ABOUT THREE YEARS.
THREE HALF YEARS HOW FAR INTO
THE THREE YEARS OUR WAY ONE ONE
OKAY SO TWO YEARS AND THEN
YOU'LL REEVALUATE YES OKAY VERY
GOOD THANK YOU. DOCTOR WOLFE I
AM JUST CURIOUS- HAVE YOU IN SB
TEETH CTA HAD ANY DISCUSSIONS
IN REGARD TO CONNECT TO THE
AIRPORT AND THE CHALLENGES THAT
YOU FORESEE GETTING THERE. WE
CERTAINLY HAVE THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION CENTER THAT WE ARE
ACTUALLY GOING TO OUR BOARD IN
TWO SHORT WEEKS- TO COMMITTEE
ACTUALLY- WITH A SCOPE OF WORK
THAT LOOKS AT AND ALLEN WALKER
HAD HAD A GENERAL MAP UP THERE
THAT LOOKS AT MULTIPLE OPTIONS
OF CONNECTING TO THE AIRPORT.
OUR GOAL IS TO COMPLETE- AND
ALTERNATIVES ANALYSIS- THAT
BUILDS ON WHAT'S GAG IS DONE IN
THE PAST WHAT WE HAVE DONE IN
THE PAST AND OTHERS- SO THAT WE
CAN START THE ENVIRONMENTAL
WORK WITHIN THREE SHORT YEARS.
BECAUSE WE RECOGNIZE AS ALAN
POINTED OUT OF THE SIGNIFICANCE
OF THE TIMELINE THAT WE HAVE
THAT WE FACE THERE AT FIVE
POINT SIX MILLION ANNUAL
PASSENGERS TODAY THEY'RE GONNA
HIT THIRTY MILLION IN IN VERY
SHORT ORDER AND SO WE'VE GOT TO
DO SOMETHING NOW AND NOT WAIT-
OUR GOAL WE DON'T HAVE THE
MONEY IN OUR CURRENT MEASURE TO
BUILD THIS CONNECTION. BUT THAT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT WE SHOULDN'T
PUSH THE ENVELOPE AS MUCH AS WE
CAN AND THEN WE WILL BE COMING
UP AND POUNDING ON YOUR DOORS
AND SACRAMENTO WITHIN A FEW
SHORT YEARS LOOKING FOR THE
MONEY- THAT WE CAN. START TO
CONSTRUCT THIS PROJECT I THINK
THAT WE CAN START CONSTRUCTION
AND TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN FOR A
RAIL CONNECTION WHATEVER THAT
IS FOR A RAIL CONNECTION
ONTARIO INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT.
BUT WE'RE GONNA NEED YOUR HELP.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU A I THINK
CAN SEE FOR MY- AND PRY MY
COLLEAGUES WE STAND READY TO
HELP- TO MAKE SURE THAT
HAPPENS. I THANK YOU TO THE
WHOLE PANEL VERY HELPFUL THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU. THIS RACE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. JUST ONE COMMENT
AND I'D LIKE TO- ASSOCIATE
MYSELF WITH MANY OF THE
COMMENTS FROM MY EYES STEAMED
SENATOR IS THAT WE'RE LOOKING
AT DIFFERENT DIFFERENT
ALTERNATIVES WE KNOW WE WANT TO
CONNECT TWENTY AIRPORT I THINK
EVERYBODY AGREES WITH THAT- I
THINK HAVE COMING UP WITH THE
ALTERNATIVE THAT YOU ALL THINK
IS THE BEST THEN ALLOWS US TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH WHATEVER IT
IS WE NEED TO DO TO HELP YOU
WITH THE FUNDING. BUT THAT'S A
VERY IMPORTANT STEP IN YOU ALL
ARE THE EXPERTS SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO MEETING YOU AT THAT
POINT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE THEN
TAKE CARE OF EVERYTHING ELSE
THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE BECAUSE
WE DO WANT THAT CONNECTIVITY TO
THE AIRPORT ESPECIALLY BEFORE
THE OLYMPICS I THANK YOU ALL
FOR THE PRESENTATION AND I
REALLY LOOK FORWARD TO KNOWING
WHAT. THE GREAT MINDS DECIDE IS
THE BEST SOLUTION FOR THAT
THANK YOU. THE YOU AGAIN ARBOR
FOR THEIR PRESENTATIONS IT'S-
COMMON THEME I'M HEARING AS WE
NEED TO WORK TOGETHER. SOLVE
THESE ISSUES AND LIKE THE
CENTER SAYS THE MORE WE WORK
TOGETHER WE WENT TOGETHER. A NO
I'M JUST LOOKING BACK AT AT-
WHAT I'VE BEEN TRYING TO WORK
ON WITH THIS PROJECT EVER SINCE
I GOT ELECTED IN. THE ELECTION
IN TWENTY THIRTEEN TWENTY
FOURTEEN. HI ONE OF MY FIRST
BILLS AB TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY
FOUR. WAS THINKING THAT THAT
EXTENSION FROM. MONCLER INTO
THE AIRPORT AND SEEM LIKE BACK
THEN. THERE ARE SOME HESITATION
PEOPLE DON'T REALLY WANT TO
WORK WITH ME I THINK. SOME
FOLKS IN THE ROOM HERE WERE IN
MY OFFICER AN AUNT AND CHINO WE
HAD THAT DISCUSSION SEEM LIKE
BACK THEN THERE'S PUSH BACK. OF
THE GOAL LINE FOR SOME REASON I
DON'T KNOW WHERE SO IT'S LIKE
THIS IS BEEN AN ONGOING ISSUE.
HOW BEST TO GET THE GOAL LINE
TO THE AIRPORT WORKING TOGETHER
AND NOW WE'RE PRESENT HERE WERE
OUT THAT WE'RE STILL HAVING
SOME. OF YOUR COLOR PUSH BACK
OR HESITATION WHAT NOT. LET'S
TRY TO MAKE SURE WE CAN GET ON
THE SAME PAGE BECAUSE LIKE SAID
IT'S A SOMETHING. FROM MY
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE. BACK IN
LEX'S TWENTY FOURTEEN WITH. MY
BILL I'M SURE YOU'LL PROBABLY
FIND OUT THERE- A. B. TWENTY
FIVE SEVENTY FOUR. IT WAS KINDA
LIKE NOT THAT STUDY HOW HOW
WOULD IT LOOK LIKE EXTENDING
THE GOAL LINE FROM MONTCLAIR.
INTO THE AIRPORT AND NOW FAST
FOR TORE AT NOW WE'RE LOOKING
AT OTHER ALTERNATIVES BUT-
LET'S MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
REALLY TALKING ABOUT WORKING
TOGETHER OR NOT. YOU KNOW
DIVIDING ONCE. ONE ANOTHER
FROM. ULTIMATELY THE GOAL OF
CONNECTING THE AIRPORT TO OUR
COMMUNITIES. AND REALLY HELPING
OUR FAMILIES AND THE BARMAN AND
EVERYTHING THAT COMES WITH
THAT. SO JUST A COMMENT I
WONDER ST THANK YOU ALL FOR
BEING HERE AS WELL. THANK YOU I
WOULD JUST ADD TO THAT I THINK
THAT A AND- TO NOTE THAT AS
RELATES TO THE GOAL LINE. YOU
KNOW IT'S A PROJECT THAT'S BEEN
UNDER WAY FOR. DECADES AND
WE'RE ON THE CUSP OF HAVING THE
PROJECT- MAKE ITS WAY TO AN END
TO- THE SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY.
SO I THINK ONE OF OUR
CHALLENGES AND OBVIOUSLY PART
OF THE CONVERSATION WITH THE
CENTER AND OTHERS SENATOR AND
OTHERS HAVE. ARTICULATED IS
WE'RE BRINGING IN A LOT OF
PEOPLE FROM OF THE WESTERN SAN
GABRIEL VALLEY COMMUNITIES. OF
THAT UTILIZE THE AIRPORT AND-
CERTAINLY SUPPORT THE COMMUNITY
AND DOLLARS SPENT AND SO I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ
POINTED OUT WE NEED TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO. MAKE THAT LINK
COMPLETE BUT IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT. MANY OF
THE PLANS THAT YOU TALKED
ABOUT- IN TERMS OF SORT OF
INTEGRATING THE ENTIRE- INLAND
EMPIRE. INTO THE AIRPORT MAKING
CONNECTION REAL CONNECTIVITY IS
CRITICAL AS WELL SO I I'M YOU
KNOW I JOIN WITH. MY COLLEAGUES
TO SAY THAT. SO WE WILL BE A
PARTNER AND CONTINUING TO
FIGURE OUT WAYS TO- INSURE THAT
THE GREATER SAN BERNARDINO
RIVERSIDE COUNTY AREAS ARE
BEING ABLE TO LINK TO. A
RESOURCE THAT IS NOT JUST FOR
SAMBAR INYO COUNTY BUT
CERTAINLY AS OF A DRIVER OF
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AS WELL AS
CREATOR OF. OPPORTUNITIES FOR
INTERNATIONAL TRAVEL AND AS
SOMEONE WHO LIVES IN PASADENA
AND LOS THE IDEA OF- DRIVING TO
LA ACTS AND BEING A PART OF
THAT- NETWORK OF PARKING AND
GETTING TO TERMINAL- I THINK WE
ALL RELISH THE OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE A CLEANER SAFER WAY TO
TRAVEL TO AN INTERNATIONAL
AIRPORT AND I THINK THAT. THIS
DYNAMIC NEEDS TO WE NEED TO TIE
UP THE LOOSE ENDS ON THAT. BUT
JUST BE ONE DOLLARS. PEOPLE
THROUGHOUT. VOTERS THROUGHOUT-
THE SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY THE
INLAND EMPIRE SUPPORTED. AND IT
IS OUR JOB TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE FAIR SHARE OF DOLLARS MAKE
THEIR WAY INTO IMPORTANT
PROJECTS- IN THE IN THE
COMMUNITY AND SO. THIS
CONVERSATION AND OTHERS THAT
WILL FOLLOW HELP US GET A ROAD
MAP OF WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE SO
THAT WE'RE IN A MORE EFFECTIVE
POSITION TO BE ABLE TO ADVOCATE
IN THE LOBBY. OF FOR. THE
DOLLARS THAT SHOULD RIGHTFULLY
COME INTO THIS REGION- SO I
JUST WANT TO MAKE THAT POINT I
THINK. ARRAY YOU'VE ALREADY
OUTLINED THE- OUR PROCESS AND
HOW. THE GOAL LINE IS TO BE
CONSIDERED IN THAT SO A YOUR
YOUR PLANNING PROCESS IS VERY
IMPORTANT BUT I THINK AT SOME
POINT SEEING- SOME CLEAR
DEFINITIVE. L. NARROWING IN ON
THAT SIX OR SEVEN. MILE GAP
BECAUSE I MEAN LOOK. AS I MADE
CLEAR IN MY OPENING STATEMENTS
WE DO HAVE A FUNDING GAP
BETWEEN POMONA. AND MARK LAYER.
BUT WE'RE GOING TO BE WORKING
VERY HARD AND COLLABORATIVELY
TO SEE THAT WE CAN GET THAT-
THAT GAP. OF FUNDING OF FINISH
WE HAD A GAP. FROM A SEUSS- TO-
TO PROMOTE POMONA- AND WE WORK
TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT WAS HILL
SO I HAVE EVERY BIT OF
CONFIDENCE THAT WE WILL BE ABLE
TO GET THE RESOURCES. TO SEE
THE LINE- TO MONTCLAIR. THE
POINT IS WE DON'T NEED PEOPLE
THAN HAVING TO UBER FROM MY
CLEAR TO THE AIRPORT. SO BUT
COUNT ME AS A- ALONG WITH THE
OTHERS AS A- A STALWART IN
SUPPORT OF- SUPPORTING PLANS
THAT MOVE. OF THE PEOPLE OF-
THE INLAND EMPIRE. TO THE
AIRPORT AND ONTARIO. I ALSO
WANTED TO JUST TAKE A SECOND TO
ON THE- MEASURE LIKE
PRESENTATION- TODD WHERE YOU
HAD TALKED ABOUT. YOU KNOW HOW
THE- RIDERSHIP IS INCREASING
AND IT IT'S IMPORTANT TO THIS
CONVERSATION TODAY EVEN THOUGH
IT CENTERS ON THE POTENTIAL OF.
A LINE A DOUBLING OF THE LINE-
TO EXTEND FROM BURBANK AIRPORT
TO WHERE THE COMMUNITY BURBANK-
TO ORANGE COUNTY. IS THERE ANY
AND I KNOW AND- HELLO LAURA
FRIEDMAN WHO IS ALSO A MEMBER
OF THIS COMMITTEE COULD NOT BE
HERE TODAY BUT IS THERE
ANYTHING YOU CAN SHARE ON THAT
BECAUSE OF WHAT I UNDERSTAND.
IF THAT WERE TO BE PUT IN PLACE
THE REMOVAL OF TRAFFIC OR CARS
OFF OF THE FIVE FREEWAY BETWEEN
THAT STRETCHES WHO IF THE
NUMBERS THAT I'M HERE IN OUR
CORRECT. INCREDIBLY SIGNIFICANT
WHICH IMPACT THE ENTIRE REGION
AS IT RELATES TO THE- THE
FREEWAY SYSTEM IS THERE
ANYTHING YOU CAN ADD ON- OR-
VERIFY AROUND WHAT'S WHAT
CONVERSATIONS ARE HAPPENING ON
THAT KIND OF A PROJECT- THANK
YOU JERROLD AND- I BELIEVE
THAT- THERE ARE ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS BETWEEN- THE
SPEAKER. OF THE ASSEMBLY AND
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE- LOOKING
AT WAYS FORWARD IN ORDER TO TRY
TO- INSURE THE GREATEST AMOUNT
OF INVESTMENT POSSIBLE IN RAIL
AND IN THE CORRIDOR HERE IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THAT
ULTIMATELY CAN HELP THEM GET.
HIGH SPEED RAIL READY IN WHAT
WE DID IS WE WORKED WITH- THE
HIGHEST REAL AUTHORITY TO
PROVIDE THEM INFORMATION AS TO
THE LEVEL OF INVESTMENT- THAT
WAS NEEDED. AND OVERALL JUST
CONTINUE TO COMMUNICATE WITH
THEM TO SEE IF THERE MAY BE
SOME OPPORTUNITY IN THE FUTURE
FOR- THE GROWTH IN. FUNDING FOR
RAIL INVESTMENT TO HELP US TO
ACHIEVE OUR THE ANTI AND
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION GOALS
IN AN ANSWER THE- IF THAT WERE
TO HAPPEN IN THAT LINE WERE TO
BE DOUBLED WHAT IS THE
ANTICIPATED. NUMBER PERCENTAGE
OF CARS REMOVED FROM THE FIVE
FREEWAY IN THE STATE IS THERE A
I BELIEVE WE HAD JUST ABOUT A
FIVE POINT. THREE MILLION
ADDITIONAL RIDERSHIP TRIPS AND
IF YOU. DO THE EQUIVALENT.
RIGHT NOW ABOUT LOVE POINT NINE
SO JUST UNDER HALF OF THAT SO
THAT'S IN A- CONTINUED
REDUCTION OF MAYBE AROUND YOU
KNOW FOUR FIVE MILLION. VEHICLE
TRIPS JUST FROM THAT CORRIDOR
ALONG. I KNOW I GET EXCITED
ABOUT SOMETHING OUT OF THAT
THING AND JUST- IN IN CLOSING
ON THIS PANEL I JUST WANT TO
ALSO THINK- FALL AND- ALLEN-
AND THE COMMUNITY FOR YOUR-
STRONG ADVOCACY AROUND THE-
TANAMI. REPORTED BEING ABLE TO
GET AN AGREEMENT TO WHERE YOU
HAVE THE ABILITY TO OPERATE
THAT AIRPORT IN A WAY THAT-
CONTINUES TO SEE IT GROW AND
BENEFIT THE COMMUNITY AND THE
RESOURCES OF THIS COMMUNITY I
KNOW AS- HAVING SERVED ON
AIRPORT AUTHORITY FOR TWENTY
YEARS. OUR RECORD IT IS IN
TERMS OF AN ECONOMIC ENGINE FOR
THE COMMUNITY BUT ALSO TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE SOME CONTROL AND-
HOW THE BILL YOU TO PLAN
EFFECTIVELY THAT INTEGRATES
INTO THE COMMUNITY AS A WHOLE
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT. SO LET
ME THANK ALL OF YOU FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION IF YOU CAN STICK
AROUND TO THE- Q. AND A FROM
THE PUBLIC WE WOULD- MAY NEED
TO CALL ON YOU TO ANSWER A
QUESTION OR TWO. THANK YOU.
OUR
SECOND PANEL WILL DISCUSS THE
DEVELOPMENT OF SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITIES AND THEIR ROLE IN
REACHING CALIFORNIA'S
ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS. MS SUZANNE
HEY DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF PLANNING
AND RESEARCH WILL DISCUSS THE
IMPORTANCE OF CALL OF QUALITY
EQUITY AND AFFORDABILITY AND
THE NEXUS OF HOUSING AND
TRANSPORTATION. MISTER WESLEY
BROUGHT HIM IN SPECIAL PROGRAMS
DIRECTOR AT ACTIVE SAN GABRIEL
VALLEY WILL SPEAK TO THE
NECESSITY OF ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
AND COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT AND
PROMOTING ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION.
AS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AT THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF GOVERNORS GOVERNMENT'S MR
CALL MAY I DO SAY WILL SHARE
THE REGIONAL PLANNING GOALS AND
VISION OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
TO ADDRESS THE TRANSPORTATION
AND HOUSING NEEDS. WE'D LIKE TO
WELCOME OUR PANEL AND IF YOU
CAN PRINT. PRESENT IN THE ORDER
THAT YOU WERE- ACKNOWLEDGE. WE
WILL START OUR PANEL TO.
NO WAY
MILLION. SURE. TESTING HELLO
TESTING. AS CHAIR HOLDEN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR HAVING ME THIS MORNING
SUZANNE HAGUE FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF PLANNING
AND RESEARCH AND I'M HERE THIS
MORNING REPRESENTING BOTH OPR
AS WELL AS THE STRATEGIC GROWTH
COUNCIL FOR THOSE WHO DON'T
KNOW- MY OFFICE- PR AND THE STC
WORK HAND IN GLOVE HAS SORT OF
THE POLICY AND IMPLEMENTATION
ARMS OF SUSTAINABLE EQUITABLE
GROWTH THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AB YOU CAN GO AHEAD
AND GO AHEAD WITH THAT- SO I
WAS ASKED TO COME AND SPEAK TO
YOU ABOUT- THE STATE'S VANTAGE
POINT ON THE IMPORTANCE OF
SUSTAINABLE EQUITABLE GROWTH AS
WELL AS WHAT THE STRATEGIC ROTH
COUNCIL IS DOING TO IMPLEMENT
SUCH GROWTH THROUGHOUT THE
STATE SO THIS NARRATIVE REALLY
STARTS FOR MANY OF US WITH OUR-
STATUTORY GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION GOALS WHICH AS MANY
IN THE ROOM NO- WILL REQUIRE
MORE BETTER AND FASTER CLIMATE
SOLUTIONS IN ORDER TO REACH
THOSE TWENTY THIRTY AND TWENTY
FIFTY TARGETS. HAD AND THAT'S
BEEN MENTIONED TRANSFERRED. OF
COURSE THE LARGEST SHARE OF
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS IN THE
STATE REPRESENTING OVER HALF OF
GHG EMISSIONS. NEXT IN ADDITION
UNFORTUNATELY VEHICLE MILES OF
TRAVEL OR BE AND HE IS GOING IN
THE WRONG DIRECTION- UP PER
CAPITA RATHER THAN. DOWN AND
HAS BEEN FOR SOME YEARS. AND AS
MANY KNOW CALIFORNIA IS
PROJECTED TO ADD TEN MILLION
NEW RESIDENTS- PRESUMABLY WHO
WILL NEED TO LIVE PLACES AND
WORKPLACES AND GO LOTS OF
PLACES AND- HOPEFULLY NOT ADD
TOO MUCH TO THAT. THE M. T.
INCREASE THAT WE SAW ON THE
LAST SLIDE. THE FUTURE
CALIFORNIA WILL BE OUT
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE DIVERSE IN
TERMS OF RACE AND ETHNICITY AS
WELL AS OLDER SO AT THESE
GRAPHS REPRESENTS- AGE BRACKETS
FROM YOUNGEST ON THE BOTTOM TWO
OLDEST ON THE TOP AND YOU CAN
SEE. THIRTY YEARS FROM NOW THAT
THE TOP PART IS SIGNIFICANTLY
WIDENING SO WE'LL HAVE A VERY
DIFFERENT POPULATION- SORT OF
STRATA GUIDE- AND AS IS NO
SECRET HOUSING PRODUCTION IN
THE STATE IS NOT KEEPING PACE
WITH DEMAND SO THE RED ARROW
THERE IS THE ANNUAL PROJECTED
PRODUCTION PRODUCTION AND
DEMAND. I NEEDED AND THE BAR
GRAPHS REPRESENT THE ACTUAL
HOUSING PERMITTED ON THE GROUND
AFFORDABLE RENTAL HOMES ARE THE
MOST SCARCE HOUSING TYPE SO ON
THE LEFT YOU SEE. THE DEMAND
FOR VERY LOW AN EXTREMELY LOW-
AREA MEDIAN INCOME HOUSING FOR
RENTAL RENTER HOME OWNERS AS
GUINEA RENTER HOUSEHOLDS. AND
ON THE RIGHT YOU SEE THE
SUPPLIED THE NUMBER OF HOMES
THAT ARE AVAILABLE AT THOSE
INCOME STRATA WITH. THE RED
SHAPE REPRESENTING A PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT GAP THE
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS HAS
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACTS BY
RACE AND ETHNICITY SO HERE WE
SEE HOUSING COSTS BURDEN-
DISAGGREGATED BY RACE. SOME
STARK CONTRAST AND- MOST-
GROWTH IN THE STATE IS
PROJECTED IN THE MOST
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES SO WE
SEE THE MAP REPRESENTS IN
YELLOW- THE TOP. 25% OF
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IN
THE STATE AND THE GRAY SHADED
AREAS REPRESENTING PROJECTED
HOUSEHOLD GROWTH. THERE IS A
SPATIAL MISMATCH BETWEEN JOBS
AND HOUSING SO ON THE LEFT MAP
YOU SEE THAT JOBS ARE
CONCENTRATED ON THE COAST AND
ON THE RIGHT YOU SEE THAT
PROJECTED HOUSING GROWTH IS
LARGELY CONCENTRATED INLAND.
ONE OF THE- THE RESULTS OF THIS
PHENOMENON IS THAT SUPER
COMMUTERS ARE ON THE RISE THESE
ARE FOLKS WHO TRAVEL MORE THAN
NINETY MINUTES EACH WAY TO GET
TO A JOB. AND THIS SNAPSHOT IS
FROM THE BAY AREA BUT I KNOW
WELL THAT THIS PHENOMENON IS
ALIVE AND WELL IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AS WELL- THE LATEST
NUMBER I SAW FROM THE CITY OF
PALMDALE IS AT FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND PEOPLE TRAVEL EVERY
SINGLE DAY IN THEIR CARS. TO
THE LA BASIN AND THEN BACK
AGAIN IN THE EVENING. I
TRANSPORTATION OF COURSE
INCREASES THE HOUSEHOLD COST
BURDEN- PARTICULARLY IN LOWER
DENSITY COMMUNITIES SO THAT
CHART SHOWS. THE PERCENTAGE. OF
TOTAL HOUSING PLUS
TRANSPORTATION COSTS TO AREA
MEDIAN INCOME HOUSEHOLDS. I
APOLOGIZE THAT SOME OF MY
FORMATTING GOT A LITTLE BIT.
THE VISTA MISINTERPRETED HERE
BUT- BUT THE THAT TAKE AWAY IS
THAT SOME OF THE- LESS DENSE
COMMUNITIES TOWARD THE BOTTOM
OF THE ON THAT CHART HAVE SOME
OF THE HIGHEST- HOUSEHOLD
BURDEN WHEN YOU COMBINE
HOUSING. AND TRANSPORTATION
COST LOOKED AT ANOTHER WAY-
THIS IS A TOOL THAT MEASURES
AFFORDABILITY IN TWO DIFFERENT
WAYS SO ON THE LEFT WE SEE A
TRADITIONAL DEFINITION OF
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY AT 30% OF
MEDIAN INCOME AND THE MAP SHOWS
A MAP OF THIS AREA SO YOU CAN
SEE ON TERRIO WHERE WE ARE IN
THE BOTTOM LEFT OF THAT MAP-
THE YELLOW AREAS ARE AREAS THAT
ARE AFFORDABLE AT 30% OF INCOME
FOR HOUSING. WHEN YOU ADD
TRANSPORTATION COSTS- FOR A
COMBINED TOTAL OF 45% OF AREA
MEDIAN INCOME THE AREAS OF
AFFORDABILITY SHRINK
CONSIDERABLY. SO WE NEED TO
EXPAND HOUSING AND
TRANSPORTATION CHOICES IN
LOCATION EFFICIENT AREAS WITH A
FOCUS ON EQUITY AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. SO
HOW ARE WE DOING THIS- WE HAVE
A LOT OF- POLICY MEASURES IN
PLACE BUT IN PARTICULAR IS
ASKED TO THE TO FOCUS ON THE
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL AS A
MODEL FOR AN INTEGRATED
APPROACH TO SUSTAINABLE
EQUITABLE GROWTH. IF YOU'RE NOT
FAMILIAR WITH US DO YOU SEE
THIS IS OUR OUR OUR COUNCIL
EFFECTIVELY OUR BOARD OF
DIRECTORS COMPRISES. SIX STATE
AGENCIES SECRETARIES THREE
APPOINTED PUBLIC MEMBERS- MY
BOSS FROM THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
AS THE CHAIR OF THE COUNCIL.
AND ALL HIGH LATE IN PARTICULAR
ARE GRANT PROGRAMS- WE HAVE
FOUR SEPARATE GRANT PROGRAMS-
TOTALING OVER HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS THIS YEAR- TO FUND A
HOST OF INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS
AROUND AFFORDABLE AND EQUITABLE
AND SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES. IN
PARTICULAR THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITIES PROGRAM IS AN
INNOVATIVE- PROGRAM IS GOING
INTO ITS FIFTH CYCLE THAT FUNDS
INTEGRATED HOUSING AND
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS SO WE
REQUIRE. PROJECT PROPONENTS TO
COME TO US WITH WITH A HOUSING
AND TRANSPORTATION PROJECT THAT
IS AS ONE MANY OF THESE PROJECT
PROPONENTS HAVE NEVER MET EACH
OTHER OR TALK TO EACH OTHER
WITHIN THE COMMUNITY AND THAT
IS BECAUSE I NEVER HAD TO- BUT
ONE OF THE OUTCOMES OF THE
GRANT PROGRAM IN ADDITION TO
THE PROJECTS THAT WE ACTUALLY
END UP FUNDING. IS THIS IS
DIANE RELATIONSHIPS ACROSS
SILOS AND ACROSS PARTNERS
WITHIN THOSE COMMUNITIES- A
HIGH LATE TO THAT- WE FIND
SUSTAINABLE AGRICULTURAL LAND
PRESERVATION WHAT WE OFTEN
CALL. THE OTHER SIDE OF THE
COIN OF INFILL DEVELOPMENT IS
OF COURSE PRESERVATION OF
NATURAL WORKING LANDS- AND THE
TRANSFORMATIVE CLIMATE
COMMUNITIES HAS BEEN A REAL
SIGNATURE PROGRAM FOR US AS
WELL THAT. COMBINES MANY
DIFFERENT TYPES OF
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS AS
WELL AS WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AND CAPACITY BUILDING AT A
LOCAL LEVEL IN THE TOP FIVE TO
SPUR OF PERCENT OF
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES-
THROUGHOUT THE STATE- WHEN I
HAD A ALSO THAT. WE HAVE
SEVERAL PASSED THE BUILDING-
PROGRAM. INCLUDING IN PART
THANKS TO SENATOR GIVE US
LEADERSHIP ON SPEED TEN SEVENTY
UP NEW PRO FOR. ON REGION LIMA
COLLABORATIVE WITH WERE X.
ABOUT. ALL IT YOU SEE THE
PROGRAM OF BUT AS SORT OF WITH
A NATION TO COMMITMENT TO. WE
PRAY. IN ALL OF OUR GRANDSON
TECH ASSISTANCE WORK LOW INCOME
IN DOES IT COMMUNITY WERE ALSO
VERY PROUD TO HAVE ADOPTED THE
FIRST EVER PUBLIC FACING.
RACIAL EQUITY ACTION PLAN JUST
LAST YEAR SUMMER IMPACT
INCLUDES EIGHT HUNDRED SIXTY
EIGHT NINETY SIX MILLION-
INVESTED IN DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. OVER NINE THOUSAND
AFFORDABLE HOMES CREATED US
SEVERAL MILLION TONS OF CARBON
EMISSIONS ELIMINATED FROM THE
STATE AND THEN SOME. AND I
WANTED TO GIVE YOU JUST A BRIEF
SNAPSHOT OF WHAT ARE PROJECTS
LOOK LIKE ON THE GROUND SO THIS
IS A PROJECT CALLED ERRO HEAD
GROVE IN ST BERNARD YOU KNOW IT
WILL CREATE A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY FOUR UNITS OF AFFORDABLE
OF HOUSING 80% OF WHICH WILL BE
AFFORDABLE AND HAS A CLEAN
ENERGY COMPONENT. AND IT ALSO
HAS TWO MILES OF BIKE LANES.
CONNECTING THE PROJECTS TO
EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE HALF
MILE OF SIDEWALKS IN TWO NEW
BUS SHELTERS. FIVE
TRANSFORMATIVE CLIMATE
COMMUNITIES HAS TO INVESTMENTS
AND- SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THAT
WERE VERY EXCITED AND PROUD OF.
ONE RIGHT HERE IN ONTARIO IS
CALLED ON TERRIO TOGETHER-
THIS. PROJECT HAS BEEN THE
RECIPIENT OF THIRTY FIVE
MILLION AND STATE INVESTMENTS
COUPLED WITH. OVER SIXTEEN
MILLION AND LOCAL LEVERAGE
FUNDS. IT INCLUDES FIFTEEN
IMPLEMENTATION PARTNERS WHO ARE
LOCAL OUR PARTNERS- PROJECT
PROPONENTS WORKING VERY CLOSELY
IN COORDINATION TOGETHER- TO
INVEST IN HOUSING
TRANSPORTATION OPTIONS-
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT- AND-
THINGS LIKE BIKE MILE. BIKE
LANE MILES AND SIDEWALK
IMPROVEMENTS. I LIKE WISEMAN
WHAT'S WE HAVE A PROJECTS- ALSO
WITH A THIRTY FIVE MILLION TCC
INVESTMENT FROM THE STATE WHICH
HAS LEVERAGED ALMOST A HUNDRED
AND NINE EXCUSE ME A HUNDRED
AND SIXTY NINE MILLION IN LOCAL
LEVERAGE FUNDS- SEVENTEEN
COMMUNITY PARTNERS COMING
TOGETHER TO MAKE THIS PROJECT-
PROP POSSIBLE. IT INCLUDES
EXCUSE ME. AFFORDABLE HOUSING
OPTIONS- ELECTRIC BUS- SERVICE
AND INFRASTRUCTURE INCLUDING
THE PURCHASE OF THOSE- THOSE
ZERO EMISSION BUSES VAN POOL
AND CAR SHARING AND OVER FOUR
THOUSAND NEW TREES BEING
PLANTED. I HOPE THAT GIVES YOU
JUST A QUICK SNAPSHOT OF SORT
OF OUR VANTAGE POINT FROM THE
STATE FROM THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE AND THE STRATEGIC GROWTH
COUNCIL WHY WE VIEW SUSTAINABLE
AND EQUITABLE COMMUNITIES AS
BEING VITAL TO THE STATE'S
FUTURE. AND WHAT WE THINK THAT
ACTUALLY LOOKS LIKE ON THE
GROUND AND HOW WERE OR WALKING
THE WALK IN COMMUNITIES ALL
ACROSS THE STATE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
SIX GOOD MORNING EVERYONE
MY NAME IS WES REMAIN WITH-
ACTIVESYNC GABRIEL VALLEY WE
CAN GO TO THE NEXT SLIDE FOR
THOSE WHO AREN'T FAMILIAR WITH
US WE ARE A PLACE BASED
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATION STARTED
IS THE ALL VOLUNTEER COMMUNITY
COALITION IN TWENTY TEN AND NOW
WE HAVE A REALLY DEDICATED
PASSIONATE AND DIVERSE STAFF
THAT REFLECTS REALLY THE
RICHNESS OF THE SAN GABRIEL
VALLEY IN EAST LOS ANGELES
COUNTY WE ARE SMALL
ORGANIZATION. BUT THERE ARE
MANY GROUPS OF ALL DIFFERENT
SIZES WORKING ON THE SAME
ISSUES THAT I'LL BE SHARING
TODAY WE'RE REALLY FORTUNATE TO
HAVE AMAZING PUBLIC HEALTH
PARTNERS. ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ORGANIZATION SOCIAL JUSTICE
ORGANIZATIONS OTHER
TRANSPORTATION JUSTICE IN
MOBILITY ORGANIZATIONS THAT WE
WORK HAND IN HAND WITH ACROSS
THE STATE. AND AS THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKER STATED- TRANSPORTATION
IS REALLY CLIMATE ACTION IF WE
ARE GOING TO MEET OUR CLIMATE
GOALS. AND IN TWENTY THIRTY
MAJOR TWENTY TWENTY GOALS WE
NEED TO ADDRESS- THE OUR
MOBILITY SECTOR AND IT'S OVER
50% WHEN YOU INCLUDE THE- ALL
THE OIL PRODUCTION AND
DISTRIBUTION. EMISSIONS SO IT'S
A IT'S A HUGE HUGE CHALLENGE.
AND IT'S GETTING WORSE
UNFORTUNATELY WORK WE'RE DOING
BETTER IN ALMOST EVERY OTHER
SECTOR EXCEPT SECTOR AND THAT'S
THAT'S VERY PROBLEMATIC I KNOW
US LOCALLY AND MANY OTHER
GROUPS ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THIS
AND- IT'S A REAL CHALLENGE FOR
ALL OF US. ONE OF THE FACTORS
HERE WHICH I THINK IS JUST
COMING TO THE FOREFRONT MORE
RECENTLY CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD RECENTLY
ACKNOWLEDGE THIS BUT- THE VAST
MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIANS AND
PEOPLE ACROSS THE WORLD ARE
BUYING LARGER AND LESS FUEL
EFFICIENT VEHICLES EVEN ASKED
HAS LINE ALL THESE ELECTRIC
VEHICLES ARE BECOMING
AVAILABLE- THESE LARGER ON
TRUCKS AND CARS. ARE SINGLE
HANDEDLY TORPEDOING OUR ABILITY
TO MEET OUR CHRONICLES. AND
THEY'RE ALSO OTHER CONCERNS IS
PARTICULARLY WITH REGARD TO
PUBLIC SAFETY ABOUT STV'S WHICH
I'LL TALK TO ABOUT A LITTLE
LATER- THEY ARE MORE DANGEROUS
FOR EVERYONE OUTSIDE OF A CAR
IF A CHILD OR AN OLDER ADULT IS
STRUCK BY A HIGHER PROFILE
VEHICLE. YOU WILL NOT ROLL OVER
THE HOOD OF THAT VEHICLE ON AND
THE OUTCOMES ARE ARE. FAR FAR
GRIMMER FOR FOLKS INVOLVED IN.
A COLLISION TO THOSE VEHICLES.
ANOTHER SLIGHT JUST KIND OF
ILLUSTRATES HOW EXPONENTIALLY
DIFFERENT IT IS DEPENDING ON
HOW WE'RE MOVING AROUND OUR
COUNTY SO IF YOU'RE MOVING
AROUND IN A LARGE FOUR WHEEL
DRIVE SUV ON YOUR OWN.
URINATING YOU KNOW. FAR FAR
MORE THAN IF YOU'RE ON A BUS OR
IF YOU'RE WALKING. SO HOW DO WE
REDUCE TRANSPORTATION EMISSIONS.
REDUCING VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED
THERE'S LOTS OF EMPHASIS ON
THIS- REPLACING CAR TRIPS AS
WELL AS PLACING HOUSING CLOSER
TO JOBS IN TRANSIT LOT OF
PEOPLE ARE INTERESTED IN HAVING
A WALK TO WORK OR A SHORT BUS
RIDE TO WORK BUT IT WITHOUT
HOUSING CLOSE TO JOBS THAT'S
JUST NOT FEASIBLE. ELECTRIFYING
TRANSPORTATION WE'RE SEEING
THIS IS REALLY AN AMAZING TREND
THE LAST FIVE YEARS- ALL MANNER
OF BICYCLES YOU KNOW AND LARGER
VEHICLES ARE ARE NOW AVAILABLE
IN ELECTRIC AND THEN IT
IMPROVING. ALSO HAVE TO BE MORE
EFFICIENT VEHICLES FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS NOT HELPING US ON
THIS AS WE ALL KNOW CALIFORNIA
IS A LEADER IN THE WORLD AND WE
ARE THANKFUL THAT YOU ALL ARE
PUSHING BACK. SO I WANTED TO
TOUCH BRIEFLY ON THERE SOME
AMAZING THINGS HAPPENING IN OUR
PART OF THE COUNTY ARE PART OF
THE WORLD. FOOTHILL TRANSIT
NEEDS TO BE RECOGNIZED FIRST IN
THE NATION WILL BE ALL ELECTRIC
BY TWENTY THIRTY. THEY'RE
SETTING THE STANDARD FOR
EVERYONE ELSE. AS SAN GABRIEL
VALLEY COUNCIL OF GOVERNMENTS
ALSO DOING AN AMAZING JOB THEY
HAVE SECURED A NUMBER OF GRANTS
TO. ADVANCE TO STAND WILL
ABILITY INCLUDING THE FIRST
REGIONAL ELECTRIC BIKE SHARE
PROGRAM IN THE STATE FIFTEEN
CITIES HAVE EXPRESSED INTEREST
IN PARTICIPATING IN THIS. I'M
REALLY INTERESTING OPPORTUNITY
ELECTRIC BIKES IF YOU NEVER
TRIED ONE EASIER THAN A
SKATEBOARD TO USE FOR OLDER
ADULTS- YEAH. EASIER THAN
SCOOTERS MUCH MORE FORGIVING
AND THE HILL YOU KNOW THEY
TACKLE HILLS GREAT AND IF IT'S
A HOT DAY IT'S ALSO OFTEN USED.
I LOVE USING THEM I TAKE MY SON
TO SCHOOL COUPLE DAYS A WEEK ON
ELECTRIC BIKE SO. LET US KNOW
IF YOU WANT TO TRY ONE THESE
ARE SOME OF THE OTHER ONCE AND
YOUNGER MILLENNIALS- ARE
INCREASINGLY USING SCOOTERS AND
OTHER- ELECTRIC VEHICLES TO GET
AROUND WE SHOULD EMBRACE THAT
WE DON'T ALL NEED TO USE THE
SAME THING TO GET AROUND.
HOWEVER STILL THE GREEN AND THE
BEST FOR OUR HEALTH AND ALL
SORTS OF OUTCOMES IS. WALKING
AND BIKING AND JUST GETTING
AROUND ON THEIR OWN TWO FEET.
LOTS OF MENTAL HEALTH BENEFITS
IS THE HEALTH BENEFITS
ENVIRONMENTAL DOWN BENEFITS.
THANKS LINE. SOMERS TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT OUR
ORGANIZATION REALLY FOCUSES ON
IS- COMPLETE STREETS MORE
SUSTAINABLE STREETS AND GREENER
STREETS. ON THE CONCEPT IS
JARGON BUT IT BASICALLY MEANS
WE'VE DONE ONE THING FOR
SEVENTY YEARS AND THAT'S
DESIGNED STREETS PRIMARILY JUST
TO MOVE ONE TYPE OF USER. WE
REALLY NEED TO BE WORKING MORE
HOLISTICALLY AND LOOKING AT ALL
DIFFERENT TYPES OF USER GROUPS
INCLUDING. PEOPLE ON FOOT NOW
TRANSPORTATION DELIVERING AND
ON IN PUBLIC TRANSIT. SO TALK
ABOUT CROSS DESIGNER OF THE
STUFF DOES NOT TO COME A TON OF
MONEY AND MANY OF YOU I KNOW
TRAVEL ALL OVER THE STATE AND
PROBABLY HAVE NOTICED SOME OF
THESE THINGS EVERY COMMUNITY.
FOR THE MOST PART APPROACH
THESE THINGS DIFFERENTLY. GOOD
THE NEXT SLIDE I'VE US NICE
EXAMPLES HERE SO THIS IS
STANDARD CROSSWALK YOU SEE THIS
IN MOST CITIES IN CALIFORNIA-
AND TO GO TO THE NEXT SIDE THIS
IS. AN EXAMPLE SIMPLE-
CONTINENTAL CROSSWALK WITH THE
CURVE EXTENSION MAKING THAT
CROSSING DISTANCE A LITTLE BIT
SHORTER. EASIER FOR PEOPLE TO
GET ACROSS YOU CAN GET THE NEXT
TIME YOU CAN GET- ARTISTIC WITH
THESE TO THE PLAYHOUSE DISTRICT
ASSOCIATION IN AND PASADENA
HAS. HAS AN AMAZING ARTISTIC
CROSSWALK PROGRAM THEY'VE HIRED
LOCAL ARTISTS TO DESIGN THESE
TEMPLATES AND THEY USE THEM
THROUGHOUT THEIR DISTRICT TO
REALLY GIVE IT. A CERTAIN
UNIQUE FEEL AND IT ALSO ADDS TO
SAFETY. LAST COUPLE YEARS.
PEDESTRIAN START. SOME PEOPLE
CAUGHT EARLY WALKED TIMING THE
PLANNERS CALL IT A AND L. P. I.
A LEADING PEDESTRIAN INTERVAL.
ESSENTIALLY GIVES- PEDESTRIAN A
COUPLE SECONDS HEAD START
GETTING ACROSS THE INTERSECTION
BEFORE THE LIGHT TURNS GREEN
SO. REDUCING US RIGHT TURNING
CONFLICTS THIS CALL VERY LITTLE
MONEY BUT- HAS TREMENDOUS
BENEFITS FOR SAFETY. AND
MICHAEL MOBILITY LANE SO FOR A
LONG TIME PEOPLE TALKED ABOUT
BIKE LANES BUT- AND SO MANY
MORE PEOPLE USE THESE THAN JUST
PEOPLE ON BIKES. SO PEOPLE ON
SCOOTERS AND SKATEBOARDS AND
ALL THESE HE WHEELS AND
DIFFERENT THINGS YOU SEE MORE
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA BUT ARE
COMING DOWN HERE. THE LOCAL
EXAMPLE AND CLAREMONT THE LOWER
PICTURE FOOTHILL BOULEVARD IT
JUST REDESIGNED THE STREET
SPACE A BIT INCLUDED STORM
WATER CAPTURE MORE STREET
TREES- SO MULTI BENEFIT
REDESIGN OF THE STREET SO
MOVING VEHICLES HELPING
EVERYONE GET AROUND SICK MORE
SAFELY. THREE TREES- TREMENDOUS
BENEFITS FOR A WALK ABILITY FOR
PUBLIC HEALTH FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT- AND- YOU KNOW THIS
IS ONE OF THE LOWEST COST
THINGS YOU CAN DO AND IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE A LOT OF
ROOM FOR IMPROVEMENT ON. AND
HERE'S ANOTHER EXAMPLE FROM THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF CITY
TRANSPORTATION OFFICIALS A LOT
OF OUR STREETS LOOK LIKE THIS
NOT A LOT OF AMENITIES. NEXT
SLIDE. WILL SHOW A REDESIGNED
WITH STREET TREES WITH AN
ELEVATED CROSSWALK WITH THE
SAFETY ALLEN IN THE MIDDLE SO
YOU DON'T NEED TO RUN ACROSS
THE WHOLE STREET ONCE BECAUSE
NOT EVERYONE STOPS FOR US WHEN
WE- MUST WALK. I AND THEN SOME
OF THE OTHER BENEFITS AND WE
TALKED ABOUT PHYSICAL NOW. ONE
IS MENTAL HEALTH AGING IN PLACE
OUR SENIORS SO THEY CAN GET
AROUND WITHOUT A CAR NOT ALWAYS
YOU CAN BE ABLE TO DRIVE FOR
EVER- ON. PERSONAL FINANCE.
SICK AND IT'S ABOUT SIX GRAND A
YEAR TO HAVE A CAR WHEN YOU ADD
UP INSURANCE TICKETS PARKING
EVERYTHING ELSE. AIR QUALITY
BENEFITS QUALITY OF LIFE
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT MORE
WALKABLE VIBRANT DOWNTOWN TO DO
BETTER ECONOMICALLY. JOBS WHEN
YOU INVEST IN THESE TYPES OF
IMPROVEMENTS THAT ARE MUCH
MORE. LABOR INTENSIVE SO FIXING
SIDEWALKS IMPROVING SUCH LOCAL
STREETS CREATES MORE JOBS THAN
FOR EXAMPLE PUTTING ANOTHER
LANE ON THE FREEWAY- PUBLIC
SAFETY AND THIS. THAT'S WHAT
I'LL TALK A LITTLE BIT ON NOW.
IT'S NOT SPECIFICALLY
SUSTAINABILITY FOCUS BUT
TRAFFIC VIOLENCE REMAINS A HUGE
PROBLEM WE ARE AT A TWENTY FIVE
YEAR HIGH RIGHT NOW IN TERMS OF
FATALITIES. OF PEOPLE ARE.
RIDING BICYCLES AND WALKING IN
THE STATE. A ONE OF THE FACTORS
HERE IS THOSE LARGER VEHICLES
WE HAVE MORE HAVE YOUR VEHICLES
ON THE STREETS WHEN THEY HIT
PEOPLE THEY DO A LOT OF DAMAGE.
AND THE OTHER ISSUE IS OF
COURSE EVERYONE HAS A
SMARTPHONE NOW. AND IF YOU'RE
OPERATING HEAVY VIA AND PAYING
IT. THAT CAN BE DEBT TO. SO
THESE ARE JUST ACCEPT I KNOW WE
HAVE A LIST THE LAST TWO YEARS
OF PEOPLE PREDOMINANTLY PEOPLE
WALKING KILLED AND IT
OVERWHELMINGLY IMPACT. CHILDREN
IN OLDER ADULTS. WHO OFTEN
DEPEND ON WALKING TO GET
AROUND- CRASHING ON ACCIDENT-
MANY OF THESE COLLISIONS FATAL
COLLISIONS THAT WE CAN'T WE
HAVE TO STOP CALLING THEM
ACCIDENTS BECAUSE THEY ARE.
OFTEN PREVENTABLE WITH BETTER
DESIGN WITH BETTER EDUCATION.
HI IF YOU CAN ADVANCE TO SLIDE.
ABOUT 18% OF TRIPS IN
CALIFORNIA BY FOOTER BIKE 40%
OF FATALITIES ARE PEOPLE DOING
EITHER OF THOSE THINGS AND WE
WERE TRYING TO GET MORE PEOPLE
TO GET AROUND BY PUTTING MY WE
WORK WITH A LOT OF YOUTH. AND
IT'S PARTICULARLY NOW MONEY
CENTER SAYING YOUR BILL VALLEY
A LOT OF THESE. YOUTH ARE ARE
FROM. THIS COMMUNITIES AND THEY
ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY-
VULNERABLE TO BEING KILLED
WHILE WALKING AROUND THEIR
CITIES. AND ONE OF THE REASONS
THIS IS AGAIN HISTORIC UNDER
INVESTMENT SO LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES. ONLY ABOUT HALF OF
THEM HAVE SIDEWALKS HAVE
NEIGHBORHOODS WITH SIDEWALKS
VERSES AND ALMOST 90% OF HIGH
INCOME COMMUNITIES. SO THE LAST
I KNOW EVERYONE'S TALKING ABOUT
BUDGET AND IF YOU BROUGHT YOUR
CHECKBOOK- I'M NO DIFFERENT. I
WILL HIGHLIGHT THAT LESS THAN
1% OF ALL THE STATE
TRANSPORTATION SPENDING IS
INVESTING IN WALKING AND
BICYCLING PROJECTS AND OTHER
ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
IMPROVEMENTS- MEANWHILE ABOUT
18% OF THE TRIPS ARE BY FOR A
BIKE. AND CALTRANS AS A GOAL
BUT I BELIEVE TWENTY THIRTY
FIVE TO DOUBLE THAT SO WE WANT
TO GET TO THIRTY FIVE PERCENT-
TRIPS BY PUT HER BIKE IN ORDER
TO MEET OUR CLIMATE GOALS AND
MANY OF OUR OTHER GOALS. AND
TALK A QUICK ABOUT ONE PROGRAM
SO THAT THE BIGGEST PROGRAM TO
FUND THESE THINGS IN CALIFORNIA
AT THE STATE LEVEL TO THE
CALIFORNIA ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM. YOU'VE
HAD FOUR CYCLES OF THIS SO FAR
AND- NOW IT'S EVERY TWO YEARS.
THE YELLOW BARS TO SHOWCASE THE
AMOUNT OF FUNDING REQUESTED BY
CITIES. THE GREEN BARS HOW MUCH
FUNDING IS AVAILABLE IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN YOU CAN SEE WAS
EXTREMELY COMPETITIVE- NOT MANY
CITIES RECEIVE THIS FUNDING-
AND CYCLE FIVE IT HAS INCREASED
MUCH- SO ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE'RE SEEING OUR ORGANIZATION
AS HELP CITIES FOR MANY YEARS.
APPLYING FOR THESE GRANTS. IS
THAT. AFTER APPLYING ONCE OR
TWICE CITIES JUST STOP. BECAUSE
THEY REALIZE IT'S TOO HARD AND
IT TAKES. HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS
OF HOURS TO SUBMIT THESE THINGS
OR THEY HAVE TO HIRE
PROFESSIONAL- CONSULTANTS TO
SUBMIT THE PROPOSALS. AND IF
YOU DON'T GET FUNDED YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO KEEP DOING IT SO I
THINK. THE REQUESTED FUNDING
WOULD BE EVEN HIGHER IF. IF
THEY WERE BETTER SHOT THAT FOR
CITIES TO GET THESE THINGS
FUNDED. SO QUICK EXAM CYCLE FOR
THESE ARE THE PROJECT THAT WERE
SOME IN EAST LA ANGELES COUNTY.
SO DIAMOND BAR TO RTL MONEY LA
COUNTY PUBLIC WORKS SUBMITTED
TEN. LEAVE PROJECTS COUNTY WIDE
THEY DID NOT GET A SINGLE
PROJECT FUNDED WHICH IS NEVER
HAPPENED BEFORE AND THERE ARE
HUGE INSTITUTION WITH. ALL THE
EXPERTISE AND MANPOWER TO
SUBMIT THE THINGS AND KEEP
ADVANCING THE SLIDES SO I LOVE
PLENTY LOOKING OUT OF
FLINTRIDGE MONROVIA MONTEREY
PARK PASADENA AT POMONA
SUBMITTED TO PROPOSALS ROSE
MEETS OMITTED TO PROPOSE A
SOUTH OF MONEY. ONLY TWO OF
NINETEEN WERE FUNDED. AND JUST
KIND OF IN A NUTSHELL HOW
DIFFICULT THIS IS THE BECOME
FOR CITIES AND MANY THE CITIES
ARE GOING TO APPLY AGAIN IN
TWENTY TWENTY BASED ON WHAT
HAPPENED THE MOST RECENT. TIME
SO WE'RE EXCITED TO SEE A
COUPLE CITIES GET FUNDING BUT
THE SAME TIME IT'S SIMPLY NOT
ENOUGH. AN EXCELLENT. IT'S
TWENTY TWENTY I KNOW SOME OF
YOU ARE INTERESTED IN WHAT
VOTERS THINK ABOUT THESE ISSUES
SO IN TWENTY SIX TEEN ONE
MEASURE AND MUST PASS LOS
ANGELES COUNTY AMERICAN HEART
ASSOCIATION DID POLLING OF
VOTERS ON DIFFERENT
TRANSPORTATION INVESTMENTS I'D
SAY FOR OUT THE SCHOOL MAKING
OUR SCHOOL SAFER FOR KIDS TO
GET TO- IS VERY POPULAR AMONGST
VOTERS SAME THING WITH THE
CROSSWALK IMPROVEMENTS- I THINK
ALL OF US ARE PEDESTRIAN AT
SOME POINT I THINK MANY OF US
OF EXPERIENCES FIRSTHAND THAT
IT ISN'T SAFE ENOUGH TO WALK
ACROSS TOO MANY OF OUR STREETS.
AND THIS IS SOMETHING WE CAN DO
A RELATIVELY LOW COST SO- WITH
THAT THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR
TIME AN INVITATION SPEAK TODAY
WE'RE HAPPY TO HAVE PEOPLE
CONTACT US IF YOU LIKE TO COME
DOWN MONEY ARE ALSO HAPPY TO
SHOWCASE OUR CENTER WHICH IS IN
WHICH INCLUDES- THE COMMUNITY
BICYCLE PARK AND THE TRAFFIC
GARDEN WHERE WE TEACH A SAFETY
CLASSES. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON THE MORE ARCHER
HOLDEN AND MEMBER AND SAY LEYVA
ARE RELIEVED THE INVITATION TO
BE A MY NAME IS AND EXECUTIVES
OF LOOKS LIKE SKY IS ISN'T
PLANNING ORGANIZATION FOR THE
REGION ARE A THREE I ALWAYS
JOKE THAT I TO USE OF THE AND
MY JOB. BECAUSE BECAUSE THIS
STYLE THE STORY OF HOW HOW
ABOUT OUR REGION IS AND HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS AND WHY WE THIS
OF THE REGION ZERO WE HAVE ON
HAVE PUBLIC OF THE STATE YOU
KNOW SEE COUNTY ARE ARE ARGUES
INCLUDING NINETY CITY AND IN
THE SIX COUNTIES. IN TERMS.
WITH ABOUT NINETEEN MILLION
PEOPLE. TO SPEAK ORDER. FOR ALL
RIGHT NEXT RIGHT BOB JUST TO GO
NEED ON THAT ON THAT FOR A
SLICE WE THE WORK DO AT AT SKY
RE DO WE OF ALL OF LOCAL
COORDINATING LOW ISSUE WE
ALWAYS ALWAYS ARE TONE IT'S
THAT THE BEST IS REALLY THE LOW
GOVERNMENT CITY AND COUNTY GO.
BECAUSE THAT'S WITH THAT TO
LIVE DIRECTLY THE PEOPLE AS
IMPORTANT THAT WORK IS IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT THAT STATE GO
AND NAY OUR SO GOVERNMENT ALL
BE IMPORTANT AND YOU ALL ARE
HERE FOR THAT AND WE FIND
OURSELVES IN A NICHE THAT
SOMEWHERE IN THE MIDDLE WHERE
WERE TACKLE THINGS THAT ARE
DONE A LITTLE BIT BIGGER THAN A
SINGLE JURISDICTION AND THESE
OTHER REGIONAL ISSUES THAT YOU
ARE CALLING US TO SPEAK TO
TODAY. ABOUT ONE OF THE THINGS
WE DO ARTS GUY WILL PROBABLY
THE MOST IMPORTANT DOCUMENT
WOULD PRODUCE IS THE REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION PLAN THAT'S
REQUIRED BUT BOTH FEDERAL AND
STATE LAW HOW WE DO THIS EVERY
FOUR YEARS AND WE'RE IN THE
MIDDLE OF OUR CURRENT UPDATE
WHICH IS A TWENTY TWENTY UPDATE.
HOW WE CALL THE CAN OKAY
BECAUSE INTO IS TO RE. GET A
THE FIVE THAT WE HAVE A REGION.
THAT IS LIKE I SAID THE MOST
THAT CAN VIABLE REGION BECAUSE
OF JUST LA- BUT BECAUSE OF ALL
OF THE REGION COMING TOGETHER
AND GETTING NEEDED TOGETHER.
AND SO THAT ELEMENT OF
CONNECTIVITY IS IMPORTANT AND
THAT WAS THE END OF THE NATURE
OF THE CONVERSATION YOU HEARD.
ON THE FIRST PANEL WE ACTUALLY
DID A CONNECTIVITY STUDY
BETWEEN LA AND SOMEBODY YOU
KNOW THAT WAS ALLUDED TO.
EARLIER ON. IN THIS LONG RANGE
PLAN WHAT IT IS REALLY MORE OF
A VISION FOR THE REGION. IT'S
NOT A MANDATE HOWEVER IT DOES
PROVIDE. OF VERY DATA DRIVEN-
FACT BASED- BASIS FOR WHERE WE
THINK WE SHOULD GO AS A REGION.
ARE IN ALIGNMENT WITH STATE
GOALS- STATE SUSTAINABILITY
AND- AND LIVABILITY GOALS WE
HAVE TO ASSURE THAT THE THINGS
THAT ARE IN THE PLAN OF
FINANCIALLY CONSTRAINED
OTHERWISE WE JUST DON'T MAKE
THINGS UP- SO THE POLICIES AND
STRATEGIES IN THE PLANT. AND
THE PROJECTS IN THE PLAN HAVE
TO- HAVE A REASONABLY A SHORT
FUNDING OVER THE TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE YEARS OF THE PLAN LIFE.
OUR STATE REQUIREMENT ON THE SP
THREE SEVEN FIVE OFFICE ALSO
REQUIRES US THAT THESE PLANS
SHOW AND DEMONSTRATE. HOW WE
ACHIEVE REDUCTION IN GREENHOUSE
GAS ABOUT TWENTY THIRTY FIVE
OUR TARGET IN THIS REGION IS
19% REDUCTION. BY TWENTY THIRTY
FIVE FROM THE TWO THOUSAND AND
FIVE LEVELS- ON THE FEDERAL
LEVEL OUR PLAN HAS TO BE IN
CONFORMITY WITH HER CLEAN AIR
ACT. AND SO THAT'S SOMETHING WE
ARE WE ALSO STRIVE TO
ACCOMPLISH NEXT LINE. WE HAVE
SOME CHALLENGE AND YOU ARE NEW
TO JOHN IN THIS I THINK SOME OF
THOSE HAVE BEEN ALREADY
ARTICULATED SO I'M NOT GONNA.
DO A MUCH ON IT- VERY
SIGNIFICANT IN OUR REGION
OBVIOUSLY IS THE FACT THAT WE
KNOW WE'RE GROWING WE'RE GOING
TO GROW BY ABOUT FOUR MILLION
THE PLAN. AND THE PLAN PERIOD-
WE ARE GOING TO. AS A RESULT
HAVE- INCREASING DEMAND ON OUR
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM. WE HAVE
A DECLINE IN TRYING TO
RIDERSHIP. I'D SAY IN TIME WE
CONTINUE TO MAINTAIN THAT
TRANSIT IS THE BACKBONE OF OUR
MOBILITY IN THIS REGION.
ESPECIALLY ON THE ON THE LONG
HALLS AND SO WE HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO INVEST IN TRANSIT
WE HAVE TO ARREST THE DECLINE
IN TRANSIT RIDERSHIP IN THAT.
REST WE ALSO HAVE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE FACT WE THE SYSTEM
WE HAVE- THAT WE ARE PLANNING
FOR THE FUTURE OUR FUTURE
SYSTEM MOST OF IT IS ALREADY
HERE IN TERMS OF HIGHWAYS FOR
EXAMPLE. WHEN A BILL NINETY
MORE BUT WHAT WE HAVE WE ALSO
HAVE TO BE VERY EFFICIENT AND
HOW WE USE THEM. AND THAT
REQUIRES SOME FUNDING. BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY IS HOW WE
COORDINATE. LAND USE AND
TRANSPORTATION WHY WE DON'T
HAVE LAND USE AUTHORITY AT THE
REGIONAL. LEVEL AT THIS GAG
LEVEL WE WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH
A LAND USE AUTHORITIES TO MAKE
SURE THAT. WE'RE MAKE IN- OUR
WORDS COLOCATION EFFICIENCY-
LOCATION- SHOPPER LAND USE
DECISIONS WHERE WE'RE WE'RE
MAKING SUSTAINABLE DEVELOPMENT
THE- THE ESSENCE OF OUR- OF OUR
OF OUR PLANET. OUR OUR PLAN WAS
PREDICATED ON THIS TEN GOALS
THAT OUR BOARD- REVIEWED AND
ADOPTED THAT ALLOWED US TO
BASICALLY BE TO BE THE
PREDICATE FOR THE PLAN THAT WE
RELEASED. LAST NOVEMBER. ARE
THE PLAN WAS IN CIRCULATION FOR
FIFTY FIVE DAYS- FOR COMMENT.
AND THOSE WHO FIVE DAYS ENDED
ON THE TWENTY FOURTH OF JANUARY
WE HAVE RECEIVED SO FAR- WHEN I
CHECKED WOULD STAFF YESTERDAY.
WE RECEIVED SO FAR NORTH OF THE
HEART OF FIFTEEN UNDER
COMMENTS. ON THE PLAN. SO WE
ARE VERY GRATIFIED THAT PEOPLE
ARE PAYING ATTENTION TO- TO THE
PLANNING TO WORK NOW BEGINS TO
SORT THROUGH. AUGUST COMMONS.
THERE ARE TWO ESSENTIAL BUCKETS
THE PLAN ON THE WRIST AND THIS
REGIONAL PLAN THAT WE WORK WITH
ALL OF OUR STAKEHOLDER THE TO A
BUCKETS ARE WHAT WE CORD AS AND
WE CORPS V. REAL MEAN A THINGS
THAT WE HAVE DONE IN THE THAT
INTO A- AND WANT TO CONTINUE TO
DO THOSE BECAUSE IT MAKES SO
THE ARE THE CORE VISION EL OF
THE TO COME TO MAINTAIN HE
TALKS ABOUT MAINTAINING WE
ALREADY HAVE FIXING FORCE WILL
WE HAVE TALKS ABOUT EXPANDING.
IN TERMS OF MOBILITY AND
HOUSING AND ALSO INCREASE IN
INVESTMENT IN TRANSIT
INCOMPLETE STREETS THE OTHER
BALK AT IS OUR ELECTRONIC
THAT'S RIGHT NOW KEEP
CONNECTIONS THE KEY CONNECTIONS
ARE NEW THINGS THAT WE ARE
BRINGING FORWARD IN THIS IN
THIS PLAN THAT ADDRESS- THE
OPPORTUNITIES WE HAVE TODAY AND
LOOKING FORWARD ESPECIALLY
ALONG THE LINES OF WHAT
TECHNOLOGY MIGHT OFFER US AND
SO HERE WE HAVE IN THIS LIKE WE
HAVE A LIST OF THINGS THAT WE
ADDRESS OUR SCORE VISION THESE
ARE THINGS THAT WE'VE DONE IN
AT LEAST THREE OR FOUR PLAN
CYCLES BACK SOME OF THESE WE
PIONEERED IN OUR REGION AND
HAVE BECOME MORE STATE WIDE- IN
ITS ADOPTION- IT'S NOT. IT'S
NOT NEWS THAT WE'RE WORSE
INVEST IN TRANSIT- IT'S NOT
NEWS THAT GOODS MOVEMENTS
ESSENTIAL TO OUR ECONOMY IT'S
ABOUT A THIRD OF OUR ECONOMY SO
WE CONTINUE TO CARRY- THOSE FOR
BY MAINTAINING AND ENSURING WE
EAT OUT THE MOST OUT OF
EXISTENCE SYSTEM IN TERMS OF
DEMAND AND SYSTEM PRESERVATION
AND THE SYSTEM MANAGEMENT
HAVING IS ALSO IMPORTANT WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE KEY. CORRECTION.
ARE WE- ON WHAT TECHNO WILL DO.
IN TERMS OF TRIP READ THE ONE
OF THE FIVE. GROWING TREAT CHIP
MÙT TO MODE. THAT WE SAW IN
OUR IN OUR US. IS TO WORK AT
HOME. THE MOBILE WORKING ON
HOME BECAUSE OF THE UP OF THE-
WE HAVE WITHIN FOLKS CAN DO MY-
ABOUT WORKING AT HOME OR WORK.
TO SPUR SITES THEY'RE NOT NEXT
WEEK. TO FAR WE- AWAY FROM HOME.
HOW AN INFRASTRUCTURE THAT SO.
HOUSING DID. I THINK ALSO IN WE
ALSO AS A MATTER OF ELEMENT IN
THIS IN THIS- IN THIS- PLAN
FOCUS ON. OR HOW WE MANAGE. THE
SYSTEM WHERE DURING THOSE PEAK
PERIODS HOW DO WE MANAGE THIS
SYSTEM AS A UTILITY. MOST OF US
KNOW THAT. WE DON'T WANT TO USE
ELECTRICITY CERTAIN TIMES OF
THE DAY SO WE DON'T RUN OUT
WASHES AND ENERGY AND- AND HIGH
CAPACITY OUR ELECTRICAL.
APPLIANCES AT CERTAIN TIMES OF
THE DAY BECAUSE IT'S HIGH COST
WE KNOW YOU JUST KNOW THAT.
HOWEVER MOST OF US DON'T THINK
TWICE ABOUT JUMPING ON THE
FREEWAY WHEN EVERYBODY ELSE IS
THAT WHETHER OR NOT THAT CHIP
IS IMPORTANT. HOW WE MAKE
PEOPLE MAKE THAT CHOICE HE'S
ONE OF BY ONE OF THE
DISCUSSIONS THAT WE HAD IN. IN
THE GOES ON DISCUSSION.
MOBILITY AS A SERVICE THAT'S
SOMETHING WE HAVE NOW- WHERE
WOULD BE THE TWENTY SIXTEEN
PLAN WHICH IS STILL CURRENT WE
DIDN'T SPEND TOO MUCH TIME
TALKING ABOUT UBER AND LIFT-
BECAUSE IT WASN'T AS RELEVANT
TODAY WE CAN'T LOOK PAST THAT.
AND SO HAVING THOSE MOBILITY.
CHOICES AS A SERVICE SERVING AS
THE FIRST AND LAST MILE TO OUR
TRANSIT SYSTEM THE TRANSIT
BACKBONE AT THESE IMPORTANT. AS
ONE ELEMENT OF A REQUEST IN
TRANSIT THE CAR RIGHT DECLINE.
AND OF COURSE AS WE FACE AGREE
GAS GOALS THAT WE HAVE. WE HAVE
TO SERIOUSLY. LOOK AT HOW WE
ACCELERATE THE. ELECTRIFICATION
OF THE ENTIRE. SYSTEM OUR FROM
THE PROBABILITY TO. OF A CHANCE
SYSTEM AND EVEN THE SING SINGLE
OF. THE. EXCITE I'M GONNA END
JUST TALKING ABOUT AND SO WERE
FOR I REALIZE SITE. THE ALLEGES
KIM UP WITH A ONE AS AN
INVESTOR IN JUMP STARTING THE
HOUSING. THAT WE HAVE NO NO NEW
THAT WE HAVE A CRISIS BOTH ON
THE A FOUR SIDE AND ALSO ON THE
HOMELESS SIDE AND DOING
SOMETHING ABOUT IT I THINK OF
THE STATE. STATE GOVERNMENT
SHOWED A JUST TREMENDOUS
LEADERSHIP WITH AB ONE A ONE-
WE ARE- STEPPING FORWARD TO THE
STATE TO- TO GO FOR EARLY OF
EARLY- THE EARLY ACTION GRANT
MONEY TO BEGIN TO DO MORE WORK
PLANNING FOR. HOW WE ACTUALLY
JUMPSTART HOUSING CONSTRUCTION
AND CREATING CAPACITY FOR-
ULTIMATELY BENDING THE NEEDLE
ARE MOVING THE NEEDLE ON ON-
THE HOUSING AFFORDABILITY IN
OUR REGION WHAT THAT GRANT
MONEY DOES FOR US IS ALLOWS US
TO WORK WITH EACH OF OUR
COMMUNITIES TO THE EXTENT
POSSIBLE. TO HELP THEM
ENERGIZED THEM GIVEN THE
CAPACITY TO ONE DO THE PLANNING
WE HAD WE WERE ASSIGNED A VERY
HARD HIGH REMAIN THIS YEAR IF
YOU OFFER WITH RE I THINK I. IS.
HEY IN WE WILL PASS THE S. OF
THE NUMBER WE TO KNOW IF OUT
HOW ACTION BILL THOSE. NOW THIS
AND COUNTIES NOT I BILL. BUT
THEY'RE IN A POSITION. HELP BY
IN. THOSE WHO ACTUALLY BUILD
AND TO DO THAT THEY HAVE TO
HAVE THE CAPACITY TO DO THAT
AND SOME OF THAT IS PLANNING
SOME OF THAT IS RESOURCES- IN
TERMS OF CAPITAL- THE- AGENCY
MONEY THAT WE GET FROM S. S.
YOU SEE I THINK IS IMPORTANT.
IS ONE CATALYST THAT WE'VE SEEN
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS IN A
CREATING AFFORDABLE HOUSING I
THINK THERE ARE OTHER IDEAS
THAT WE WANT TO BRING TO THE
TABLE- THROUGH THIS- EARLY
ACTION ACTIVITIES THAT WE WILL
BE TALKING ABOUT THIS AT A
BOARD- NEXT WEEK THURSDAY. BOB
OUR NEXT LIGHT MY THAT'S IT
BECAUSE I WANTED TRYING KEEP
THE TIME YOU TIME IS. LITTLE
FASTER HERE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. HI CERTAINLY AGAIN
APPRECIATE THE PRESENTATIONS
AND I THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
THAT HOW THEY ARE ALL LINKED TO
SUSTAINABILITY OF. GROWTH AND
DEVELOPMENT AND HOW WE PROVIDE
SKEWS ME FOR. SEEMS LIKE
HOUSING AND URBAN AREAS THAT
YOU CAN BUILD ON SOME OF THE
THEMES THAT WERE OUTLINED IN
YOUR VARIOUS REPORTS- I'M GOING
TO YIELD TO MY COLLEAGUES BUT I
DO WANT TO IN YOUR MIND IF YOU
CAN SORT OF THINK ABOUT THE
ISSUE OF DENSITY- AND HOW THAT
PLAYS. SEES ME IN TERMS OF THE
HAVING MORE PEOPLE LIVING IN
DOWNTOWN SO AND TRANSIT
ORIENTED DEVELOPMENT
OPPORTUNITIES I KNOW IN
PASADENA WE HAVE THE GOAL LINE
HAS CERTAINLY PROVIDED
OPPORTUNITIES FOR GENERAL PLAN-
REVISIONS THAT. BRING GROWTH
AND DEVELOPMENT OUT OF SINGLE
FAMILY NEIGHBORHOODS IN INTO
THE CORE PARTS OF THE CITIES SO
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT I HAD A FLASHBACK
TO THOSE DAYS SO- IF YOU CAN
KIND OF THINK ABOUT. WHAT
DENSITY ROLE THAT PLAYS IN
TERMS OF- CREATING THE
SUSTAINABLE STREETS AND A GREEN
MOBILITY AND HOW THAT ALL COMES
TOGETHER I THINK THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL- BUT ALL YOU'LL TO.
CENTER LABOR. THANK YOU SORRY
MUST VOICE OF AND- SO WANT TO
START WITH WAS IT MISS HOW.
HAGUE SORRY I WAS IN THE
RESTROOM- WE JUST I JUST WAS IN
THE TEAM LEYVA ABSOLUTELY LOVES
THIS RETURN STRATEGIC GROWTH
COUNCIL WE JUST SO APPRECIATE
ALL THE WORK THAT YOU DO- AND
ARE ALWAYS LOOKING TO PARTNER
WITH YOU. AND THEN ALSO TO SAY
PUBLICLY HOW MUCH WE APPRECIATE
THE GOVERNOR FUNDING SB TEN
SEVENTY TWO- VERY EXCITED ABOUT
WHAT WE HOPE THAT WILL DO FOR
THE ENTIRE STATE- AND YOU KNOW
I A ALSO JUST YOU KNOW WHAT YOU
TALKED ABOUT WITH HOUSING BEING
CLOSE TO TRANSIT AND WHATNOT.
AND AS YOU WELL KNOW WE HAD A
BILL THAT WE DEBATED AND
DEBATED ABOUT SEVEN HOURS OVER
TWO DAYS ON THE SENATE FLOOR
THING ABOUT THAT YEAH. AND YOU
KNOW I'M I'M DISAPPOINTED THAT-
MORE OF MY COLLEAGUES- DIDN'T
DO THE RIGHT THING A VOTE FOR
THE BILL SO THAT WE COULD GET
IT OFF THE FLOOR AND SEND IT
OVER TO THE ASSEMBLY- WE CAN
CONTINUE TO PRETEND. LIKE WE'RE
DOING THE RIGHT THING
EVERYWHERE BUT WERE NOT AND YOU
KNOW I'VE SAID MANY TIMES THAT
YOU KNOW IF YOU LEAVE IT TO THE
STATE WE MIGHT SOMETHING THAT
YOU DON'T LIKE- TO OUR LOCAL
CITY. AND I THINK THAT SB FIVE
WAS VERY- I THINK A LOT OF
PEOPLE DID NOT COMPLETELY
UNDERSTAND IT I THINK THERE'S A
LOT OF CONFUSION AROUND IT- BUT
THE I THINK IT WAS A REALLY
GOOD BILL. AND I'M SORRY THAT
IT DID NOT- GET OUT OF THE
SENATE AND I'M SURE WE'VE GOT
SOMETHING ELSE COMING BUT MY
FRUSTRATION AS A LEGISLATOR IS
THAT FOR SIX YEARS WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT HOUSING. BUT
NOTHING DONE NOTHING AND WHEN
YOU DO POLLING- YOU WILL SEE
THAT THE TWO MOST IMPORTANT
THING. TO PEOPLE UP IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS THE
HOMELESSNESS ISSUE AND THE
HOUSING ISSUE SO I WOULD JUST
HOPE THAT OUR ELECTED OFFICIALS
YOU GUYS ARE OFF THE OVER THERE
IN THE ASSEMBLY COULD YOU DON'T
HAVE TO VOTE ON IT. BOB THAT WE
SHOW A LITTLE COURAGE AND WE DO
GOOD WORK AND WE DO IT TO BE
DONE THIS OF PEOPLE IN THE
STATE OF. AT TRIMS XIN. WE
DON'T KNOW ABOUT WELL AND ABOUT
TRANSPORTING OF US BUT SAID
TWENTY WE HAVE WHERE IN ANY
PLACE IN THE SO FROM A LOT OF
THIS IS A HOW WE ELECT BIG RIGS
WE PASSED ON TO GIVE SIGNED A
TWO SO THAT WE DO HAVE SOME
CHECKS ON BIG RIGS WHICH IS AND
THAT WILL BE LIKE. THREE
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND
BIG RIGS OFF OF THE- OUT OF THE
OFF THE ROADS- SO I THINK WE
NEED TO LOOK MORE THAT TO NOT
JUST WHAT ARE WE A SINGLE
PASSENGER'S DOING BUT WHAT ARE
WE DOING TO MAKE SURE IF YOU
KNOW AMAZON AND ALL OF THESE
COMPANIES ARE THE WAVE OF THE
FUTURE THAN WE HAVE TO MAKE
SURE THAT PEOPLE ARE BREATHING
CLEAN AIR- AND THEN THE CITIES
WHO DIDN'T GET THE MONEY WILL
BE IT BECAUSE I TOTALLY AGREE
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO APPLY
AGAIN IF IT'S TOO HARD HOW DO
WE HELP WITH THAT. THAT'S FOR
YOUR CHECKBOOK COMES IN. WITH
ME GET IT I HAVE IT. SURE YOU
JUST DON'T LIKE THE LABEL VERY
WELL. OKAY SO WE JUST MORE
MONEY. I IF THIS. HAS A GOAL OF
DOUBLING IN BIKING IN. TRANCE
AND NEEDS TO FUNDING
COMMENSURATELY WITH THAT YOU
KNOW WITH THAT GOAL SO WE GOT
IT TO SHIFT OUR TRANSPORTATION
INVESTMENTS IN LINE WITH. THOSE
GOALS CLIMB IN AND HEALTH GOALS
WE HAVE. GOT IT I AGREE THANK
YOU TO EVERYONE VERY GOOD
PRESENTATION. ZERO ONE MAKE A
COMMENT WE SPOKE TO THAT WERE
STILL PRESENT. ON IT GOES BACK
TO CENTER I GOT OVER TO YOU
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT WE WORK
TOGETHER- WE HAVE RESULTS AND
LOOKING BACK HERE ON TERRA
SINCE WARREN TO REAL. THE
THIRTY FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT WE DID THE TCC
GROUNDS AS YOU CAN SEE- THE
SLICE OF RARE OVER A HUNDRED
NEW HOMES AFFORDABLE HOMES-
HOUSING TRANSPORTATION OPTIONS
WORK FOR DEVELOPMENT. BUT IT
TOOK A LOT OF WORK TO GET THAT
DONE I THINK- ONE OF THE KEY
THINGS WE DON'T MEAN CENTER ONE
A BUS TOUR REMEMBER. GOING
AROUND THE AREA TALKING ABOUT.
HOW IT'S GOING TO IMPACT- THIS
AREA WHICH IS HUGE NOW. AND
BRING IN THOSE TYPES OF FUNDING
OPPORTUNITIES AND DEVELOPMENTS
HERE- IN ONTARIO IS A LEADER
WHAT THEY'VE DONE WITH THAT
MONEY THEN. LOOKING BACK WE
TALK ABOUT THE ROUTE THE
CONNECTIVITY AND HOW THE
DEVELOPMENT WORKS. PUBLIC AT-
MONTCLAIR WHO'S ALSO LOOKING AT
DOING A LOT OF DEVELOPMENT A
REGARDING THEIR TRANSIT OR IT
GOVERNMENT. TO HOLD UP. BANK
WHERE. ARE ALSO ADAMANTLY WORK
ON. BUILDING AND BRING MORE FOR
BY HOW. AND HOME AS WELL AS
JUST. TO MAKE THE COMMENTS WHAT
WE'RE DO HERE IN THIS. AS WE DO
ABOUT. EVERYTHING WORKING
TOGETHER FOR. BENNETT OUR
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU. THANK
MISTER CHAIR I JUST TO MY I
SAID A FIVE IMAGE AS FOR. BY
SENATOR WIENER. THANK YOU- ANY
THOUGHTS ON THE ISSUE OF
DENSITY AND HOW THAT. AND I
GUESS THAT TO SOME DEGREE TIES
IN WITH THE SENATORS COMMENT.
YES CHAIR HOLDEN- I CAN START-
WITH A FEW THOUGHTS THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING UP WHAT IS KNOWN
IN PLANNER CIRCLES AS THE D.
WORK- WHAT IS THE ROLE OF
DENSITY IN IN CREATING ALL THE
USE IN FOSTERING ALL THE
SOLUTIONS THAT WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT I THINK AB. THERE
ARE SEVERAL THINGS I MEAN FIRST
OF ALL DENSITIES RELATED TO A
LOT OF POSITIVE OUTCOMES THAT
WE TALK ABOUT US POLICY GOALS
NOT JUST ENVIRONMENTAL OUTCOMES
BUT A PHYSICAL HEALTH AND
MENTAL HEALTH AS WEST RIVER-
REFERRED TO- ALSO JUST HUMAN
HAPPINESS THERE ARE SOME REALLY
INTERESTING STUDIES FROM THE
WORLD OF PSYCHOLOGY AND
SOCIOLOGY THAT SUGGEST THAT.
OUR INTERACTIONS WITH OTHER
HUMAN BEINGS NO MATTER WHO WE
ARE NO MATTER WHETHER WHERE A
DEMOCRAT OR REPUBLICAN OLDER
YOUNG- ETCETERA- MAKE US
HAPPIER AS INDIVIDUALS EVEN IF
IT'S JUST SITTING NEXT TO US
SOMEBODY ON ON THE TRAIN OR THE
BUSSER SO YOU KNOW BUYING YOUR
GROCERIES AND SMILING ACROSS
THE- THE CASH REGISTER- SO. ALL
THAT TO SAY WHAT IS THE ROLE
DENSITY AND IN THESE. IN THE
POLICY GOALS THAT WE- I THINK
IT'S AN- TO I THINK THAT AS PRO.
ARE KIND OF APPROVAL CONCEPT
AND WE REALIZE THAT AND WE
WOULD LOVE FOR YOU ALL TO
DOUBLE AND TRIPLE OUR FUNDING
BECAUSE WE SEE THE IMPACT THAT
WE'RE HAVING IN COMMUNITIES BUT
THAT SAID. WE CAN'T DO IT ALONE
AND SO WE OFTEN TALK ABOUT- THE
THAT ARE PROGRAMS AS SORT OF
THE CENTER OF A SERIES OF
CONCENTRIC CIRCLES AND SO AS WE
LEARN WHAT WORKS IN COMMUNITIES
WE LIKE TO THINK ABOUT. HOW DO
WE EMBED THOSE LESSONS LEARNED
IN OTHER POLICIES AND OTHER
LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT AS JUST
SORT OF STANDARD PRACTICE
ACROSS ALL- ALL ENTITIES. AND
WHAT WE SEE WITH RESPECT TO
DENSITY IS THAT IT DOESN'T HAVE
TO BE SCARY. HOME WE SEE ARE
PROJECTS AS SORT OF REALLY EYE
OPENING AND COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVEN'T PREVIOUSLY HAD DENSITY.
AND WHEN THEY COME TO THE
RIBBON CUTTING AND THEY SEE
WHAT DENSITY THAT YOU ARE LOOKS
LIKE. IT'S SORT OF A ABA THAT'S
YOU. I'D TO LIVE THERE UP
THAT'S A REAL ASSET TO OUR
COMMUNITY SO WE SEE THAT PART
OF OUR IMPACT- I WANTED. OUR BY
THE CITY OF LOS. AND WORK ON I.
TO A UNITS AND ALSO OF COURSE
THE LEGISLATURE YOUR LEADERS
ACROSS BOTH HOUSES. TO REALLY
ADVANCE AN AND FOR EIGHTY PAULA
THE PLANNING FOR OF LA INFORMED
RECENTLY THAT- PRIOR TO THE
CITY'S WORK TO ADVANCE THAT.
FUNDING PERMITS. MAKING IT
EASIER AND CHEAPER AND FASTER
TO DO EIGHTY USE AND THEY'VE
DONE A WHOLE SUITE OF. POLICY
MEASURES. BEFORE THEY WERE
PERMITTING AROUND A HUNDRED OR
TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY USE A YEAR
IN THE CITY OF THE LAKE.
CALPERS UP OR OF FOUR THOUSAND
A YEAR AND I IS IN EXIST IN
NAME BUT- THIS. FLOOR AREA
RATIO TO GET. ON YOU- IT
DOESN'T CHANGE THE CHARACTER OF
COMMUNITY SIGNIFICANTLY BUT ONE
OF THE BENEFITS THAT THEY SEE
IS OTHERS AND ADDED IN URBAN
PLANNING- RETAIL FOLLOWS
ROOFTOPS. SO WITH ADDITIONAL.
ADDITIONAL CHEQUE BOOKS AN
ADDITIONAL WALL IT'S IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD. SUDDENLY BUT.
COOL STORY EVERYONE. IN ONE.
ACTUAL WILL BE THERE'S MORE
PEOPLE THAT WALK BY IT EVERY
DAY RATHER MORE PEOPLE THAT
TAKE THE TRAINS YOU KNOW STOP
AND GET A COUPLE COFFEE ON THE
WAY TO. A TO THEIR THEIR PER OF
WORK IT'S ADDRESS OF. JUST A
FEW THOUGHTS THE TOP OF MY
OBVIOUS LOTS TO SAY. THAT HAPPY
TO TRAVEL. WELL WE- WERE THINK
DENSITY IS NECESSARY. ARE YOU
FOR GONNA. FOR MORE. PEOPLE TO
THE NINE. THAT YOU HAVE IMAGINE
THAT WE TO GROW A LITTLE BIT IN
THE RE. I THINK THE EAST IS
HOUSE. DENSE AS OFTEN. WHEN
PEOPLE GET REALLY OF ABOUT DÂN.
THEY IMAGINE. SKYSCRAPERS UP IN
THE NAY. AND I THAT'S REALLY.
THAT OVER EXPRESS AND THOUGHT.
OF THE IDEA IS TO BE ABLE TO-
PROVIDE. THE ABILITY OF PEOPLE
TO LIVE CLOSE TO WHERE THEY
WORK FOR EXAMPLE- THE REASON
YOU HAVE CITIES IN CITY CENTERS
BECAUSE THERE'S DENSITY. THE
REASON- CENTRAL BUSINESS
DISTRICTS WORKERS BECAUSE OF
DENSITY. HAVE THIS CATCHMENT
POPULATION THAT THERE TO- BE A
BIT TO AVAIL THEMSELVES OF
SERVICES AND- AND COMMERCIAL
ACTIVITIES ARE GOING ON- WE
WILL STILL PREDOMINANTLY HOW
SINGLE FAMILY HOUSING. IN MOST
OF OUR REGION AND THAT'S NOT A
CHANGE PEOPLE THAT WANT TO
LEAVE AND- THEN. ONE AND MAYBE-
ARE THREE OR FOUR UNITS ON A
CAR OR EVEN. ON ON FIVE ACRE
RANCH IS STILL BE TO DO THE-
HOWEVER AS WE INVEST. IN
INFRASTRUCTURE. LIKE AND WHICH
IS AN ALLEN OF OUR PLAN WE
THINK. THE WAY BE IT WILL BE ON
WHY I MEAN IF. TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE. OF THIS IS THIS
REALLY LINE ALL AND BUILD
AROUND THEIR BANK ARE CREE
DIVIDE. THAT MANY OF US TRAVEL
ALL OVER THE TO GO YOU KNOW
PLACES CREE THAT VIBRANCE
AROUND WE CAN DO THAT REAL
SMARTLY AND STILL OFFER.
AFFORDABLE AND WORKFORCE
HOUSING VERY CLOSE TO WHERE
PEOPLE TRANSPORT AND THAT
ALLOWS THEM TO REALLY BEGIN TO
CUT DOWN ON THE COMMUTE
DISTANCES. FARTHER OUT THERE
BECAUSE IF WE IF WE HAVE TO ADD
A MORE JOBS AND MORE- MORE
PEOPLE WE NEED TO THEN BUILD
EVEN MORE CLOSER TO THOSE JOBS
AND PEOPLE. WE ARE TODAY LOSING
TALENT. BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
PORTABLE HOUSING OUR YOUNG
FOLKS WE HAVE I THINK WE CAN
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE. FOUR YEAR
UNIVERSITIES IN OUR REGION.
THEY GRAB WITH THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE THOUSANDS OF YOUNG
TALENT EVERY MAY JUNE. MOST OF
THEM LEAVE THE REGION. THAT'S
NOT SUSTAINABLE FOR US AND I
THINK IT'S REALLY AND- ISSUE
FOR US WE DON'T ABOUT. WE
CREATE MORE HOUSING AND TO
CREATE MORE HOUSING WE HAVE TO.
BE A LITTLE MORE INTENSIFIED.
BUT I DO APPRECIATE THE AND I
THINK IT'S ALSO A- FOR US
BECAUSE WE'RE- TO HAVE THIS
THESE PAY. CONVERSE IN LIFE US
BUT ALL. OF THOSE WHO ARE IN A
TWO AND WHO LIE STREAMING TO
GET A BETTER SENSE OF WHAT ALL
OF THE SOLUTIONS TO THESE
PROBLEMS REPRESENT. SOME OF
THEM WE MAY BE ABLE TO GET OUR
ARMS AROUND FROM A LEGISLATIVE.
PERSPECTIVE AND I THINK THIS IT
UNDER HIGHLIGHTED A COUPLE OF
BILLS THAT ARE ARE UNDER
CONSIDERATION- HAVE BEEN UNDER
CONSIDERATION. BUT ALSO THROUGH
THE BUDGET SUPPORTING THE
GOVERNOR'S EFFORTS IN TERMS OF
TRYING TO GET- TOOLS QUITE
FRANKLY AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
HANDS TO BE ABLE TO EFFECTIVELY.
BUILD BUT THERE IS A ROAD AND
WE HAVE TO CONTINUE TO- FIGURE
OUT HOW BEST TO BRIDGE THE GAP
IN TERMS OF COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE. TRYING TO MAINTAIN A
CERTAIN QUALITY LIFE FOR THE
SAME TOP RECOGNIZE. THAT. AS WE
START TO EXPAND ON REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION OPTIONS AND THEY-
INTERSECT THERE CAN. IS WILL CA
OP. FOR HOUSING TO BE BUILT-
THAT WILL ALLOW PEOPLE TO HAVE
ACCESSIBILITY- TO PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION RAIL
TRANSPORTATION BUT OTHER FORMS-
WE WERE WE WERE SAYING
HIGHLIGHTED. SO IT IS A
CONVERSATION OF CONNECTING THE
DOTS AND I DO APPRECIATE. THE
FOCUS OF THIS PANELS-
PRESENTATION- WE THANK YOU FOR
THAT- IF YOU CAN STICK AROUND
WE LOVE TO HAVE YOU AND IF I
ANY. COMMENTS FROM THE PUBLIC
TIE INTO YOUR ISSUE THAT-
YOU'LL HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
RESPOND AS WELL SO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION THIS
MORNING. THE THIRD CONCLUDING.
OF OUR ATTENTION ON
SPECIFICALLY ON ADDRESSING THE
NEEDS OF VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. IT WILL LOOK AT
THE VALUE OF PROGRAMS
CONNECTING STUDENTS TO SCHOOLS
AND HOW QUALITY TRANSIT CAN
PROMOTE EQUITY AND ACCESS FOR
FINANCIALLY BURDENED WRITERS.
MARIANA HER AT- JONES FROM A C.
T. L. A. OR ACT LA WILL TOUCH
UPON THE IMPORTANCE OF QUALITY
BUS TRANSIT OPTIONS FOR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. AS
DIRECTOR POLICY IN
COMMUNICATION AT MOVE LA GLORIA
OLEN WILL DISCUSS HOW MAKING
TRANSIT MORE AFFORDABLE
PROVIDES OPPORTUNITIES AND REAL
THAT RELY. AND RELEASE FINING
PRESSURES. FROM STUDENT RAW
CHIEF OFFICER FOR OMNI TRANS
AND- MICHAEL TURNER DEPUTY
EXECUTIVE OFFICER FOR GOVERNOR
RELATIONS AT LA METRO WILL
TOUCH UPON THEIR CURRENT
STUDENT TRANSIT PASS PROGRAM IN
THE FUTURE OF CLEANER BUS
TECHNOLOGY. SO WELCOME ALL OF
YOU AND LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR
PRESENTATION. A MARIANNA WOULD
GO FIRST I REALLY. NOTHING
NUMBER THE LOOKING THINK CAN MY
THAT. THANK YOU ARE YOU AGAIN
FOR AND US TO PART OF THE
HEARING SO I MIGHT AND I WITH
THE AT THE FOR CAN TRY. ON AND
I'LL BE MY REMARK ON JUST. WHAT
WE SEE AS SOME OF THE- OF I. TO
QUALITY TRYING FOR COMMUNITY. I
READ AND COUNTY REGION FOCUS ME
IN OUR CITY AND I LIKE HOW AND
AT SOME SOLUTION THAT WE'VE
ALREADY IDENTIFIED IN
OPPORTUNITIES THAT ARE-
PRESENT. SO THE ALLIANCE FOR
COMMUNITY TRANSIT IS. HOLD OF
SEVEN GROUPS WORKING AROUND THE
ISSUES OF TRANSIT AND HOUSING
SO IT INCLUDES TENANT RIGHTS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT GROUPS-
AND TRANSIT EQUITY
ORGANIZATIONS. AND WE WANTED TO
COME TOGETHER TO LOOK AT POLICY
SOLUTIONS- AND CAMPAIGNS TO
ENSURE THAT WE CAN HAVE ACCESS
TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING NEAR
TRANSIT. AND ENSURE THAT WE CAN
CREATE THE BEST QUALITY AND
EFFICIENT- TRANSIT SYSTEM-
POSSIBLE FOR THE FOR THOSE WHO
NEEDED- WE CAME TOGETHER AFTER
THE PASSAGE OF MEN MEASURE ARE.
IN TWENTY ELEVEN TO REALLY MAKE
SURE THAT FUTURE INVESTMENTS IN
PUBLIC TRANSIT ARE REALLY OP
BENEFITING AND UPLIFTING-
TRANSIT RIDERS AND THE
RESIDENTS LIVING YOUR TRANSIT
AND NOT DISPLACING THEM. SO
KNOW ALLEY HAS A MAJOR TRAFFIC-
AND CONGESTION TRAFFIC
CONGESTION AND HOUSING PROBLEM
AND THEY ARE LINKED FOR DECADES
WE HAVE FOCUSED ON AND FAVORITE
SINGLE FAMILY ZONING SUBURBAN
SPRAWL AND KERR CENTRIC-
DEVELOPMENT PATTERNS ON A AND
ALSO THE LACK OF. INVESTMENTS
IN TRANSIT HAVE REALLY CREATED
A SYSTEM THAT IS UNDER RESOURCE
WERE ROOM WE OVER RELY ON CARS
AND MOST REST MOST PEOPLE ARE
DRIVING TO WORK ALONE. THIS HAS
IMPACTS ON ALL OF US BUT WE-
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT THIS
REALLY HAS DISPROPORTION
IMPACTS ON COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
AND ALL INCOME RESIDENTS. IN
ADDITION TO REALLY IMPACTING
OUR POCKETBOOKS AND OUR
CLIMATE. AND SOMEONE. SO IN IN
TWENTY. WE PASSED MEASURE M.
AND THAT'S CREATING THE LARGEST
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECT. IN THE
IN THE U. S. CURRENTLY SO IT'S
OVER A HUNDRED SIXTY BILLION
DOLLARS BEING INVESTED- ON
GOING FOR- TRANSIT BUT ALSO
ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION MODES AND
IT IS YOU KNOW SOMETHING THAT
IS GOING TO REALLY TRANSFORM
THE REGION ON THROUGHOUT THE
NEXT. SEVERAL DECADES AND WHAT
WE'RE SEEING IS THAT ITS FOCUS
A LOT ON RAIL WHICH IS
WONDERFUL AND WE NEED MORE
CONNECTIVITY IN THE IN THE
REGION BUT 70% OF METRO USERS
ACTUALLY RIDE THE BUS. I AND
YOU KNOW WE ARE NOT INVESTING
AS MUCH IN OUR BUS SYSTEM
CURRENTLY AND OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL A OVER THE LAST DECADE
IN FACT METRO HASN'T LOST
WRITERS UP 225% OF WRITERS HAVE
STOPPED USING BUSES ALTOGETHER
THERE MANY FACTORS INCLUDING-
YOU KNOW ACCESS TO DRIVER'S
LICENSE FOR BOOKS I DIDN'T HAVE
IT BEFORE. YOU'RE NOT BEING
ABLE TO AFFORD TO LIVE NEAR BUS
BUS LINES ARE OR- YOU KNOW
THOSE TRANSIT RICH COMMUNITIES
BUT IT'S ALSO THE LACK OF A
VERY HIGH QUALITY AND RELIABLE
AND DEPENDABLE SYSTEM THAT WILL
REALLY GET PEOPLE TO THEIR
DESTINATION ON TIME AND YOU
KNOW WHERE WE KNOW THAT WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE ACCESS TO A
SHELTER SO THAT. YOU KNOW FOR
PEOPLE THAT ARE OUR THAT OUR
HAVE SPECIAL NEEDS CAN ACTUALLY
USE OUR BUS SYSTEM SO IT'S
REALLY CRITICAL THAT WE ARE
DOING SOMETHING ABOUT THEM.
REVIVING OUR BUS AND IMPROVING
OUR BUSES. SO YOU KNOW WE KNOW
THAT IN MANY IN THE MEASURE
REGION OF USERS OF OUR TRANSIT.
THEY ARE MATURE PEOPLE OVER SIX
FOR. AND THE LOW INCOME SEVEN
OVERSEE FOR OF. US MET RIDERS
LAW BURNED LESS THAN TWO
THOUSAND A YEAR WITH THE MEAT
INCOME FOR BUST OF. A LITTLE
OVER THOUSAND DOLLARS. AND FOR
RAIL RYE IT'S ABOUT THIRTY
THOUSAND A SO A VERY LOW INCOME
POPULATION VERY OF OWNER POP
AND IT'S ALSO A VERY. UP A
POPULATION THAT DOESN'T HAVE
ACCESS TO TWO VEHICLES- WE HAVE
SEEN THAT ABOUT 10% OF. BLACK
HOUSEHOLDS IN THE ALLEY COUNTY
AREA DO NOT HAVE ACCESS TO A
CAR IN ABOUT ELEVEN PERCENT. OF
LATINO. HOUSEHOLDS DO NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO A CAR SO THESE ARE
TRANSIT DEPENDENT ON. RESIDENTS
THAT REALLY NEED ACCESS TO A
GOOD QUALITY TRANSIT SYSTEM.
AND I MENTIONED THAT OVER 70%
OF US WRITERS. ARE AT 70% A
MEASURE USERS ARE USING THE BUS
SYSTEM BUT WE ARE LOSING. THE
OF BASS MAJORITY OF BUS RIDERS
AND THIS IS THE LARGEST DECLINE
NATIONALLY IT'S- A PERCENT THAT
METRO HAS LOST OVER THE LAST
DECADE. I'M ONE OF THE- POINTS
AN INMATE ABOUT KNOW IT'S BEEN
MEN BEFORE FROM OTHER PANELISTS
THAT WE HAVE VERY- BIG GOALS
FOR MEETING CARBON REDUCTION
CARBON EMISSION REDUCTIONS- AND
YOU KNOW HOPEFULLY WE ARE DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO REACH
THOSE GOALS BUT- UNLESS WE ARE.
TAKING THE BUS RIDERSHIP LOS
VERY SERIOUSLY WE CANNOT
ACTUALLY MEET SOME OF OUR GOAL
SO. IN THIS SLIDE IT SHOWS
THAT- THIS GAG REGION MAKES UP
OVER 50% OF TRANSIT- TRIPS THE
SHARE OF TRANSIT TO TRIP SO WE
NEED TO REALLY RECOVER. THE 25%
IF NOT MORE OF TRYING A BUS
RIDERS TO ACTUALLY. OF ATTEMPT
TO MEET SOME OF OUR CLIMATE
GOALS- AND OF CARBON EMISSION
REDUCTIONS. SO I THE AS A COLD
A OR- IS REAL YOU KNOW FACED
WITH- THE PRESS ORGANIZATIONS
AND- TRANSIT RIDERS WHO USE THE
SYSTEM EVERY DAY WE'VE
IDENTIFIED SOME SOLUTIONS- AND
METRO IS ACTUALLY A LEADER IN
REALLY IDENTIFYING SOLUTIONS
AND- IMPLEMENTING THEM SO. WE
HAVE A YOU KNOW A LEADER IN THE
REGION BUT WE DO WANT TO SEE
THE AGENCY DO MORE TO ADDRESS
THE ISSUE OF FALLING RIDERSHIP
AND REALLY AND IMPROVE OUR
SYSTEM FOR EVERYONE- IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN METRO PASS THE FIRST
OF ITS KIND. TRANSIT ORIENTED
TRANSIT ORIENTED COMMUNITIES
POLICY- WHICH RELATES TO THE
PANEL THAT SPOKE PREVIOUSLY BUT
IT REALLY IS- LOOKING AT
ADDRESSING COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND DISPLACEMENT ALONG THE
TRANSIT CORRIDORS- AND THIS IS
KEY TO REALLY BE ABLE TO. TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE ARE ABLE
TO KEEP RESIDENTS THAT ARE
DEPENDENT ON TRANSIT TO STAY IN
THOSE TRANSIT RICH
NEIGHBORHOODS- YOU KNOW THIS IS
A GREAT POLICY BUT WE- DON'T
HAVE. FUNDING ALLOCATED FOR
THIS POLICY SO IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT IT HAS TEETH AND
THAT MORE FUNDING IS ON CREATED
FOR THE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
THAT ARE SEEN YOU PUBLIC
INFRASTRUCTURE- INVESTMENTS TO
ENSURE THAT THEY CAN. DO
TRANSIT NEIGHBORHOOD PLANNING
OUR COMMUNITY AND LAND PLANNING
TO COMMENT EIGHT YOU BETTER
PROTECTIONS FOR LOW INCOME
RENTERS AND THAT WRITERS IN
THESE JURISDICTIONS- ANOTHER'S
NEED A SOLUTION. IS YOU KNOW
THE ISSUE OF. I RELY THIRTY AND
IMPROVE TO THE BUS SYSTEM. WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT AS YOU
KNOW MATCH IS CREATE A
IMPROVING THE BUS SYSTEM WE-
ARE TALK ABOUT A LITTLE BIT. IN
A BAY. THEY ARE IN KNOW BUSTED
A LAY. I YOU KNOW IMP THE THAT
AREAS THAT WE HAVE SHELTER
THERE'S BETTER INFRASTRUCTURE
NEAR- BUS STOPS AND AREAS WHERE
PEOPLE CAN ACCESS THE BUS
SYSTEM. AND THAT THEY RUN ON
WEEKENDS AND EVENINGS AND YOU
KNOW BETTER SERVICE SO THAT
IT'S MORE RELIABLE AND OUR-
COME FASTER. SO THOSE ARE SOME
OF THE THINGS THAT WE WANT TO
SEE AS WELL- WE ALSO YOU KNOW
METRO IS RECENTLY FOR THE
TAKING THE LEADERSHIP OF
ADDRESSING THE ISSUE OF EQUITY.
AND LOOKING HOW WE'RE YOU KNOW
WE'RE DEFINING EQUITY FOR THE
FUNDING THAT THE ALLOCATING
GOING FORWARD- AND THE WAY THAT
THEY DEFINED IT IS NEAT I'M-
THEY'RE CALLING THEM EQUITY
FOR. CAN BE SO. OUR SENSES
TRACTS WITH LOW CAR. WE'RE COME
THAT HAVE. THAT HAVE LOW CAR.
HOUSEHOLD WITH NO CARS THESE
HOUSES WITH NO CAR AND LOW IN
CAN. SO PRIORITIZING FUN. IN
THE AREAS I HAVE HAD DECENT FOR
MANY DECADES AND ENSURING THAT
AREAS THAT YOU KNOW DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO CAR ACTUALLY HAVE
BETTER AND- QUALITY TRANSIT
ACCESS. SO ENSURING THAT YOU
KNOW ANY TRANSIT PLANNING AND-
FUNDING IT REALLY IS
PRIORITIZING THESE EQUITY FOCUS
COMMUNITIES. AS A WAY TO
ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS AND WE REALLY WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT- WITH THIS
MAJOR BILLION DOLLAR HUNDRED
YOU KNOW SIXTY BILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT THAT THERE ARE. MORE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PARTICIPATORY
BUDGETING SO THAT COMMUNITY
MEMBERS ARE REALLY INVOLVED
TRANSIT RIDERS ARE INVOLVED IN
HOW THESE FUNDING HOW THESE
FUNDS ARE ALLOCATED TO REALLY
ENHANCE THEIR EXPERIENCE AND
FEEL- JUST REALLY CONNECTED AND
WANT TO REALLY USE THE SYSTEM-
VERSES YOU KNOW PUTTING DOWN.
THERE DOLLARS INTO AREAS THAT
ARE NOT REALLY IMPROVING THE
TRANSIT SYSTEM ARE ENHANCING
EXPERIENCE THE EXPERIENCE OF
TRANSIT RIDERS- AND- THERE ARE
A LOT OF A- AS I MENTIONED.
AHMED IS REESE THEIR BUS
SYSTEMS THEY THEY INITIATED
SURVEYS AND ARE STUDYING HOW
THEY CAN YOU KNOW RE RE COOPER
GET BACK THERE TRANSIT THE BUS
WRITERS THAT THEY'VE LOST- AND
YOU KNOW WHAT KIND OF A NETWORK
OF BUSES WILL WORK FOR OUR
REGION- SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT. THERE IS- GOOD PLANS
GOING FORWARD METRO RECENTLY-
ADOPTED WHAT THEY'RE CALLING A
TRANSIT FIRST MODEL- WHICH WILL
HELP- RECOVER- SOME OF THE
TRANSIT RIDERS AT THE HAVE BEEN
LOST BUT THERE IS VERY LITTLE
FUNDING ALLOCATED THERE WAS
ANOTHER MODEL CALLED THE FUTURE
FUNDING MODEL THAT THE- WE'RE
CONSIDERING BUT DECIDED NOT TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH SO WE WANT TO
JUST MAKE SURE THAT. YOU KNOW
THERE IS A LOT MORE FUNDING
ALLOCATED TO THE BUS- REDESIGN
A BUS RESTRUCTURING TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE. TAKING THIS
VERY SERIOUSLY OF RECOVERING
LOST ON BUS WRITERS AND
INSURING THAT WE ARE CREATING
THE BEST AND MOST EFFICIENT BUS
SYSTEM- FOR THE REGION AND
THERE'S ALSO BEEN A
CONVERSATION ABOUT CONGESTION
PRICING OR CONGESTION RELIEF
MODELS METROS ALSO CURRENTLY
STUDYING THIS. AND YOU KNOW
THEY'RE THEY'RE TALKING A LOT
ABOUT- HOW TO USE THOSE FUNDS
TO REALLY- AND CONGESTION
PRICING JUST TO REALLY ANA
SHORT WAY IS THAT IT WOULD
CREATE- KIND OF LIKE- IT WOULD
PRICE. ROLE THAT ARE IN THE
DURING PEAK I. SO THAT IF
YOU'RE A DRY YOU WOULD HAVE PAY
YOU THE ROAD KINDA LIKE TOLL
ROAD WRITER FAST BUT THIS IS A
WAY TO GET PEOPLE OUT OF YOU
KNOW I DON'T THEIR CARS USING
THE PUBLIC TRANSIT SYSTEM BUT
WHATEVER REVENUE GENERATED
FISCAL BACK. INTO OUR TRANSIT
SYSTEM BUT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE'S- WE'RE LOOKING AT
IT THROUGH AN EQUITY LANDS
ENSURING THAT WE CAN. GET
EXEMPTION FOR LOW INCOME
DRIVERS RIGHT BECAUSE THIS WILL
HAVE IMPACT ON A LOT OF DRIVERS
AND REALLY MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
REVENUE REVENUE GENERATED. IS
GOING BACK TO THE BUS SYSTEM
AND TO COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN
DISINVEST IT FOR MANY YEARS AND
FINALLY. ANOTHER BUT YOU NEED
IS A NATIONAL DISCUSSION FAIR
FOR TRANSIT. IT SOUNDS IN A
WHILE BUT WE WANT YOU KNOW IT'S
REALLY WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE CAN SEE THAT IN OUR
LIFETIME. THAT OUR SYSTEM ARE
TO TRANSIT SYSTEM IS ACTUALLY
UNIVERSAL PUBLIC GOOD AND THAT
IT'S FAIR FREE FOR ALL OF US.
WHO ARE YOU KNOW. NOT INVESTING
OUR TAX DOLLARS INTO THIS. AND
YOU KNOW WE ALREADY SEEN THIS
IN THE CITY OF OLYMPIA
WASHINGTON. IN KANSAS CITY
MISSOURI THEY JUST CREATED
THERE. BUT THERE RAIL SYSTEM
AND BUS SYSTEMS FARE FREE. HI
N. ON MONTGOMERY. THERE IS OF.
A SIMILAR PROGRAM. FOR YOUTH SO
THEY MAKE TRANSIT PASSES FREE
FOR YOU THEN THEY'VE SEEN A 50%
INCREASE IN RIDERSHIP. SINCE
IMPLEMENTING THIS PROGRAM SO
THERE'S A DEMAND THERE IS AN
EXCITEMENT ABOUT HAVING ACCESS
TO TRANSIT AND WE KNOW THAT
MORE PEOPLE. WILL USE IT IF
IT'S FREE FOR THEM- FOR YOU
KNOW FOR EITHER SHORT TERM OR
FOR LONG TERM. SO YOU KNOW JUST
THESE ARE SOME REALLY GREAT
OPPORTUNITIES AND- IT'S-
SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION AND
THE DIALOGUE GOING FORWARD SO
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU. HER
NEXT WORDS. I'M NAME IS OAKLAND
AND WORK FOR AN OR AND NO
CALLED LA WE WORK MOSTLY ON
TRANSPORTATION BUT ALSO ON
HOUSING AND CLIMATE CHANGE WE
WORKED WITH CLOSELY WITH METRO
ON MEASURES ARE AND THEN AND WE
LIKE TO FIND WAY FIND SOURCES
OF MONEY TO HELP GOVERNMENT DO
GOOD THINGS AND I'M VERY
HONORED TO BE ASKED TO SPEAK TO
YOU TODAY THAT STUDENT TRANSIT
PASSES BECAUSE WE WORK WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN. AND
STUDENT TRANSIT PASSES FOR THE
NUMBER ONE YEARS. SO ON I THINK
AS- WITH THE FIRST. OKAY ON A
GUESS THAT IS IT ON. I REALLY
THINK THE IF WOULD ABOUT CA CAL
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT ABOUT
CONNECTING STUDENTS TO
OPPORTUNITY AND I'D JUST I
THINK WE HAVE HE KNOWS THE MOST
AWESOME ROAD SYSTEM IN THE
WORLD BUT IT'S TIME TO START
ADDING OTHER ELEMENTS LIKE
TRANSIT AND BIKING AND WALKING
AND BIKE SELECTED BIKES AND
SCOOTERS IN YES. SKATEBOARDS
FOR REBEL AND- I THINK THAT BUT.
IT'S THAT SUDDENLY ALL OF THE-
PEOPLE. WE NEED. FIVE THE
PRESENTATION. SO AND LIGHTEN
MARIANI'S. SUDDENLY THERE
ALWAYS INTEREST IN TRADE PASS
AND I'VE WHEN I WAS THE THINK
ABOUT THIS POINT I STARTED ON
LAW A WEEK AGO LOAN BUT I FOR
ALL THESE TO AND JUST THE LAST
WEEKS WHERE CITIES OF THE ARE
TALK ABOUT MAKING TRANSIT FREE
WHICH WHILE. AND I CAN IT WORK
I DON'T KNOW BUT I THINK IT'S
BECAUSE- CITIES EVERYWHERE
FACING THE SAME PROBLEMS WHICH
ARE IN AS TRAFFIC AND IT'S
POVERTY AND ITS- DECLINING
RIDERSHIP AND IT'S GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS AND CLIMATE
CHANGE. SO ON WE ARE- WHY
STUDENT TRANSIT PASSES. YOU
KNOW WHAT WE BELIEVE THAT
COLLEGE IS HARD AND THAT IT
SEEMS TO BE OR CALL IT CAN BE
HARD AND IT SEEMS TO BE GETTING
HARDER IN WE REALLY NEED AN
EDUCATED WORKFORCE IN
CALIFORNIA TO REMAIN
ECONOMICALLY COMPETITIVE BUT
IT'S INTERESTING STUDENTS ARE
POOR AND A STUDY BY ACCOUNT BY
CSU IN TWENTY SIXTEEN FOUND
THAT AN ESTIMATED 10% OF CSU
STUDENTS ARE HOMELESS AND
ALMOST TWENTY FIVE PERCENT. OUR
FOOD IN SECURE. AND YEAR THERE
WAS A STUDY OF FORTY THOUSAND
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS THAT FOUND THAT HAVE
STRUGGLED TO BUY FOOD. A
MAJORITY HAVE A- OF THE
STUDENTS HAVE TROUBLE PAYING
THE RENT AND 20% ARE HOMELESS
AND. WHEN STUDENTS IN THE FACE
OF SCHOOLS LIKE THESE YOU'RE
NOT GOING TO DO VERY WELL AT
SCHOOL AND- IT WAS INTERESTING
LAST WEEK AT METRO THERE WAS A
LOT OF QUESTIONS THAT. EVERY
STUDENT TRANSIT PASSES FOR LA
U. S. T. COLLEGE STUDENTS. LA
U. S. D. IS STUDENTS KIDS WOULD
TUNES IN LOS ANGELES AND- IT
WAS SHOT TO ME. FIND OUT THE
80% ALL YOU DIS LIVE IN POVERTY.
AND I JUST OBVIOUSLY PAYING FOR
TRANSPORTATION THEN BECOMES A
VERY BIG DEAL FOR THE STUDENTS
AND THEIR FAMILIES AND A LOT OF
THE STUDENTS. THEN EVADE PAYING
FARE IS AND THEY GET CAUGHT BY
THE POLICE AND THEN THEY GET
TRAPPED UP IN THE- IN THE YOU
KNOW. CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
THAT'S A BIT HARSH BUT THEY GET
YOU KNOW IT LEADS THEM IN THE
WRONG DIRECTION. SO AND THERE'S
ALSO A VERY FAMOUS STUDY THAT
WAS DONE IN TWENTY FIFTEEN BY
HARBOR THAT TALKS THAT FOUND
THAT ACCESS TO TRANSPORTATION
IS THE SINGLE BIGGEST FACTOR.
IN THE ODDS OF THIS GAPING
POVERTY AND AVOIDING
HOMELESSNESS SO CLEARLY ON.
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO GIVE
STUDENTS ACCESS. TO
TRANSPORTATION. END NEXT BUT SO
IT'S NOT JUST STUDENTS THE
BENEFIT IT'S ALSO THE SCHOOLS
AND COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES
BECAUSE- THIS REDUCES DRIVE
LOAN MODE SHARE IT REDUCES THE
NEED FOR SCHOOL TO BUILD
PARKING STRUCTURES WHEN THAT
LAND IS EXPENSIVE IT CAN BE
USED FOR. THE BUILDINGS THAT
HAVE TO DO WITH EDUCATION
INSTEAD REDUCES. PARKING
DEMAND- COSTS CAN BE SHARED
THERE WAS UCLA STUDY THAT
FOUND- STUDENTS ARE WILLING TO
HELP PAY FOR THESE PASSES ON.
AND IT WAS INTERESTING LAST
YEAR EIGHT OF NINE ON. LA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
SCHOOLS VOTED TO ADD THIRTEEN
DOLLARS THE STUDENTS VOTED TO
CHARGE THEMSELVES AN EXTRA
THIRTEEN DOLLARS PER SEMESTER
TO HELP PAY FOR DISCOUNT PASSES
FOR MET METRO. AND IT'S ALSO
INTERESTING NUMBER ONE CAUSE OF
ABSENTEE ISN'T K. THROUGH
TWELVE IS LACK OF
TRANSPORTATION AND THAT
OBVIOUSLY DRAMATICALLY REDUCES
THE FUNDING PER STUDENT
RECEIVED BY SCHOOLS. IN. SO
THERE'S A CONUNDRUM YOU KNOW
METRO HAS A PROBLEM DESPITE
RAIL BUILDING BOOM AND ALL OF
THE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT
WE'RE SPENDING ON BUILDING A
BIGGER RAIL SYSTEM THERE IS
STILL RIDERSHIP IS DECLINING
AND ON THE OTHER HAND- THE LA
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT FOR
EXAMPLE HAS A POVERTY PROBLEM
SO YOU KNOW WITH 80% OF THE
STUDENTS. LIVING BELOW THE
POVERTY LINE SO WHAT IF METRO
AND LA U. S. D. HELD ONE AT.
AND IN FACT THAT IS WHAT
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT DOING
THERE WAS A BIG THE BOARD
MEETING LAST WEEK THERE WAS A
BIG DISCUSSION ABOUT WHETHER ON
METRO COULD PROVIDE FREE.
TRANSIT PASSES TO K. THROUGH
TWELVE OR K. THROUGH I THINK TO
ALL STUDENTS ACTUALLY AND- SO
THEY'RE WORKING ON IT AND-
INDEX BUT BUT I SHOULD ALSO
GOING FOR I'M SORRY YOU KNOW.
EIGHT STUDENTS COULD FILL IN
SEATS. DURING OFF PEAK HOUR IN
THAT COULD HELP NOT ONLY
INCREASE TOTAL TRANSIT
RIDERSHIP BUT IT COULD HELP
REDUCE OPERATING SUBSIDIES IT
COULD CAUSE HIGHER DEMAND FOR
TRANSIT WHICH ALSO TENDS TO
RESULT IN BETTER SERVICE. IT
COULD YOU IMPROVE DECLINING
RIDERSHIP IT COULD PRODUCE
TRAFFIC SO. THE PUBLIC THE
GENERAL PUBLIC WOULD ALSO
BENEFIT BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY AGAIN
DRESSES ALL THE BIG PROBLEMS
TRAFFIC BY TAKING CARS OFF THE
ROAD REDUCE PARKING DEMAND
REDUCES AIR POLLUTION. AND
AGAIN WE NEED EDUCATED
WORKFORCE THIS PICTURE HOWEVER
DOES NOT REALLY DEPICT THE
PROBLEM BECAUSE- THE FOR A FIVE
THREE THIS IS A GOOD DAY ON THE
FOUR OH FIVE AS ALL THESE CARS
MANY OF THEM PEOPLE WHO ARE
HEADING TO UCLA TO GO TO
SCHOOL. ON IN ITS SCHOOLS
ESPECIALLY BIG ONES LIKE UCLA
OR YOU SEE SUN OR IS STILL A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. THE LOTS
LOTS OF. WHICH IS OF COURSE THE
BIGGEST OF GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS. SO THERE IS THAT WE
GOT INTO THIS BUSINESS AND HAVE
BEEN TRYING TO WITH. AND WE'RE
VERY HARD WITH MEMBER. IS THE
X. DIRECTOR OF MOVE LA WORK
WITH CENTER BECAUSE- ON BILL
THE UNC. THIS ALSO STUDENT PASS
PROGRAM WHICH THE CALL AND BLUE
BUT- AND BEEN HOT EXTREMELY
SUCCESSFUL BECAUSE HALF OF ALL
STUDENTS FACULTY FACULTY AND
STAFF NOW USE TRANSIT TO GET TO
CAMPUS. AND ON. THE WAY THIS IS
DONE IS THE SCHOOL PAYS PART.
AND THE BIG BLUE BUS DISCOUNTS
THE TRANSIT PASSES AND STUDENTS
ALSO PAY A PART THEY THEY PAY
NINE DOLLARS PER SEMESTER WHICH
IS NOT VERY MUCH MONEY AND THEY
CAN RIDE ANY LINE ANY TIME FOR
FREE. WHAT'S NOT FOR FREE THEY
PAID NINE DOLLARS BUT ON THIS
IS THE WAY IT'S DONE IS WHEN
STUDENTS REGISTER FOR CLASSES
THEY CAN THEY DON'T OPT IN THEY
CAN OPT OUT BUT THEY DON'T
OFTEN. SAID THE END IS THAT IT
IT OPERATES KIND OF LIKE HEALTH
INSURANCE PROGRAM WE BY HEALTH
INSURANCE EVERYBODY PAYS PAYS A
LITTLE BUT NOBODY HAS TO PAY
THAT MUCH AND EVERYBODY
BENEFITS SO THIS IS WHAT IS
BEING CALLED THE HEALTH
INSURANCE MODEL. AND
INTERESTINGLY ON THE
LEGISLATURE ASKED UC IRVINE TO
DO A STUDY THAT STUDENT TRANSIT
PASSES BECAUSE WE HAD. WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN GOTTEN A
STUDENT TRANSIT PASS ON
GOVERNOR BROWN'S DESK. BUT HE
SAID HE VETOED IT AND HE SAID
HE NEEDED TO KNOW MORE ABOUT
HOW STUDENT TRANSIT PASS
PROGRAMS WORKING CALIFORNIA. SO
THIS STUDY WAS DONE. HELP
ANSWER THOSE QUESTIONS AND IT
WAS JUST DELIVERY TO THE
LEGISLATURE. AND IT'S REALLY
INTEREST. BECAUSE IT TALKS
ABOUT THE INSURANCE MY AND HOW
THIS BE A WAY. BECAUSE I KNOW
YOU KNOW FREE IS SUCH A GREAT I
BUT FREE IS DIFFERENT. SOMEBODY
HAS TO. AND WHO INTO THE LATEST
CAN. METRO CAN PAY. THE SCHOOLS
PAY THIS CAN PAY BUT- HAVING A
BE FREE FOR EVERYBODY I DO KNOW
WHO THEN PAYS. BUT IT'S A GREAT
IDEA AND I THINK WE SHOULD KEEP
IT. KEEP IT UNDER CONSIDERATION.
SO ON AGAIN IT WAS INTERESTING
BECAUSE IT FAMILY MEMBER
GONZALEZ HAS AB THIRTEEN FIFTY
BEFORE THE LEGISLATURE AND THAT
BILL- FLEW AT OF ASSEMBLY
TRANSPORTATION IT FLEW OUT OF
HER APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
AND IT GOT OUT THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR SO. YOU KNOW THERE'S
ALREADY MOMENTUM IN THAT AREA A
MAYOR GARCETTI HAS MADE THE
DASH BUS IN LOS ANGELES SPREE
FOR ALL K. THROUGH TWELVE
STUDENTS. THE CITY IS PAYING
FOR THAT PROGRAM SAYS AGAIN
SOMEBODY IS PAYING EVEN THOUGH
IT'S FREE. AND METRO IS NOW
STUDYING HOW TO MAKE TRANSIT
FREE FOR ALL STUDENTS I THINK
IT'S GONNA BE VERY INTERESTING
TO SEE. HOW THAT GOES. I THINK
IT'S INTERESTING THAT SACK OR
TA IS ALSO MAKING STUDENTS FREE
MAKING PASSES FREE FOR STUDENTS.
OF THE- A WAY. IN METRO SEE
PHIL WANTS TO CAN CHEN HAS TO
PAY FOR IT TRANSIT AND MAKE IT
FREE FOR P. WHICH- WHILE
THAT'LL BE THAT'LL BE THE DAY.
I MEAN I WON IT TO BE THE DAY
SO I AND THEN NOW IN WOMEN.
HELLO HAS IN THE BILL WHICH-
YOU HAVE AN ENTRY YET BUT YOU
WILL. END SO NEXT. SO WE HAVE
WORKED WITH MEMBER HOLDEN
STUDENT SINCE TWENTY. LOW THIS
PICTURE HE IS THE CHAIR. OF IN
THAT THE TWO BILLS WE WORK ON
TOGETHER THE BILLS ACTUALLY HAD
ALMOST YOU SUPPORT IN MAY
COMMITTEES AND IT WAS BROAD
SUPPORT DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS IT WAS NOT IT'S NOT
A PARTISAN ISSUE ANYWAY AND
THEN YOU KNOW WE GOT TO THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK AND HE SAID NO.
BUT NOW THAT THE STUDIES BEEN
DELIVERED WE BELIEVE THAT
THERE'S GOING TO BE PROGRESS
THIS YEAR'S SO IT'S ALL VERY
EXCITING AND I THINK THAT'S THE
AGAIN. YOU KNOW HOW HELLO BUT-
IF THIRTEEN FIFTY IF YOUR BILL
GETS ACROSS HOW WILL IT BE
FUNDED YOU KNOW THE CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM THE GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION FUND IS ONE
POSSIBILITY IT THE STATE BUDGET
IS ONE POSSIBILITY YOU KNOW
THIS HEALTH INSURANCE FUNDING
MODEL WHERE EVERYBODY PUTS IN A
LITTLE MONEY. IT'S ANOTHER
GREAT MODEL METRO HAS BEEN
WORKING TRYING TO WORK TOWARD
THAT KIND OF THE MODEL AND WE
ESTIMATE BASED ON WHAT WE KNOW
BASED ON THE EXPERIENCE IN
SANTA MONICA IT COULD COST
ABOUT SEVENTY FIVE MILLION A
YEAR TO PROVIDE A SUBSIDY
FIFTEEN DOLLARS PER STUDENT PER
YEAR. SO THAT ALL STUDENTS
COULD. GET DISCOUNTED PASS
ASSUMING THAT ONLY SEVENTY
WOULD PROTECT. LAST FRIDAY. WHO
KNEW WE HAD SUPPORT FROM METRO
EARLY ON BEGINNING IN TWENTY.
AND METRO IS ALWAYS BEEN
INTERESTED METROS TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO MAKE THIS
WORK. THE LEGISLATURE IS TRYING
TO FIND A WAY TO MAKE THIS WORK
SO TWENTY TWENTY I THINK IT'S
THE YEAR. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND- A WE SHOULD CHORE YOURS
STEP. A SUPPORT IN AND ENERGY
THIS INITIATIVE AND CERTAINLY-
TAKE MORE THAN ANY TAKES ALL OF
US WORKING TOGETHER TO MAKE IT
HAPPEN AND I'M OPTIMISTIC THIS
TIME AROUND AS WELL- FOR TWO
REMAINING PRISONERS IF I COULD
JUST ASK YOU TO SORT OF
CONVINCE YOUR PRESENTATION WE
HAVE TO BE OUT BY ONE I DO WANT
TO GIVE THOSE WHO. HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS TO TASK AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DO SO. THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE CERTAINLY GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS AARON
RODGERS AND I'M THE INTERIM CEO
AND GENERAL MANAGER OF ON THE
TRANS YOUR LOCAL TRANSIT SYSTEM
HERE IN THE SAN BERNARDINO
VALLEY IT'S AN HONOR TO BE HERE
WITH YOU TODAY AND HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
THIS IMPORTANT DISCUSSION ON
BEHALF OF OMNI TRANS AND ON
BEHALF OF THE REGION. OTHERS
BEEN A WEALTH OF THE L. WEALTH
OF INFORMATION SHARED AND I
HAVE THE BENEFIT OF A LOT OF MY
THUNDER BEING SOLD BY SOME OF
MY PREVIOUS PANELISTS SO IT
WILL HELP ME SHORTEN MY
PRESENTATION- I THINK WE ALL
AGREE- WE'VE HEARD A LOT ABOUT
RAIL WE'VE HEARD A LOT ABOUT
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND
ALL OF THESE. ISSUES THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO RESOLVE AND I THINK
WE ALL AGREE THAT A ROBUST AND
STRONG TRANSIT SYSTEM REALLY
HAS TO BE THE BACKBONE THAT'S
IN PLACE AS AS WE MOVE FORWARD
TO MEET OUR OUR GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS GOALS. JUST QUICKLY A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT ON THE TRANS-
WE ARE THE LARGEST
TRANSPORTATION TRANSPORTATION-
PROVIDER IN THE SAN BERNADINO
VALLEY- OUR TAGLINE IS
CONNECTING OUR COMMUNITY- WE
SERVE FIFTEEN CITIES IN THE
COUNTY OF SAN BRING A DINO AND
OUR SERVICE AREA STRETCHES TO
THE WEST ALL THE WAY TO THE LA
COUNTY LINE STARTING ALL THE
WAY OVER CHINO HILLS CHINO. AND
WE WE'D SOUTH TO THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY LINE AND WE SPREAD ALL
THE WAY OVER- THROUGH THE
VALLEY- SAMBAR TO SALMON A DINO
YUCAIPA HIGHLAND GRAND TERRACE-
CONNECTING OUR COMMUNITY WHERE
THE OWNER OF A REGIONAL- OUR
AGENCY OWNS A REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION CENTER IN THE
CITY A SAMPOERNA DO YOU KNOW
WHERE WE CONNECT WITH THE
RIVERSIDE TRANSIT AUTHORITY THE
VICTOR VALLEY TRANSIT AUTHORITY
THE MOUNTAIN AREA TRANSIT
ALREADY PASSED TRANSIT WE'RE IN
THE PROCESS OF CONNECTING WITH
SUNLINE TRANSIT IN THE
COACHELLA VALLEY. SO WE REALLY
ARE- THE MULTI MODAL CENTER
WITH THE METROLINK TRAINS IN
THERE AS WELL AS THE FUTURE
ERRO RAIL SERVICES YOU HEARD
ABOUT EARLIER AS YOU KNOW WE'RE
FUNDED THROUGH A COMBINATION OF
LOCAL STATE AND FEDERAL
FUNDING- AND I'LL JUST TELL YOU
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT WE KNOW
ABOUT OUR CUSTOMERS WHICH
REALLY SORT OF- REFLECTS THE
INFORMATION THE MARIANA SHARED
WITH YOU- WE KNOW THAT 30% OF
OUR RIDERS ARE BETWEEN. ARE ARE
GENERALLY STUDENTS BETWEEN THE
AGE OF NINETEEN AND TWENTY NINE
ANOTHER 30% ARE BETWEEN FIFTY
AND SIXTY FIVE AND THEY'RE
GENERALLY LOW INCOME IN TERMS
OF THOSE STATISTICS FOR OUR
RIDERS- THE AVERAGE INCOME. IS
A 57% OF OUR WRITERS HAVE AN
AVERAGE INCOME OF UNDER TWENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND 80% UNDER
THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS SO
THE THIS IS THE DEMOGRAPHIC-
THAT THAT WERE GENERALLY
SERVING- IN TERMS OF OUR TRIP
PURPOSE- TO THE POINTS THAT WE
DISCUSSED EARLIER APPROXIMATELY
65% OF THE TRIPS TAKEN OUR ON
OUR SYSTEM. ARE TAKING PEOPLE
TO WORK IN TO SCHOOL- SO WE ARE
THAT VITAL LINK CONNECTING
THESE COMMUNITIES TO
OPPORTUNITY EDUCATION AND JOBS.
AND AS AND AS YOU KNOW OUR
SERVICE AREA SPAN AS WE SPAN
ACROSS THE VALLEY REALLY DOES
COVER A NUMBER OF DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND OPPORTUNITIES
OWNS. AND WHILE YOU'VE HEARD
ABOUT THE PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION. PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION INDUSTRY AS AS A
WHOLE ACROSS NOT JUST THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA BUT THE COUNTRY
EXPERIENCING A SIGNIFICANT
DECLINE IN RIDERSHIP WE TO MERE
A MERE WHAT WE SHARED ABOUT
METRO WE'VE EXPERIENCED ABOUT A
TWENTY FIVE PERCENT. DROP IN
RIDERSHIP AND- DESPITE THIS WE
KNOW- THAT WILL CONTINUE TO BE
A VITAL LINK IN THESE
COMMUNITIES AND I'M GOING TO
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT
WE'RE DOING TO ADDRESS THAT IN
THE FUTURE BUT FIRST I WANT TO
TOUCH ON- WE'VE ALSO HEARD A
LOT ABOUT. ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACTS CONGESTION AIR QUALITY
SO I DO WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT
TO TALK ABOUT- ENVIRONMENTAL
STEWARDSHIP AND THE
PARTNERSHIP. THAT WE BRING TO
THIS TO THIS COMMUNITY- I'M THE
TRANS LEAD THAT THE INDUSTRY IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA EARLY
IN THE TWO THOUSANDS BY
INTRODUCING THE VERY FIRST
HYBRID ELECTRIC TRANSIT BUS.
AND AS WE MOVE THROUGH THE PAST
DECADE WE TRANSITIONED OUR
ENTIRE FLEET TO COMPRESSED
NATURAL GAS ENGINES- WHICH ARE
THE CLEANEST BURNING- ENGINES
THAT WERE AVAILABLE RIGHT NOW
WE'RE RE POWERING- SIXTY FIVE
OF OUR BUSES TO WHAT'S CALLED A
NEAR ZERO. AND GIN- WHICH WILL
REDUCE OUR EMISSIONS EVEN MORE
UP 290% WHEN WE'RE DONE WITH
THAT PROJECT 70% OF OUR FLEET
WILL. WILL BE OPERATING WITH
THE CLEANEST BURNING ENGINES
AVAILABLE ON THE MARKET. SO
WE'RE VERY PROUD OF THAT. AND
AS WE COMPLETE THAT AT THE SAME
TIME WE ARE PREPARING TO MEET
THE STATE MANDATED INNOVATIVE
CLEAN TRANSIT RULE WHICH AS YOU
KNOW REQUIRES TRANSIT OPERATORS
TO TRANSITION THEIR FLEETS TWO
ZERO MISSION BY TWENTY FORTY.
THAT THE GRAPH ON THIS SLIDE
BEFORE YOU. DEPICTS OUR FLEET
ROLL OUT PLAN IS TO COMPLY WITH
THIS REGULATION AND WE ARE
REQUIRED TO SUBMIT THIS PLAN TO
CARB BY JUNE OF THIS YEAR. THE
BLUE BARS ON THIS GRAPH SO ARE
COMPRESSED NATURAL GAS BUSES
AND YOU CAN SEE THEY GET
TRANSITIONED OUT EACH YEAR AS
WE BRING IN ZERO EMISSION
BUSES. WERE EXCITED- TO REPORT
THAT WE WILL BE GOING TO OUR
BOARD. NEXT MONTH TO SEEK
APPROVAL TO PURCHASE THE FIRST
FOUR BATTERY ELECTRIC BUSES FOR
OUR FLEET AND WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON TO SUPPORT US
IN THE- PREPARING OUR
FACILITIES TO MEET THE
INFRASTRUCTURE DEMANDS THAT
WILL BE REQUIRED TO MEET THAT
MANDATE- I'D ALSO LIKE YOU
HEARD ABOUT. ONTARIO'S
TRANSFORMATIVE CLIMATE
COMMUNITIES GRANT COMMUNITIES
CLIMATE GRANT- WE WERE ONE OF
THE PARTNERS IN THAT EFFORT SO
THAT BUS TOUR YOU ONE ON I'M
QUITE CERTAIN WAS AN OMNI TRANS
BUS AND SO WE'RE EXCITED TO BE
A PARTNER. IN THAT PROJECT AND-
WE ALSO ARE PARTNERING- WITH SB
CTA TO APPLY FOR A GRANT FOR
ADDITIONAL ADDITIONAL ELECTRIC
VEHICLES FOR ANOTHER
SIGNIFICANTLY REGION REGIONAL
SIGNIFICANT PROJECT THE WEST
VALLEY CONNECTOR PROJECT WHICH
WILL BRING THE NEXT BUS RAPID
TRANSIT. SERVICE TO ONTARIO. I
WILL ADD BEFORE I LEAVE THIS
SLIDE SINCE SINCE EVERYONE ELSE
WAS NOT SHY ENOUGH TO TALK
ABOUT EVERYONE'S TECH BOOKS
THAT. MEETING THAT THE MANDATE
FOR THE ZERO EMISSION BUSES- IS
FINANCIALLY A CHALLENGE NOT
JUST FROM THE TRANS BUT FOR
OTHER SMALL AND MEDIUM SIZE
TRANSIT AGENCIES ACROSS THE
STATE. AND WHILE WE BELIEVE
IT'S A VERY ACHIEVABLE GOAL WE
WILL HAVE TO BE VERY AGGRESSIVE
AND WORK- WORK TOGETHER TO FUND
TO. FUND THIS THIS IMPORTANT
EFFORT. WELL WE TALKED ABOUT
TRANSIT EQUITY AND QUICKLY I
KNOW I NEED TO ABBREVIATE- AND
I AND I SPOKE TO YOU A BIT
ABOUT OUR TWO LARGEST
DEMOGRAPHIC GROUPS THAT ARE
USING OUR SYSTEM. STUDENTS AND
ALTHOUGH I HESITATE TO CALL
FIFTY TO SIXTY FIVE SENIORS I
WILL SAY. SENIORS BUT WE DO
HAVE A STUDENT PASS PROGRAM
CALLED OUR GO SMART PROGRAM- WE
PARTNER WITH FOR UNIVERSITIES
IN THE REGION AND WE DO JUST
WHAT WAS TALKED ABOUT- IS PART
OF THE STUDENT FEES WE HAVE
AGREEMENTS WITH THESE CAMPUSES-
TO PROVIDE STUDENT STUDENT
PASSES SO THOSE AND INCLUDE
CHAFEE COLLEGE CRAFTING HILLS
COLLEGE THEN BRING TO THE YOU
KNOW VALLEY COLLEGE. AND CAL
STATE SAN BERNARDINO- AND WITH
THAT PROGRAM WERE CONNECTING
STUDENTS TO EDUCATION AND I
ALSO BELIEVE THAT WE'RE
DEVELOPING OUR NEXT GENERATION
OF TRANSIT RIDERS- BY BY HAVING
THAT GROUP FAMILIAR WITH USING
THE TRANSIT SYSTEM. NEXT I WILL
TOUCH ON. THE SERVICES THAT WE
PROVIDE FOR SENIORS AND PERSONS
WITH DISABILITIES IN OUR
SERVICE AREA- WE'RE FORTUNATE
ENOUGH TO HAVE OUR LOCAL SALES
TAX MEASURE SUPPORT SOME OF
THESE SERVICES AND THOSE
PROGRAMS ARE ADMINISTERED BY
OMNI TRANS UNDER THE
CONSOLIDATED TRANSPORTATION
SERVICES AGENCY AND AS PART OF
THE MEASURE WE AT AND AS PART
OF OUR RESPONSIBILITY AS THE C.
TSA- WE HAVE FUNDS TO PROVIDE
TO THE COMMUNITY TO SUPPORT
LOCAL COMMUNITY TRANSPORTATION
SERVICES AND IT AND AS A MATTER
OF FACT AS I ARRIVED HERE THIS
MORNING. THE BUS THAT WAS OUT
FRONT WAS FROM THE WEST END
YMCA PROVIDING TRIPS TO SENIORS
TO THIS FACILITY RIGHT HERE
WHERE WE ARE- USING THAT
SERVICE- SO WE'LL WORK WITH THE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS MANY OF THE
CITIES IN YOUR DISTRICTS ARE
ARE PARTICIPATING IN THAT
PROGRAM THE CITY OF FONTANA
REDLANDS GRANT TERRORISTS SO
MANY ARE ALREADY PARTICIPATING
AND WE'RE REALLY MAKING A
PROACTIVE EFFORT. TO GET THAT
MONEY OUT IN THE COMMUNITY TO
PROVIDE TO PROVIDE MORE TRIPS
UNDER THAT SERVICE. SO QUICKLY
THE NEXT SLIDE JUST SHOWS THE
REGION THE SERVICE AREA AND I
KNOW IT'S A LITTLE BIT HARD TO
SEE BUT THE TRIANGLES ARE WHERE
THESE PROGRAMS CURRENTLY ARE
FUNDED AND AGAIN WE PROACTIVELY
REALLY ARE TRYING TO INCREASE
THE PARTICIPATION IN THAT
PROGRAM. UP NEXT IN TERMS OF
SUSTAINABILITY WHAT'S NEXT YOU
HEARD A LOT ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES WE HAVE OUR CONNECT
FORWARD PLAN WE ARE REDUCING
SERVICE BY 11% AND WE WERE
DOING THIS REALLY TO ENSURE A
SUSTAINABLE FUTURE FOR OMNI
TRANS WERE REALIGNING OUR
SERVICES TO MATCH THAT 25%
DECLINE IN RIDERSHIP SO WE ALSO
BELIEVE THIS IS WHAT'S
NECESSARY TO PREPARE US TO BE
NIMBLE TO MEET SOME OF THESE
OTHER NEEDS THAT THAT WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT- IN THIS PLAN WERE
IMPROVING REGIONAL CONNECTIONS
TO METROLINK WE ALREADY HAVE
CONNECTIONS TO THE AIRPORT THAT
WE'VE HEARD SO MUCH ABOUT- SO
WE'RE REALLY WORKING TO MAKE
BETTER CONNECTIONS FOR FIRST
AND LAST MILE TRIPS. AND
INTRODUCED A MORE FLEXIBLE
OPTIONS LIKE MICRO TRANSIT WILL
BE STARTING OUR FIRST MICRO
TRANSIT PILOT PROJECT IN THE
CITY OF CHINO HILLS OUT LATER
THIS YEAR AND WE'RE EXCITED
ABOUT THAT IS WE KNOW THAT
PEOPLE'S EXPECTATIONS HAVE
CHANGED FOR TRANSIT THEY
EVERYBODY WANTS EVERYTHING FAST
SO WE WILL BE PILOTING THAT
CHINO HILLS AND WE'RE LOOKING
AT ELECTRIC VEHICLES FOR THAT
SERVICE SO WILL BE EXCITED TO
SHARE THE NEWS ON HOW THAT
GOES. SO LASTLY IN TERMS OF
TECHNOLOGY REALLY OUR GOAL IS
TO MAKE THE BUS SYSTEM EASY TO
USE WE WANT PEOPLE TO BE ABLE
TO PLAN PAY AND USE THE SYSTEM
WE HAVE ALL THE TECHNOLOGY THAT
IT WAS ON LAST NIGHT BUT THAT'S
OKAY REAL TIME PASSENGER
INFORMATION WIFI SYSTEMS ALL
THE TECHNOLOGIES THAT ALLOW.
PEOPLE TO USE OUR SYSTEM. AND
CLOSE. I REALLY WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME I KNOW I'M
HERE AT THE END I APPRECIATE
YOUR ATTENTION- SO WHY TRANSIT
I THINK THAT THIS PICTURE WHICH
YOU HAVE PROBABLY SEEN IN OTHER
PLACES BEFORE- YOU KNOW REALLY
TELLS TELLS THE STORY VISUALLY.
AND I KNOW THAT WE ALL NEED TO
WORK TOGETHER TO ENSURE LONG
TERM AND SUSTAINABLE OPERATING
FUNDING- AND I BELIEVE MUCH OF
THE INFORMATION TODAY SUPPORTS
REALLY DOES SUPPORT THE NOTION
THAT. THAT THE ROBUST TRANSIT
SYSTEM REALLY IS THE BACKBONE
IN THE STARTING POINT OF
EVERYTHING WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
SO I WILL BE BRIEF- ACTUALLY
QUITE FRANKLY AFTER LISTENING
TO- MARIANAS STE- TESTIMONY I
JUST TURNED HER AND SAID YES TO
EVERYTHING SHE SAID- I COULD
NOT HAVE. DONE A BETTER JOB
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
BLOCKING ABOUT OUR CHALLENGE
YEAH. SO BUT I JUST TO ADD AND
YES EVERY. AARON AND GLOW ALSO
IT'S LIKE A MINUTE FOR GOAL MY
PRESENT. AND GIVE THREE SAID
VERSION OF THE END BUT I JUST
WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE OF
THINGS- INITIATIVES THAT RELATE
TO WHAT- EVERYBODY ON THE PANEL
WAS TALKING ABOUT THAT METRO-
MARIANA MENTION THE NEXT GEN
STUDY THAT'S A COMPLETE. RE
ENVISIONING OF OUR BUS SYSTEM
AND WE ARE ABOUT TO EMBARK. ON
A NUMBER OF COMMUNITY MEETINGS-
BEGINNING FEBRUARY FIRST. WE'RE
WE'RE TAKING PROBABLY THE MOST
COMPREHENSIVE LOOK AT A BUS
SYSTEM. THAT ANY TRANSIT AGENCY
IN THE COUNTRY HAS EVER DONE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT COMPLETELY
REVAMPING HOW WE OPERATE OUR-
OUR BUS SYSTEM. IN LOOKING AT
THE KINDS OF ISSUES THAT PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN BRINGING UP HERE
CONNECTIONS EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM
TELL STUDENTS TRAVEL. I WANT TO
ALSO HIGHLIGHT THAT IN THE
COURSE OF THAT WE'VE ALSO DONE.
THE STUDY THAT I DON'T THINK TO
ME TRANSIT AGENCIES DONE THAT
HAS TO DO WITH HOW WOMEN
TRAVEL. AND IT'S A VERY
COMPREHENSIVE REPORT. AND YOU
KNOW PEOPLE ARE. YOU KNOW FOR
THE BUT A LOT OF FOCUS ON BIKES
ON SYSTEM AND PEOPLE ARE THEIR
ACCOMMODATIONS FOR BIKES. WITH
YOU LOOK CLOSELY WHO RIDE THEIR
SYSTEM THE OTHER THING YOU SEE
IS WOMEN WITH TWO CHILDREN.
THERE'S A STROLLER- THERE'S
USUALLY A BUNCH OF OTHER.
THINGS THAT THE WOMAN NEEDS TO
CARRY WITH HER. AND THERE'S NO
ACCOMMODATION FOR THAT THERE'S
A SPOT FOR BIKES ON TRAIN CARS-
THERE'S A SPOT OF FOR
HANDICAPPED PATRONS ON OUR-
BUSES IN A REAL CARS. BUT
THERE'S- WHERE IS THE SPOT FOR
A WOMAN WITH TWO CHILDREN. AND
SO WE'RE LOOKING AT ISSUES LIKE
THAT AS WE- AS WE WRITE REVAMPS
OUR SYSTEM- WE ARE ALSO IN THE
PROCESS OF OBVIOUSLY BUILDING A
LOT OF THE RAIL. LINES IN THE
NEW TRANSIT SYSTEMS WERE
STUDYING A LOT OF NEW CORRIDORS
THAT CONNECT- TWO MAJOR
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS AND
THINGS LIKE THAT. AND THEY ALL
NEED MORE MONEY I WANT TO SIT
HERE AND JUST TELL YOU WE NEED
MORE MONEY YOU KNOW WE NEED
MORE MONEY. WILL WORK WITH YOU
AS THESE PROGRAMS AND FOR THE
**** PROJECTS TO FORWARD TO
LOOK AT THAT- BUT WE ARE ALSO
TAKING A CLOSE LOOK AT STUDENT
TRANSIT PATH ISSUES THE- ORDER.
OF. IT CONSIDERED A. MOTIONS
LAST MONTH. THAT LOOK AT
GRANTING. TRANSIT TO SEE EVER.
IN LA YOU ARE CPAS. IN THERE'S
TO MEASURE INSECT. AT THE HAVE
TO DO RICK. US TO GRANT FREE
PASS TO STUDENTS. SO LOOKING
THAT YOU KNOW I'M THE MARKET IS
SITTER INTO YOU YOU KNOW WE-
MONEY OF. WE NEED BUT WE'RE NOT
GOING TO. WHEN GOING TO STE
JUST GOING TO IN AND SAY MONIES
ONLY. THAT WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH
YOUR THERE'S CHALLENGE. IN
HELPING PEOPLE WE WANT TO. AND
WE'LL ALL WORK THROUGH THAT.
THE LAST I WANT TO MAKE. IS
JUST AS WE FOR. THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF CHALLENGES THAT. HAVE
BEEN BROUGHT BEFORE THE PANEL-
TODAY. WE THINK THERE ARE SOME
SURGICAL SOLUTIONS THAT. WE
COULD WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE
ON. A IN TERMS OF HOUSING- PASS
AFFORDABILITY- HOW WE HELP
STUDENTS AND WOMEN MOVE AROUND.
AND WE WILL COMMIT TO WORKING
WITH- THE LEGISLATURE. ON
TRYING TO ADVANCE SOME OF THESE
INITIATIVES THAT'LL CLOSE
THERE'S A QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
AND I PRE YOU PACKED A LOT INTO.
THREE MINUTES APPROVED THAT BUT
I ALSO. THINK THAT EACH OF THE
OF TOUCH ON. SOME VERY
PRINCIPLES. WAS IMPORTANT FOR
AT LEAST ME AND I FOR THIS. TO
REFER. ON AND THAT IS HOW MANY
OF OUR- TRANSIT THE- MEMBERS OF
OUR COMMUNITY RIDE THE BUS. AND
HOW THERE IS A NEED TO CONTINUE
TO FOCUS ON. RAIL AND MOVING
COMMUNITY BUT ALSO- NOT LOSING
SIGHT OF THE IMPORTANCE OF. HOW
THE WEATHER'S JUST. PEOPLE
BECOME A CUT TO WRITING THE BUS
THIS THE ACCESSIBILITY IS MUCH
GREATER- BUT WE WILL LOSE SIGHT
OF THE FACT THAT THERE'S A AS
THE INTRACOASTAL. NEEDS BEING
MET AND WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH YOU TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S
GETTING THE SUPPORT THAT IT
NEEDS. SENATOR DO. YOU HAVE
ANY. QUESTIONS FOR A TIME OKAY
AND WITH THAT WE PIVOT AT THE
MOMENT I THINK WE COVERED A LOT
SUBJECTS TODAY. SUBJECTS SO WE
LOOK FOR TO UNIQUE THE PUBLIC
WANTS TO SHARE LET ME CHECK
REAL QUICK WITH THE STAFF IF WE
I KNOW WHEN. EVERYONE SIGN IN
THERE WAS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
FILL OUT A CARD SO IF THERE'S A
WAY THAT IF YOU HAVE A QUESTION
IN YOUR HAVE WRITTEN IT DOWN IF
YOU CAN. PRESENT THAT TO. OUR
STAFF AND THEY WILL. PRESENTED
TO US SO.
AND I WANT TO THIS
THAT AND AGAIN OUR FOR HOUSE
AND THESE MEETINGS THERE SO
MUCH TO GET OUT OF THE WAY WANT
TO SURE THAT WE HAVE. AND TO
HEAR FROM PUBLIC WE ARE UNDER
OF A CAN ON. BUT EACH OF THE
QUESTIONS WILL BE ASKED AND WE
WILL OVER IN WRITING IF WE NEED
TO DO THAT BUT WE'RE GOING TO
TRY TO COVER AS MUCH. MANY OF
THEM AS WE CAN. TWENTY THREE
LET'S SEE OKAY THIS IS FROM
JACK MOREAU THANKS FOR BEING
HERE YOU'RE WELCOME. WILL
TRAINS BE. RUN FREE. THE GUN
FREE. AND THEN I YOUR
RECOMMENDING THAT WE SEE THE
FILM THE JOKER. I'M NOT SURE
HOW TO RESPOND TO THAT BUT LET
ME JUST SAY THAT- IN TERMS OF
THE TRAINS IN BEING GUN FREE-
IS THERE A. I'VE BEEN RUNNING I
WOULD SAY YOU WERE NOT OPEN
CARE HEARING SO AREN'T THEY
ALREADY GUN FREE. CURRENTLY
THAT'S RIGHT. THIS IS. OKAY
MARTIN MARTIN SO ABOUT WARMING.
AS LET'S SEE. GLOBAL WARMING IS
THE MAIN. TRANSPORTATION THE
WORK FOR THE LESSER ACTOR GREW.
ADDRESS BEFORE YOU KNOW WHAT
WHAT I'M DO IF YOU CAN JUST
COME TO THE MICROPHONE BECAUSE
YOU HAVE A FEW HERE I DON'T
WANT TO. WHAT MAKES THE TRUE
ESSENCE OF YOUR QUESTION GETS A-
YEAH OUT. HOUSE KINDA RIGHT
THINGS DOWN AS I WAS THE ABOUT
BUT I'M A MEMBER OF A GROUP
SAID CLIMATE. SO CLIMATE LAW IS
LOBBYING CON. TO ENACT A CARBON
FEE WITH THE DIVIDEND. AND THE
CARBON FEE IDEA WAS NOT
MENTIONED BY ANY OF THE PANELS
IF WE CAN RAISE THE PRICE OF
GASOLINE I WOULD THINK THAT
BOSS MEMBER ARE RIDERSHIP WOULD
DEFINITELY GO UP. AND THE IDEA
OF THE CARBON FEE WITH THE
DIVIDEND IS IT DOESN'T WANT TO
HURT ANYBODY SO THE FEES
COLLECTED GOES INTO A FUND THAT
THEN. SENDS A SHOULD CHECK TO
ALL THE CONSUMERS AND THE
CONSUMERS CAN USE THAT.
DIVIDEND CHECK TO PAY FOR THE
INCREASED PRICE OF THE CARBON
BUT THEY CAN USE THAT TO LOWER
THEIR CARBON FOOTPRINT TO. AND
IF. THE HIGH COST OF. ANGERS
PEOPLE SUCH TO A LEVEL THAT
THEY DECIDE THAT THEY'RE GOING
TO RIDE THE BUS INSTEAD YEAH A-
SO ANYWAY- THE CITIZENS CLIMATE
LOBBY IS GOING TO HAVE A
REGIONAL CONFERENCE ON FEBRUARY
TWENTY SECOND AND TWENTY THIRD.
CAL STATE LA YOU CAN GET THERE
ON THE TRAIN SO ANYWAY- IS
SUGGEST AND RECOMMEND THAT YOU
GO TO THE OUR CONFERENCE FOR
CITIZENS CLIMATE LOBBY AT LEAST
CHECK OUT CITIZENS CLIMATE
LOBBY ON THE WAY OUT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THAT WE
APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE-
CAROLEE MONROE. I'M GONNA YOU
COME FOR IF YOU'RE HERE. IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO. THREE B. H. SURE
YOUR QUESTION.
JUST LIKE DON I
WAS MAKING NOTES FIRST OF ALL
SEVENTY YEARS AGO I WOULD BE
TOO EMBARRASSED TO TALK ABOUT
THIS. HOWEVER AT MY AGE I HAVE
WHEN I'VE WRITTEN ON THE LIGHT
RAIL THERE ARE NO RESTROOMS ON
THE LIGHT RAIL AND THERE ARE NO
RESTROOMS AT THE STATION EXCEPT
YOU HAVE TO GO TO UNION STATION.
AND SO I WAS TALKING ABOUT THIS
PROBLEM BECAUSE WE SENIORS WE
NEED THIS. OKAY IF THAT I HAVE
READ ON. THE METRO TO. MY HEAD
AND I GONE FROM. WHERE MY TO
UNION TO OCEAN TO RE STAR TO
BERNADINO ON HOME FOR TEN
DOLLARS EACH THIS SOMEONE THING
SENIOR WE HAVE GONE FROM. TO
YOU ST. TO LAND CAL IN BACK.
AND WE CAN DO BECAUSE ALL OF
OUR NEEDS ARE MET. YOUR SENIORS
FROM ALL LAW OF THINGS. THANK
YOU. I JUST SAY THAT'S A GROUP
THIS IS WHY WE DO THIS THAT
PEOPLE BRING THING UP THAT CAN
WORK ON THANK YOU CAROLE. HELLO
SO. SEE. OKAY. THANK YOU SO
MUCH TOP OF SO MUCH FOR THE ARE
TO TALK WITH YOU AS WAS
MENTIONED THE IN EMPIRE IS THE
NUMBER ONE HOT SPOT FOR
WAREHOUSES IN THE UNITED STATES.
THIS IS A TRANSPORTATION LOCAL
AND REGIONAL HEARING NOT ONCE
DID I HEAR THAT IMPACT. THAT
COMES WITH HAVING THESE
WAREHOUSES. IN THERE'S ONE
PROPOSED RIGHT NOW AND UPLAND
AND IT'S THE LAST MILE
DELIVERY. ELEVEN HUNDRED
DELIVERY VANS AND A LOT OF
HEAVY DUTY DIESEL TRUCKS TWENTY
FOUR HOURS A DAY SEVEN DAYS A
WEEK. UPLAND IS A RESIDENTIAL
CITY WHERE BEDROOM. COMMUNITY
THIS WILL SEVERELY IMPACT US.
ALSO THE THERE IS A LOT OF
ACTIVITY GOING ON BRINGING IN
MORE WAREHOUSES THROUGHOUT
RIVERSIDE AND SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY I WAS VERY SURPRISED
NONE OF THAT WAS MENTIONED
TODAY AND THE IMPACT ON TRAFFIC
CONGESTION AND NOW WITH THE
NEW- CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY ACT SYKORA GUIDELINES
THAT CAME IN SO FAR AS VEHICLE
MILES TRAVELED GREENHOUSE GASES
XTERRA. ARE YOU CONCERNED ABOUT
THE INCREASED. VEHICLES HEAVY
DUTY RIGS ON THE ROAD FROM ALL
THESE WAREHOUSES. YES AND I
KNOW THAT WE MAY NOT OF- HAD
THE SPECIFIC FOCUS ON THE TOPIC
BUT I KNOW IN TERMS OF
ADDRESSING THE ISSUE OF TRUCK
TRAFFIC MAKING ITS WAY FROM THE
PORTS. THROUGH THE INLAND
EMPIRE THAT IS A GREAT CONCERN
THERE'S ALSO THE ISSUE I THINK
THERE WAS A BILL LAST YEAR OR
OBERNOLTE I BELIEVE HAD A BILL
THAT ADDRESSED ISSUE OF- WORLD.
THERE WAS CONCERN ABOUT WHAT IT
MEANT IN TERMS OF THE- INCREASE
IN. WAREHOUSES AND
MANUFACTURING. OF THAT OR WERE
WELL HOUSING THAT WAS GOING TO.
MAKE ITS WAY INTO THE AREA AS
WELL SO I THINK WE'RE WE'RE
CLEARLY HERE. PREPARE TO TAKE
NOTES AND TO REGISTER YOUR YOUR
ISSUE AND CONCERN- IT'S ALSO.
SOME OF IT IS LAND USE IN TERMS
OF HOW. OF CITING AND PLANNING
OF THESE TYPE OF FACILITIES OR
IDENTIFY FOR COMMUNITY BUT AS
IT RELATES TO THE TRUCK
TRAFFICKING THAT'S ONE THAT
WE'RE- AWARE OF AND CONTINUE TO
TRY TO FIND. SOLUTIONS TO
ADDRESS BUT WE'RE WE'RE HERE
TODAY TO ALSO TAKE DOWN. THAT
CONCERN AND TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE GET BACK TO YOU WITH SOME
AND THIS IS NOT GOING TO BE THE
FIRST IN THE LAST OF OUR OR
MEETINGS AND GET TOGETHER
THERE. SENATOR WILL HAVE
MEETINGS I WILL JOIN I'LL HAVE
MEETINGS WILL JOIN. ME AND
ANSWER. TRICKS A CONTINUE TO
HAVE A CAR HOW WE CAN MAKE AND
GET OUR ARMS ARE THE ISSUE
THANK AS WHEN HOW WE ALL KNOW
ABOUT THE HEAVY DO DIESEL ISSUE
AT THE PORT. IT'S A SECRET HERE
IN IN EMPIRE THAT THAT WE JUST
OF. IN ISSUE WITH THE WAREHOUSE.
RIGHT THE KEY. NEEDS BECOME FOR
ABOUT QUIRK SEQUEL IS THE
PUBLIC'S RIGHT FOR THEIR VOICE
TO BE HEARD JUST NOT ONLY. YOUR
JOB IT'S OUR JOB TO WE NEED TO
PUSH BACK IN EVERY PERSON
COUNTS. REVOLUTIONS HAVE BEEN
STARTED BY ONE SHORT SPEECH
THANK YOU AND THAT'S WHY I
MENTIONED GENERAL PLANS AND
LOCAL COMMUNITY RIGHT IN IN
SOME OF THESE. YES THE PUBLIC
NEEDS TO READ THE ENVIRONMENTAL
DOCUMENTS LOOK AT THEIR GENERAL
PLAN JUST BECAUSE THE
ENVIRONMENTAL THE INITIAL STUDY
SAYS IS COMPLIANCE WITH THE
CITY'S GENERAL PLAN THAT DOES
NOT MEAN IT DOES. AND IF I MAY
WE'VE BEEN BATTLING THIS-
PROBLEM SINCE I WAS ELECTED SIX
YEARS AGO IN MY DISTRICT SENATE
DISTRICT TWENTY AND AS YOU
HEARD ME SAY WE HAVE MORE
WAREHOUSES IS INDUSTRY TWENTY
THAN ANY PLACE ELSE IN THE
COUNTRY. AND IT IS THIS IS A WE
CAN TRY AND WORK ON IT AT THE
STATE LEVEL WHICH WE DO OUR
INTERVIEWS BEST SB ONE THOUSAND
WHICH THE GOVERNOR SIGNED A
COUPLE YEARS AGO. ABOUT
ENVIRONMENTAL- JUSTICE IN- CITY
PLANS AND ON THE TRIP BIG BILL-
THE BIG RIG BILL THAT I TALKED
ABOUT NOW THE BIG RIGS HAVE TO
HAVE A SMOG CHECK THEY DIDN'T
HAVE TO EVER HAVE THAT BEFORE.
BUT THIS REALLY STARTS AT THE
CITY LEVEL AND I TALKED TO MANY
MANY MARES ABOUT WHY DO YOU
CONTINUE TO LET THESE
WAREHOUSES BE BUILT BECAUSE
THEY BRING IN TRAFFIC NOISE
POLLUTION AND USUALLY REALLY
BAD JOBS SO WE CAN DO STUFF AT
THE STATE LEVEL BUT WE NEED
PEOPLE AT YOUR CITY COUNCIL
MEETINGS WE NEED THAT COUNTIES
DOING THEIR JOB ON THIS. WE
CAN'T FIX IT ALL THE STATE
LEVEL AND SO MUCH CAN HAPPEN
FASTER AT THE CITY AND THE
COUNTY LEVEL BUT WE NEED
RESIDENTS LIKE YOU TO DO
EXACTLY WHAT YOU'RE DOING GO TO
MEETING SPEAK UP- WE HAVE DONE
SO MANY OF THESE IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE. AND I WOULD ALSO SAY
THIS WHO YOU ELECT MATTERS
WE'VE HAD MEMBERS OF ALL THE
COMMUNITY OF BLOOMINGTON WHO
HAVE HAD PETITIONS SIGNED WHO
HAVE HAD PEOPLE OUT IN FRONT OF
FOR AT THE MEETINGS AND STILL
THE- ON COUNTY BOARDS
SUPERVISORS CHOSE TO BUILD. A
WAREHOUSE RIGHT BY A SCHOOL AND
RIGHT ON BEHIND RESIDENTS SO
WHO YOU ELECT MATTERS BUT WE
WILL KEEP WORKING ON IT IS A
PASSION OF MINE. AND A PASSION
OF MINE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY
THANK YOU ALSO KNOW TOO THAT
THE- INLAND EMPIRE HAS A
CAUCUS. OF SENATORS AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SO IT'S
BICAMERAL- AND WE- MEET
PERIODICALLY TO ADDRESS ISSUES
THAT ARE IMPACTING ON OF THE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
REPRESENTED I REPRESENT UPLAND
OUR RECORD PORTION OF RANCHO
CUCAMONGA. AND SAN ANTONIO HI
SO I. GET A TWO TO BE A PART
THAT CAR BUT THE SAN. HAS YOU
POINT OUT A GOOD DEAL OF 90% OF
HER TO. OF NOW MORE AND INLAND
EMPIRE AND I'VE- THAT CAUCUSES
AROUND- ELEVEN TO SEVENTEEN
MEMBERS EITHER ABOUT. AND T.
NOW MAYBE SEVENTY SO I JUST
THROW THAT OUT BECAUSE ON SO OF
THESE ISSUES AS THE ONE THAT
WAS HAS PRESENTED- THERE'S
ANOTHER AVENUE FOR US TO SORT
OF WORK AND COLLABORATE
TOGETHER ON ISSUES OF
COMMONALITY SO- I JUST SO
THEREFORE- IN RESPONSE TO THE
QUESTION BUT LET ME JUST THANK
ALL OF YOU FOR BEING HERE AND
ALL OF YOU WHO ARE STATE- THIS
IS CERTAINLY- WE WANTED TO BE
INFORMATIVE WE WANTED TO TAKE-
SOME CURRENT ISSUES BUT ALSO
RECOGNIZE THERE SOME LONG TERM
PLANNING. THAT IS STILL UNDER
WAY THAT YOUR ORIGINAL AGENCIES
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
CONTINUED TOURING GROUP AND
BEST OUR TIME AND ENERGY
BEHIND- BUT THAT THE STATE IS
ALSO LOOKING TO BE A PARTNER IN
AS SENATOR LEYVA POINTED OUT WE
WANT TO CONTINUE TO BUILD OUR
RELATIONSHIP TO THE EXTENT THAT
WE ARE ADDRESSING ISSUES THAT
ARE OF MUTUAL CONCERN AND TO
THAT END- WE CAN FIND WE CAN
COLLABORATE AND FIND GOALS AND
RESOURCES TO HELP ADDRESS. ALL
OF THE DIFFERENT ISSUES THAT
WERE BROUGHT UP TODAY SO-
SENATOR IF YOU HAD- SOME
CLOSING THOUGHTS SO I WOULD
JUST SAY THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND MISTER CHAIR AND
THANK YOU TO EVERYONE WHO
PRESENTED AND STATE VERY
INFORMATIVE DAY. AND WE WILL
STILL STAY CONNECTED. PUN
INTENDED. THE.